Liebe Hörer, ich begrüße euch heute allein. No, keine Angst, Wolfgang ist gleich da. Nur noch wenige Sekunden. Aber die Angst ist trotzdem berechtigt, denn dieser Podcast ist gar nicht mal so gut, wenn ich hier alleine sitze. Wolfgang kommt gleich, dann ist es schon mal vollständig. Und richtig gut wird's, wenn noch 800 andere Leute da sind. Von daher, am 22. August, hier in Frankfurt, Saalbau Bornheim, machen wir unsere große Sommer-Salon-Show. Wir wissen natürlich noch nicht, auf welchen Themen könnte sein, dass bis dahin Elon Musk auf dem Mars gelandet ist. Das wird natürlich dann Top-Thema. Gestattet mir also hier noch mal kurz diesen Werbeblock, damit ihr die Blöcke füllt. Geht auf unsere Webseite neuezwanziger.de, da wo ihr auch alles sonst findet, was für diesen Podcast relevant ist. Dort gibt's Tickets für alle weiteren Live-Salons und vor allem für den Sommersalon im August. Und jetzt können wir den Podcast beginnen. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie bullish bist du schon?
Ich habe noch keine SpaceX-Aktion.
Das geht ja auch gar nicht.
Nein, noch nicht.
Denn die Preise sind noch nicht gefunden. Und wir greifen den Scherzen, die dazu zu machen, sind auch nicht vorweg.
Nein.
Wir hören nachher noch Clips dazu.
Aber du hast ja schon sehr verfolgt mit SpaceX jetzt, dass du sagst, das ist der Börsengang, auf den man blicken muss in diesem Jahr.
Also es ist der größte Börsengang der Geschichte und gleichzeitig der albernste. Und ich möchte anmerken, diesen einen Scherz kann man ja machen. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ich gründe mal schnell eine Firma für, keine Ahnung, Mausbewegung, ja, und du kaufst mir jetzt für 10 Cent 0,000000001% dieser Firma ab, dann bin ich im Buche Milliardär, weil damit ist die Marktkapitalisierung dann geregelt. Und so ist das bei SpaceX auch.
Was ja aber nicht jetzt ausschließt, dass ein erfolgreicher Börsengang zunächst einmal wird?
Es werden Aktien für grob 75 Milliarden verkauft. Das sind also dann weniger als 5 Prozent.
Mit anderen Worten, die Knappheit ist groß. Der Durst nach Aktien ist hoch.
Also die paar Leute wird es geben, die das Ding dann in der Marktkapitalisierung auf 2 Billionen treiben. Aber das ist halt genau der selbe Scherz, wie ich habe eine Firma für Mausbedienung.
Aber wir werden ja gleich darauf zu sprechen kommen. Es gibt ja dann auch immer wieder neue Aktienpakete für Elon Musk, wenn er Ziele erreicht. Also wenn er zum Beispiel die Besiedlung des Maus erreicht, dann bekommt er ein riesiges Aktienpaket als Bonus ausgezahlt. Ja, wir sind sehr gespannt darauf.
Wünsche ich viel Glück.
Bleiben wir noch ein bisschen auf der Erde. Wir wollen heute nicht so viel über Realpolitik sprechen, weil sie einen so anödet, dass ich sage, wozu. Ich bin erstaunt, wie die Podcaster und Talkshows das schaffen. Zum Teil zwei Sendungen am Tag dazu zu machen, weil ich über den Monat blicke, am Ende eines Monats, um zu schauen, was bringe ich jetzt hier mit. Und es stellt sich heraus, lassen wir das Größte weg. Nur hervorheben kann man, die Wirtschaftsweisen haben getagt, haben ihr Frühjahrsgutachten vorgelegt. Und eine alte Tradition wird wieder aufgegriffen, nämlich Achim Trugger hat ein Minderheitenvotum oder sogar zwei abgegeben. Das heißt, während der Wirtschaftsrat diesen neoliberalen Reformkurs einschlagen will mit Einsparungen, ist jetzt Achim Trugger der, der sich dem widersetzt. Was interessant ist, denn es gab ja in letzter Zeit nur noch ein Minderheitsvotum von Veronika Grimm zu verschiedenen Fragen. Und dann gab es ja eigentlich diese Einheit inklusive Achim Trugger. Das heißt also dieser Wirtschaftsrat in Fragen der Neoliberalisierung, um das jetzt mal ganz kurz auf den Punkt zu bringen. Da sehen wir jetzt, die Entwicklung geht weiter dorthin, also in die Richtung Friedrich Merz und Lars Klingbeil, während jetzt Trugger sich dem entgegengesetzt hat.
Ja, ich fand es auch sehr amüsant, dass Mik bei uns im Podcast, der sich ja sehr, also macht ja typischerweise bei sich neben der Spur stundenlange Monologe zum Thema Kongo oder so, bei der Frage, wie läuft es im Iran, drei Clips statt 30? Und einfach nur kommentarlos, ja, kann man spielen.
Ist halt, wie es ist.
Ja, wir sprechen aber dennoch heute über Drohnen und kommen darauf, den Iran zu sprechen. Und was ich auch anschneiden will, ist Israels Krieg gegen den Libanon. Zunächst aber, um ein bisschen diese ganze Friedrich-Merz-Debatte aufzugreifen, nur ein einziger Clip. Ich bin auch nur darauf aufmerksam geworden, weil sie selbst ihn nochmal geklippt hat und in den sozialen Medien geteilt hat. Jagoda Marinic war bei Maischberger zu Gast und ich will das hier paradigmatisch vorführen. Das ist eine Kommunikation, die kein Mensch benötigt. Warum? Weil es um Kommunikation geht. Wie spricht der Kanzler mit uns? Das sind ja die Fragen, die sich jetzt allabendlich in den Talkshows gestellt werden und tagsüber im Podcast. Wir hören uns das mal an, wie die Einschätzung von Jagoda Marinic ist.
Merz und es ist auch nicht gut. Muss man sich fragen, können die Deutschen sich einen Kanzler wählen, der ihnen gefällt? Muss man auch manchmal fragen. Ich glaube, Sie haben es ja schon gesagt. Was mich bei ihm überrascht ist, dass es eigentlich jemand ist, der aus der Wirtschaft kommt. Also eigentlich die Idee von Leadership, Kommunikation, Rhetorik groß sein müsste. Und da er jetzt Regierungschef ist und eigentlich der Kanzler der Deutschen.
Er kommt aus der Wirtschaft. Niemand weiß so genau, was er bei BlackRock gemacht hat. Aber er kommt aus der Wirtschaft. Er hat ja nicht ein Unternehmen aufgebaut und würde da jetzt irgendeinen Ausweis haben für Leadership. Also ja, der wird schon mal Leute rumkommandiert haben. Davon gehe ich aus, aber ist das Leadership?
Würde ich in der Krise empfehlen, eine Rhetorik anzubieten?
Jetzt Empfehlungen für den Kanzler. So funktionieren ja auch ein Großteil der Podcasts, die ich nicht mehr höre, aber du hin und wieder wirst ja auch mal abhängig. Immer Empfehlungen an den Kanzler, wie soll er sprechen? Ich sage jetzt schon mal ganz klar, ich finde gut, wie der Kanzler gerade spricht. Es wird nämlich alles sehr transparent. Also so, stelle ich mir vor, geht ein Friedrich Merz mit Gewerkschaftern um, auf dem Kirchentag oder wenn da eine schwerkranke Frau sitzt, dass er die noch mal zurecht weiß. Das ist exakt so, wie ich mir Friedrich Merz immer vorgestellt habe. Ich bekomme genau das. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, die Journalisten wollen eher so eingelullt werden. Bitte sprich mit uns als, sagst du, Merkel.
Ja, ja, also sie würde das natürlich nie akzeptieren, aber Marinic sagt jetzt dem Kanzler, sie gibt ihnen Empfehlungen zum nicht authentischen Kommunizieren.
Ja, wir hören zu.
Wo die Leute das Gefühl haben, er weiß, wo er hin will. Er weiß, was auf die Menschen zukommt. Er gibt irgendeine Zukunft, ja, vielleicht Prognose nicht, aber irgendeine Vision, eine Idee und sagt den Menschen, was auf sie zukommt. Und stattdessen hat man...
Macht er doch die ganze Zeit.
Also er sagt mir die ganze Zeit, was auf mich zukommt.
Arbeitet bis 70, arbeitet länger als acht Stunden am Tag. Sorgt selbst für euch vor, guckt, wie ihr das mit der Krankenkasse hinbekommt. Sagt er doch die ganze Zeit.
Ich hör auch nichts anderes.
Also ich muss das jetzt nicht noch in schöne Worte verpackt bekommen. Er sagt es ja ganz konkret.
Das Gefühl, er schimpft so von links nach rechts, je nachdem, wer eben gerade in die Quere kommt. Und dieses Friedrich-Merz-Motzt-Genre kommt eben nicht gut an. Friedrich-Merz-Motzt. Ja, das finde ich schon. Das können wir fast schon sagen. Es gibt ja immer wieder einen neuen Anlass, wo er gerade sagt, die sind zu faul, die tun zu wenig, die müssen mehr arbeiten. Und ich glaube nicht, dass Bürgerinnen und Bürger, die ja eigentlich der Souveränse in dem Staat Lust haben, ständig von ihrem Kanzler irgendwie angemotzt zu werden, nicht gut genug zu sein, nicht fleißig zu sein, Abstriche machen zu müssen. Ich glaube, dass er da eine Tonalität finden sollte, die mehr Vertrauen aufbaut, damit er die Menschen, wie es so schön heißt, einladen kann, durch die Krise besser durchzukommen, als wir es bisher tun. Und weniger gejammer, weniger Angst, weniger Zukunftsprobleme.
Es ist exakt, wie du sagst. Er soll bitte unauthentisch sprechen und soll den Leuten irgendwas vormachen. Er soll sie belügen.
Also ich finde es alles nicht gut, fühle mich schon wieder getriggert. Ich sehe in meiner Clip-Liste weitere Clips dazu später.
Ah ja, okay, dann bin ich gespannt.
Irgendjemand so langsam rein stolpert in dieses.
Wir kommen dann noch darauf zurück. Aber ich habe es extra mitgebracht, weil es so typisch ist, dass erst mal Journalisten glauben, sie müssten Regierungsberatung machen. Das ist ja schon das eine. Dann, dass sie sagen, wir müssen die Kommunikation ändern. Das heißt, es wird überhaupt nicht kritisiert, was Friedrich Merz fordert, sondern bitte nur, wie. Ja, wenn wir vielleicht den Leuten sagen, das ist eine tolle Chance, bis 70 zu arbeiten. Da schöpfst du auch nochmal ganz eigene Kraft. Dann kann man damit beim Kirchentag gut ankommen und vielleicht auch bei Georgoda Marinic. Also es ist der Wahnsinn, dass man eine uneigentliche Kommunikation sich wünscht.
Alles aus Solidarität. Länger arbeiten, früher sterben. Und bitte weniger in den Urlaub fahren, ja. Die heutige Episode wird präsentiert von Incogni. Das ist ein virtuelles, digitales, irgendwie unscheinbares Produkt, das ich aber aus eigener Anschauung empfehlen möchte. Ich bin nämlich selbst seit langem Kunde. Worum geht's? Wir alle hinterlassen im Internet Spuren, Namen, Adressen, Telefonnummern, Geburtsdaten. Das alles liegt dann irgendwo da draußen auf Seiten, von denen wir noch nie gehört haben. Und das ist nicht bloß unangenehm, sondern das ist ein echtes Sicherheitsrisiko. Identitätsdiebstahl, Betrugsversuche, Mahnungen für Verträge, die man nie abgeschlossen hat, Konten, die in deinem Namen eröffnet werden. Das passiert Leuten, die denken, ihnen kann das nicht passieren. Und es fängt fast immer damit an, dass persönliche Daten frei verfügbar im Netz herumliegen. Und jetzt ist ja so. Die Datenschutzgrundverordnung nervt uns alle im Alltag ein wenig. Wir klicken endlos Cookie-Banner hier, Einwilligungsdialoge da. Aber sie hat uns ein wichtiges Recht gegeben, dass die meisten von uns nie nutzen, das Recht auf vergessen werden. Wir haben einen rechtlichen Anspruch darauf, dass die eigenen Daten aus dem Netz entfernt werden. Das Problem ist nur, diesen Anspruch selbst durchzusetzen bei Dutzenden oder Hunderten von Seiten. Das ist kompliziert. Incogni schickt mir, also monatlich, Berichte, aus welchen Datenbanken ich wieder gelöscht wurde. Deren Namen habe ich, so wie sie mir aufgezählt werden, alle noch nie gehört und ihr kennt sie sicherlich auch nicht. Und genau da hilft euch Incogni. Incogni kennt die dunkle Seite des Netzes und setzt dein Recht dort für dich durch. Man bekommt also regelmäßig Updates. Hier wurde etwas entfernt, dort läuft ein Auftrag auf Löschung. Und was ich besonders gut finde, ist das Feature Custom Removal. Man kann neben den großen Datenbanken, die dort automatisch gelistet sind, nämlich noch ganz gezielt bestimmte Seiten angeben, auf denen man seine eigenen Informationen gefunden hat und von denen man runter will.
Also, die DSGVO gibt dir das Recht und Incogni sorgt dafür, dass es auch tatsächlich passiert. Wenn ihr das ausprobieren wollt, geht auf incogni.com 20er und gebt den Code 20er ein. Damit bekommt ihr 60% Rabatt auf den Jahrestarif. Nochmal in incogni.com 20er Code 20er. Der Link ist auch in der Episodenbeschreibung.
So, ich überfalle dich und unsere Hörer jetzt mit einem Thema. Es verwundert nicht.
Nein.
Du bist ja schon mal aus einer Kirche ausgetreten. Ja. Wahrscheinlich aus der falschen auch noch.
Wie, aus der evangelischen hab ich ausgetreten.
Sehr gut. Ich war, ich weiß nicht, warst du schon mal im Petersdom?
Nein.
Okay. Also ich war als erstes Mal im Petersdom letzte Woche. Es war sehr beeindruckend. Man könnte jetzt unendlich viele Worte darüber verlieren, aber die Gespräche laufen ungefähr so, dass man dort mit, also es sind ja so viele Führungen, dass man einfach wahllos jemanden zugeteilt bekommt. Und in meinem Falle hieß er Lorenzo, ein sehr guter Typ. Falls jemanden Führer durch Rom, speziell Petersdom, Vatikan usw. kennt, der Lorenzo heißt, seit 30 Jahren in Rom lebt, meldet euch doch mal bei mir, weil ich bin mit ihm lose verabredet und dachte, ich kriege den Kontakt über, bitte bewerten sie die Führung, aber die werden verstecken natürlich, wer die Führung gemacht hat, man soll nur noch die Institution bewerten und so. Jedenfalls, man steht so da und jeder ist beeindruckt vom Gebäude, aber gleichzeitig wird es immer wieder eingefangen. Also Kindesmissbrauch spielt durchaus eine Rolle, wenn man mit Lorenzo eine Stunde lang am Petersdom ansteht, weil um das Thema kommt man ja nicht herum. Dann wird halt auch dazu gesagt, wie die Kirche damit umgeht. Diese ganzen Herrlichkeiten, wir kommen gleich auf Verfehlung der Kirche, die der Papst selbst eingesteht, zu sprechen und so weiter. Also ich will jetzt nicht einfach verherrlichen, wenn ich die Enzyklika durchgehe. Und ich wurde ja auch immer wieder gefragt, jetzt, nachdem ich Fotos aus dem Petersturm schickte, wann ich mich taufen lasse und ich sage natürlich gar nicht. Denn mich interessiert die Kirche, ich wiederhol's deswegen nochmal, als historisches Relikt. Also es gibt auch Relikt, wenn, das weiß ich. Leute brauchen dann den Glauben dafür. Das ist mir ziemlich egal. Ich bin noch nicht sehr biblfest.
Relikt bedeutet aber eigentlich, dass es schon passé ist, während wir jetzt einen Enzyklika haben, die ja sehr gegenwärtig auftritt.
Ja, und das ist eben das Tolle. Ich dachte, ich interessiere mich wie die Kirche, weil sie eben Relikte da hat. Also ich habe zwei nochmal, möchte ich kurz nennen. Ich habe sie schon ein paar Mal genannt, die Frankfurter Silberinschrift. Sie liegt seit ungefähr zwei Jahren hier im Archäologischen Museum in Frankfurt. 3,5 Zentimeter lang, also ein kleines Silberblättchen, eingerollt. Man hat es noch nicht entfaltet, aber Computertomografen und so weiter konnte man entziffern, was drauf steht. Es ist das erste Zeugnis reinen Christentums nördlicher Alpen hier im Frankfurter Gebiet gefunden. Das ist also dieser historische Teil, der mich interessiert. Plus im Städtl steht seit kurzem, aber es war eine 100-jährige Anwerbe- und Ankauf-Geschichte, aber jetzt hat es geklappt, eine Marienfigur aus dem 14. Jahrhundert. Eine der allerersten Altarfiguren, die dauerhaft stehen blieb. Also tausend Jahre, nachdem hier überhaupt Christentum stattfand als obskurer Kult irgendwo, man konnte gerade so eine schriftliche Notiz hinterlassen, hat man halt gesagt, okay, wir stellen jetzt das Zeug, was wir für die christliche Messe brauchen, auf den Tisch und danach räumen wir es nicht wieder ab. Wir verwenden den Tisch jetzt nicht weiter auch zum Essen, sondern der bleibt jetzt dauerhaft als und dann Altarwahn geboren. So, solche Sachen gibt's zu sehen. Und Viertes Jahrhundert, Viertes Jahrhundert, jetzt sind wir schon in den 2000er Jahren. Das ist das Beeindruckende. Ich lasse mich aber sehr gerne von Lorenzo, der selber nicht nur atheistisch, sondern auch mit so der, und das finde ich eben wahnsinnig interessant, deswegen würde mich interessieren, wie bei anderen so die Führung in Rom ablaufen. Alle Leute haben was zur Kirche zu sagen und es ist nicht reine Affirmation. Also die Kirche hat genug im Gepäck, was sich in einer Drei-Stunden-Führung einfach thematisieren lässt. Aber dann steht man im Petersdom und dann wird einfach erklärt, ja da oben, das sind gar keine Gemälde, sondern das sind Moserike. Warum? Weil die Kirche vor 500 Jahren die Entscheidung getroffen hat, wir investieren jetzt mal in die Ewigkeit. Ja, so und dann sieht man diesen ganzen Völle-Fanz da und also es ist wirklich nichts beeindruckender als das. Die nächste Reise, Petersdom. Gut, für alle.
Ich komme dann mit.
Genau.
So, jetzt haben wir aber es mit einer Enzyklika zu tun, die sich ins Tagesgeschäft einmischt, die sich auch in die Historie stellt, die ja einen sehr langen Anlauf nimmt, um dann in den gegenwärtigen Fragen anzukommen. Was ich vorab sagen möchte, ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass eine Enzyklika so viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat in den vergangenen 20 Jahren. Das ist mir nicht bekannt. Es gibt immer wieder Diskussionen interne, manchmal gab es auch einzelne Stellen, die wurden vielleicht skandalisiert oder die wurden zumindest heftig debattiert. Aber dass plötzlich in den sozialen Medien zum Beispiel diese Enzyklika aufgegriffen zitiert wird, dass man also ihr begegnet, ohne dass man sich direkt hinsetzt und sagt, ich lese das jetzt, ist erstaunlich, das hat es so nicht gegeben. Es liegt selbstverständlich an dem Thema Digitalisierung, KI, vor allem ein bisschen soziale Medien und ich glaube auch, weil es so ein Kontrapunkt ist zu all dem, was wir jetzt gerade sonst von überall hören, ob es von Friedrich Merz, Donald Trump, Sam Altman oder sonst wem ist. Das ist wirklich das, was den Papst jetzt in dieser Weise populär macht, wie man das lange nicht erlebt hat. Denn die Päpste zuvor, also auch jemand wie Johannes Paul II hat ja inhaltlich eher junge Leute abgeschreckt, konnte dann vielleicht bewegen als charismatische Figur oder so. Aber niemand hat mit der Sexualmoral in zumindest der westlichen Welt etwas anfangen können, die Johannes Paul II vertreten hat oder so. Aber diese Einmischung jetzt in diese KI-Fragen sind wirklich ein großer Wurf, würde ich mal behaupten.
Was bedeutet? Man sieht den Vatikan, betritt ihn, wie ich, mit historischem Interesse und stellt fest Amtssitz. Also das ist zwar alles historisch aufgeladen, aber es ist halt auch total gegenwärtig. Diese Enzyklika geht hier auf 1800 Jahre Kirchengeschichte ein, um große Entschuldigungen auszusprechen. Also man sieht, hier werden einfach andere Bögen geschlagen. Was jetzt bedeutet, wenn wir jetzt in diese Enzyklika reingehen, wir werden sie in Detail uns vergegenwärtigen, kann man jetzt verschiedene Einflugschneisen dazu oder auch noch mehr wählen. Wir haben zum Beispiel eine Einladung zu einem Podcast, der wir nachgegangen sind, weil wir sie interessant fanden, bei der so die Frage ist, die Neuen Zwanziger, welches Jahrhundert eigentlich. So, diese Enzyklika kann man auch als Warnung lesen, aus einer zehnjährigen oder 100-jährigen Zukunft. So, wir können sie auch als politisches Werk lesen, das uns mal die Grundbegriffe klarzieht. Was ist eigentlich KI? Was ist sie nicht? Es steht genauso als Zwischenüberschrift drin. Was ist KI, was ist sie nicht? So ungefähr. So, also es gibt jetzt ganz viele Einflugsneisen in diesen Text, der sich wie viele Enzykliker, aber noch nicht seit sehr langem, an alle Frauen und Männerguten Willens richtet. Das heißt, ich bin auch gemeint.
Du bist auch gemeint, man muss nicht getauft sein.
Wir sind alle gemeint, genau. Es gab lange Jahrhunderte, wo es klar war, das ist nur an den Klerus. So, dann hat man irgendwann die Gläubigen mit reingenommen. Und es ist noch nicht so lange her, also 1963 gab es die erste Enzyklika. Damals kurz nach der Kuba-Krise und so, wo der Papst mal meinte, okay, jetzt wenden wir uns mal in die ganze Welt, denn Atomwaffen und so weiter, das ist alles wahnsinnig gefährlich. Die Wahrheitssuchenden, also damit sind wir auch gemeint, wertvolle Verbündete. Die Sozial- und Geisteswissenschaftler leisten einen wesentlichen Beitrag. Wieder bin ich gemeint. Also fast denke ich, ich bin mehr gemeint als irgendein Kardinal oder so, ja? Der so am Ende seines Lebens. Damals 63, Frieden auf Erden, Atomwaffe, heute KI. Er bezieht diese Begrüßungsfloskeln auf diese. Da würde ich auch sagen, diesen Bogenschlag aus Atomwaffe und KI kennen wir schon. Das hat uns Nolan mit dem Oppenheimer vorgestellt und so weiter. Trotzdem ganz interessant. Also Johannes der 23. schreibt also im Angesicht der Kuba-Krise erstmals an alle und macht gleichzeitig ein Hinweis auf die allgemein erklärten Menschenrechte, die dort nämlich als Meilensteine des moralischen Fortschritts gewürdigt werden, nachdem die Kirche das lange anders sah. Also angesichts einer globalen Bedrohung wie durch Atomwaffen ändert sich auch der Blick einer Kirche hier wieder. Und in dem Maße muss man dann auch verstehen, wenn der jetzige Papst sagt, KI muss entwaffnet werden. Was meint das eigentlich? Weil bei Atomkraft haben wir es auch mit Dual-U's zu tun. Also wir haben Atomkraftwerke und Atomwaffen. Und damals war völlig klar, wie man sich dazu verhalten kann. Schon alleine, weil die Atomwaffe oder die Atomkraft jetzt nichts ist, was man in seinem Büro betreibt oder so. Das ist ja diesmal anders. Von daher ist dieser Entwaffnungsgedanke noch mal entgrenzter als damals schon.
Darf ich die Passage gerade vorlesen mit der Entwaffnung? Schließlich möchte ich einen Begriff benutzen, der mir am Herzen liegt. Entwaffnen. KI zu entwaffnen bedeutet, sie der Logik des bewaffneten Wettbewerbs zu entziehen, der heute nicht mehr nur militärischer, sondern auch wirtschaftlicher und kognitiver Natur ist. Bei diesem Wettrennen geht es um den leistungsfähigsten Algorithmus und die größte Datenbank, um einen geopolitischen oder kommerziellen Vorsprung gegenüber allen anderen zu festigen. Entwaffnen bedeutet, diese Gleichsetzung von technischer Macht und dem Recht zu herrschen aufzubrechen. Entwaffnen bedeutet nicht, auf die Technologie zu verzichten, sondern zu verhindern, dass sie den Menschen beherrscht. Wir werden heute über Drohnen reden. Da sehen wir, wie diese Bewaffnung stattfindet. Wir sehen aber auch, wenn er hier das Kompetitivere anspricht, wie geht man mit dem Algorithmus um, wie unterwirft man sich eben. Auch darüber werden wir heute sprechen, wenn es um die Clip-Economy geht.
Genau. Und deswegen hier auch nochmal der Verweis auf 1963, den Leo ganz deutlich macht. Es gibt keine gerechten Kriege. Also wenn auch deutsche Katholiken oder Evangelier oder wer immer Texte schreibt zum Thema gerechte Kriege, sagt Leo hier schon mal, Vorsicht, Krieg heißt demnächst, da ist ein kleines Ding, das fliegt in dein geöffnetes Zimmer rein und alles explodiert. Wer da noch irgendwo eine Gerechtigkeit sieht, ist nicht. Also diese Fundierung einfach von Anfang an in diesem Text, bevor man jetzt reingeht, ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr deutlich. Damals die 63er, also die von 1963, ein paar Monate nach der Kuba-Krise, unterschied damals zwischen dem Irrtum und dem Irrenden und hat diese Gnade Gottes nochmal allen wieder zur Verfügung gestellt. Also der Mensch kann irren, aber er kann ja auch bekehrt werden, was damals bedeutete, dass er auch Kruschtjow den Text lesen ließ, dass es auch öffentlich kund gab und man überhaupt mal wieder eine gemeinsame Ebene gefunden hat. Solche Angebote sind hier auch wieder drin. Kruschtjow sitzt nicht am Tisch so, aber Anthropic sitzt mit am Tisch. Und zwar nicht nur als Zaungast und darf mit ins Auditorium, sondern trägt vorne mit vor, ist ein Mitsprecher des Enzyklikatexes. Also das sind alles...
Also ein bisschen heikeles.
Was sehr heikel ist?
Weil Anthropic ja nicht eine weiße Weste hat. Auch wenn die sich jetzt gerade so darstellen. Wir kommen auch dazu nach.
Die Kirche auch nicht. Niemand hat hier eine weiße Weste, aber man versucht den Text gerade zu ziehen. Das ist ja eigentlich nicht schlecht. So, deswegen beginnen wir auch mal mit Christopher Ola, der nämlich, und das würde ich jetzt sagen, so ist es dann auch gemeint, der Text wurde veröffentlicht zu dem Zeitpunkt, als die diese Vorstellung machten. Das heißt, für die große Öffentlichkeit ist jetzt der Takt, erst hört man die Veröffentlichung mit den Sprechern, waren ja auch Wissenschaftler dabei, und danach liest man den Text. Genauso machen wir das jetzt ja auch.
Jedes führende KI-Labor, einschließlich Anthropic, arbeitet innerhalb eines Rahmens aus Anreizen und Zwängen, die manchmal im Widerspruch dazustehen können, das Richtige zu tun. Der Druck, wirtschaftlich rentabel zu bleiben und an der Spitze der Forschung zu stehen. Geopolitischer Druck. Und die älteren, offensichtlichen Triebkräfte wie Stolz und Gehrgeiz. Ganz gleich wie aufrichtig jeder von uns beabsichtigt, das Richtige zu tun, und ich glaube, viele von uns tun das, wir werden immer von diesen Anreizen beeinflusst sein. Deshalb ist es, wenn wir wollen, dass diese Technologie zum Guten führt, enorm wichtig, dass es Menschen außerhalb dieser Anreize gibt. Menschen, denen daran liegt, dass alles gut läuft, die genau hinschauen, die bereit sind, schwierige Dinge anzusprechen, die bereit sind, unsere ernsthaften, nachdenklichen Kritiker zu sein. Durch Dialog und gemeinsame Anstrengungen, durch das Geben und Nehmen, wird die Menschheit Großes erreichen. And that is what I see in Manifigas Humanitas. Und deshalb bin ich seiner Heiligkeit und der Kirche dankbar, dass sie diese Arbeit der Unterscheidung in Angriff genommen haben.
Kanntest du vorher Christopher Roller von Anthropik? Nein. Oder? Der taucht jetzt so plötzlich auf. Ist einer der Mitgründer. Wie hoch da sein Anteil ist, keine Ahnung. Was ja erstaunlich ist, ist, dass der Papst sich ihn direkt zur Seite nimmt. Und sagt, wir treten da gemeinsam auf. Wo ja wir heute diesen Konflikt haben mit Anthropik gegen Trump. Aber dadurch natürlich auch Anthropik wahnsinnig gutes Marketing betreiben kann. Also so die besseren zu sein, die guten zu sein im Vergleich zu Sam Altman. Und im Vergleich zu Sam Altman direkt mag das ja auch stimmen. Aber wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel ansieht, dass die in diesem Monat neben dem Papst sitzen, um für Ethik zu plädieren und zugleich eine gigantische Kooperation mit Elon Musk eingegangen sind, um an Geld zu gelangen, um an Server-Kapazitäten zu gelangen, sehen wir ja schon, wohin das läuft. Denn wir wissen, dass Anthropik ja durchaus mit der Bewaffnung kein Problem hat von KI, sondern nur in gewissen Positionen offenbar nicht. Wenn man in der Kur geht mit Donald Trump, sehen wir ja, dass eigentlich Anthropik im hohen Maße Teil des Problems ist.
Absolut. Man muss ja so sehen, das, was er hier gerade vorstellte, also zu sagen, ja, wir können uns nicht ganz frei machen, von Anreizen beeinflusst zu werden, die nicht in die Richtung führen, von der wir heute schon sagen können, das ist dann für alle das Richtige. So, das ist die Idee des Katholizismus. Es gibt Menschen und ja, sie brauchen eine Kirche. Sonst verirren sie sich alle und bauen hier den Turm zu Babel, wie der Papst jetzt sagt oder was auch immer. Also der Weg führt typischerweise ins Verderben, es sei denn man orientiert sich ein bisschen. Orientiert im Sinne von. So, und sowas haben wir zumindest im Social Media Zeitalter nicht erlebt. Also sowohl die Sprechersituation als auch den Text. Also Mark Zuckerberg hat nie gesagt, im Grunde geht es mir um Profit. Und ich weiß auch, dass alle meine Mitarbeiter im Grunde nur auf ihr Aktienportfolio schielen und dass unser IPO jetzt ganz wichtig ist und so. Also wie er das jetzt sagt. Aber tatsächlich wollen wir ja die Welt und so weiter. Jeder soll seine Community finden und glücklich werden. Also genau das ist ja gerade nicht, was wir von Mark Zuckerberg oder von, wie hießen sie hier, von Twitter und so weiter.
Genau, die haben immer gesagt, hier ist die tolle Möglichkeit mit euren Freunden in Kontakt zu treten. Familiemitglieder, die man lange nicht gesehen hat, wieder zu kontaktieren. Anders.
Das war einfach alles immer Lüge. Das ist halt hier ein bisschen anders. Es ist ja auch keine Pressekonferenz. Man darf jetzt ohne Nachfrage stellen, sondern es wird halt einfach deklariert, was Sache ist. Ein wichtiger Punkt, den habe ich das letzte Mal auch schon hervorgehoben. Der Papst macht es auch ganz deutlich. Aber in Sachen Definition von KI und was man daraus ableiten muss, ist Ola hier sehr ehrlich.
Manche mögen glauben, dass Fragen der KI am besten von Informatikern wie mir behandelt werden. Sie ehren sich. Die Fragen, die die KI aufwirft, sind größer als die KI-Forschungsgemeinschaft, nicht nur in ihren Auswirkungen, sondern auch in ihrem Wesen. KI-Systeme werden nicht so konstruiert wie eine Brücke oder ein Flugzeug. Wir verstehen ein Flugzeug, weil wir jeden Teil davon entworfen haben. Und die physikalischen Kräfte verstehen, die auf es einwirken. KI-Modelle sind nicht so. Sie wachsen auf einer Struktur, die dem Gehirn nachempfunden ist. Auf einem enormen Erbe menschlichen Denkensunprechens. Was gewachsen ist, ist weitaus subtiler, seltsamer und schöner, als uns die Science-Fiction darauf vorbereitet hat. Es sind nicht die kalten, berechneten Roboter, die uns versprochen wurden, sie sind aus uns gemacht. Aus unseren Worten und, wie der Heilige Vater bemerkt, bleiben sie in wichtiger Hinsicht selbst für diejenigen von uns, die sie trainieren, geheimnisvoll.
So, also diese Idee von der Unterscheidung einer Entwicklung und einer Entdeckung. Oder wie er es hier sagt und wie es der Papst ja auch schreibt, hier wird nichts entwickelt oder gebaut, sondern hier wird gezüchtet. Man schafft ein Biotop und dann passieren Dinge. Ja. Und dass man da zum Vatikan geht, um sich Hilfe zu holen, verstehe ich sofort. Insbesondere, wenn er anfügt, das, was da entsteht, ist irgendwie aus uns gemacht, also hat einen Bezug zu uns. Das, würde ich sagen, ist eine ganz große Leerstelle, nämlich dass einfach der größte Raubzug der Menschheit gegen die Menschheit stattfand. Und diese Leute da einfach unsere ganzen Ideen einmal staubsaugermäßig abgesaugt haben, um dann irgendwas zu züchten. Aber das ist vielleicht auch eine zuwirtschaftliche Frage für den Vatikanen und Anthropic, wie auch immer.
Für Anthropic wahrscheinlich nicht, aber für den Vatikanen.
Ja, Anthropic, also wenn man jetzt ein Geschäftsmodell draus machte und wir alle hätten unseren Skin in the game. Und Anthropic müsste mir jetzt für meine drei Bücher, die sie damit ins Trainingsmaterial geworfen haben, nochmal 150 Euro zahlen. Würde es sich alles nicht lohnen.
Genau, deswegen müssen sie es rauben. Anders geht es nicht.
Und da hat der Papst auch so ein bisschen drüber hinweg geschaut.
Ja, richtig. Das ist das Interessante. Also was ich mich ja frage ist, du hast ja eben das zurecht gesagt, wir haben solche Auftritte nicht erlebt während der großen Social-Media-Ära mit Twitter, Instagram und Co.
Die übrigens noch viel näher thematisch an Vatikan-Themen, Beziehung, Liebe, Sozialisation und so weiter dran sind.
Freundschaft, all diese Dinge. Ja, da haben wir das interessanterweise nicht erlebt. Der Diskurs hat sich aber im ganzen Jahr geändert. Also ich bekomme permanent bei Instagram irgendwelche Videos gezeigt, in denen Menschen vor AI warnen. Und alle, die ich nicht angezeigt bekomme, schickt mir jemand zu. So, das heißt, wir sind da doch sowieso gerade in einer Situation, wo wir erleben, dass auch die Tech-Konzerne selbst die ganze Zeit warnen. Wir haben diese Ideen von, wir brauchen ein Moratorium. Wir haben so Leute wie Nick Bostrom, die schon seit 20 Jahren damit hausieren gehen, dass wir aufpassen müssen, dass die AIs uns nicht in Büroklammern verwandeln und das. Das heißt, ich frage mich dann immer, ist das eine erneute Sensibilität? Ich glaube, nein. Ich würde eher sagen, es ist eine neue Strategie, um mit regieren zu können, beziehungsweise um die eigene Macht ausbauen zu können. Also man kann nicht mit dem Diskurs in AI eingehen, wie bei Instagram und sagen, es ist total toll, halte deine Erinnerungen fest und teile sie mit Freunden. Ja, also das funktioniert da. Und damit konnte man auch sehr viele Leute locken oder auch Politiker vor allem beschwichtigen, dass man sagt, na ja, da werden ja einfach nur Fotos hochgeladen. Dass wir aber jetzt bei der AI sagen, es ist einfach toll, es hilft dir ein bisschen bei den Hausaufgaben, würde nicht ausreichen. Von daher muss, glaube ich, dieser ernst zu nehmende Diskurs jetzt hinzukommen. Und die Frage wird dann sein, für wen ist es Marketing und für wen ist es jetzt ein ernstes Anliegen? Bei Papst ist es ein ernstes Anliegen, bei Anthropic, ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Also das Problem hier ist, dass die Gemengelage viel zu komplex ist. Es ist also so viel mehr und anderes denkbar, wie z.B. Anthropic hat jetzt dieses Mythos-Modell seit ein paar Monaten. Das veröffentlichen sie nicht.
Ja.
So, es ist eine krasse enorme Gefahr, auch darin, wenn man jetzt sieht, okay, also das Weiße Haus richtet jetzt den nächsten KI-Panel irgendwas ein, mit Bondi, die plötzlich wieder da ist und der David Sacks darf auch wieder eine Rolle spielen und so. Und die haben aber dann Zugriff auf Mythos und ich nicht. Das ist eine Gefahr. Jetzt haben wir es hier mit der Sachlage zu tun, dass wir schon wissen, worum es geht, weil wir die KIER selbst benutzen dürfen. Und die Unternehmen selber einen erheblichen Reflektionsbedarf haben, was bedeutet, sie müssen es als Produkt veröffentlichen. Dadurch kommen sie in eine Konkurrenzsituation, die sie in diesen Wettkampf reinbringt, bei dem der Papst wieder warnt. Gleichzeitig ist das aber nicht dieses Obskure, ja, die NSA hat da so ein Riesending und hätte es Snowden nicht gegeben, hätte es keiner gemerkt. Also wir haben völlig durcheinander.
Du musstest mit dem Mythos nochmal gerade erklären, weil ich glaube nicht, dass das alle mitbekommen haben, was da passiert ist. Also Mythos ist eine neue Stufe, auf die man es gebracht hat, die man aber nicht den Endkunden zur Verfügung stellen kann, ohne weiteres aufgrund von Sicherheitsbedenken. Also jetzt mal ganz grob gefasst, nehmen wir an, man hätte einen Mixer hergestellt, aber der würde zugleich auch als Schusswaffe funktionieren, das kann man dir nicht einfach in den freien Verkauf geben. Offenbar scheint so etwas zu sein, wir können ja auch immer nur glauben, was uns dann da gesagt wurde, und dass sozusagen jetzt die Regierung zunächst absegnet, was kann veröffentlicht werden und was muss unter Verschluss bleiben. Was ja dann bedeutet, die Konzerne, heute die Tech-Konzerne, müssen wohl oder übel mit den Regierungen, mit dem Staat USA, darum geht es ja hier, direkt zusammenarbeiten, während man vorher bei dem Consumer-Internet mit all den tollen Apps ja einfach sagte, wir müssen sehen, dass die Politiker nicht auf Ideen kommen mit Regulierungen. Und am Ende denken die noch über Arbeitszeit und Arbeitsrecht nach, wir machen mal so eine Uber-App, das wird schon funktionieren. Da muss man die Politik raushalten oder so ein bisschen schmieren. Jetzt aber geht kein Schritt mehr vorbei, daran, dass man im Weißen Haus quasi gemeinsam das machen muss. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass wir also eine direkte Verflechtung haben von Regierung bzw. Staat und der freien Wirtschaft, die in dem Sinne dann nicht frei ist, weil sie ja gar nicht frei agieren kann. Dabei so sagen wir lassen jetzt dieses Tool los, denn die Angst ist ja zum Beispiel bei Mythos, dass das so gut code knacken kann, dass einfach die Infrastruktur so sehr gehackt werden könnte, dass alles zusammen bricht.
Ja, also das ist jetzt so bei Anthropic. Also wer noch nie von Claude Mythos gehört hat, Mithos, der muss das jetzt googeln. Also das ist gar nicht zu rechtfertigen, wenn man das noch nicht kennt. So, bei Anthropic ist so, die veröffentlichen Modelle, das kennen wir ja alle, die veröffentlichen halt so Modelle. Und Anthropic hat eine sehr interessante Namensgebung. Die kleinen Modelle, die für einfachste Tätigkeiten da sind, heißen Haiku, also wie dieser Dreizeiler aus Japan. Dann kommt das Sonnet, also schon ein bisschen Gedicht und poetisch. Dann kommt Opus, große Fragestellung. Das können wir sozusagen benutzen. Wir können jetzt entscheiden, muss ich noch kurz ein Wort übersetzen, nehme ich Haiku, muss ich mir eine Agenda schreiben für morgen, ist es so nett oder will ich jetzt hier Podcasts vorbereiten oder was auch immer? Dann ist Opus. Und dann kam Anthropic und meinte, wir haben jetzt auch Mythos, also es geht weit darüber hinaus. Die Frage ist jetzt aber, was ist das überhaupt? Die sind ja sehr auf dieses Coden gegangen. Und da ist es halt auch immer eine Fleiß-Sache. Es ist nicht nur Intelligenz, sondern da ist es auch wirklich, liest den ganzen Code und jetzt erste Variante, zweite Variante, dritte Variante, vierte Variante, alles muss durchgeackert werden, bringt das nochmal mit dieser Funktion in Verbindung und so weiter.
Denn diese Codes können Bugs enthalten, die am Ende die Schwachstellen sind, mit denen man sich in Systeme hacken kann.
Aber manchmal muss man halt einen Fehler, wo man so denkt, na gut, den kann man übersehen, kombinieren mit einem anderen und dann verkettet man die so und plötzlich ist man bei der NSA eingebrochen, wie ihr ist in Hand oder sowas.
Und das ist fleiß, das ist Rechenleistung.
Das ist Rechenleistung, das ist fleiß und das kann Mythos. Was eben bedeutet, die können das gar nicht einfach so veröffentlichen, weil Mythos angehalten ist, ein Ding nach dem anderen da durchzuhauen, bis man nach einer Million Versuchen irgendwas gefunden hat. So, also das nützt mir in meinem Alltag nicht, dir auch nicht, niemanden, aber diesen Sicherheitsarchitekten, die jetzt irgendwas mit Software machen, den schon.
Es würde auch einigen Konzernen weiterhelfen.
Die kriegen auch Zugriff drauf.
Aber nur manche.
Also nur amerikanische und man muss denen auch gleichzeitig hunderte Millionen an Tokenbudget mitgeben, weil selbst wenn die drauf Zugriff haben und dann sagt Entropiq, ja, also wenn ihr jetzt diesen Prompt abschickt, kostet sieben Millionen Euro und dann sagen die, den mache ich nicht. Also es wird gerade nicht sehr nach marktwirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten Rechenzeit verbraten in der Hoffnung, dass irgendeine Kombination aus dieser Fleißarbeit mal zu irgendwas führt.
Was aber die US-Hegemonie in doch erheblichem Maße verstärkt, weil die europäischen Konzerne, die es ja auch gibt, die durchaus ja Interesse daran hätten, zu schauen, was wäre mit diesem Mysos-Modell zu prüfen, wo sind bei uns die Schwachstellen, dass die dem erstmal heillos ausgeliefert sind und hoffen können, dass auch sie ein Stück vom Kuchen abhaben können, beziehungsweise dass sie mit an den Tisch dürfen und dass sie auch ihre Sicherheitsbedenken mit Anthropik klären können. Und wenn sie das nicht können, daran sehen wir auch diese ganzen, also was so auf der EU-Ebene läuft, kommt ja ständig irgendwas mit neuen Strafen, werden verhängt an irgendwelche Konzerne. Man ist so vorsichtig gerade bei der EU, diese wirklich zu verhängen und diese Millionen einzufordern. Schon deshalb, weil wenn man sich dort Washington so sehr verkrault, dass man keinen Zugriff mehr hat auf diese Modelle, die mal existenziell wichtig sein könnten für die kritische Infrastruktur, dann hat man einfach ausgespielt.
Ja, und deswegen gehen wir in diese Enzyklikereien, weil hier diese Paradigmenwechsel, dass es nicht mehr darum geht, was irgendwo die Regierung macht, sondern das, was Konzerne machen. Und dass es auch nicht mehr nach marktwirtschaftlicher Logik einfach erklärbar ist.
Ich würde sagen, das ist genau der Zusammenschluss jetzt gerade von Regierung und Konzern.
Ja, aber das ist eben was Neues. Das ist eben was ganz Neues als das, was wir bisher hatten. Kolonialismus, auch von Entropiq selbst angesprochen.
Ich möchte drei Fragen nennen, bei denen meiner Meinung…
Ich möchte drei Fragen an den Vatikanen stellen, bei denen wir nicht weiterkommen. Also das ist auch eine super Einleitung.
Ich möchte drei Fragen nennen, bei denen meiner Meinung nach die Stimme der Kirche am dringendsten gebraucht wird. Die erste ist unsere Pflicht gegenüber den Armen weltweit. Es besteht die reale Möglichkeit, dass KI menschliche Arbeitskraft in sehr großem Umfang verdrängern wird. Wenn das geschieht, wird die Unterstützung der Verdrängten eine moralische Verpflichtung von historischem Ausmaß sein. Diese Aufgabe wird schon schwierig genug sein, aber ich befürchte, dass die meisten Diskussionen eine noch größere Herausforderung übersehen. Die KI-Entwicklung konzentriert sich auf eine Handvoll wohlhabender Nationen. Wie können wir sicherstellen, dass die Vorteile der KI weltweit geteilt werden? Wir haben keinen Mechanismus dafür. Es ist ein ungelöstes Problem. Und es ist die Art von Problem, bei der die Kirche es historisch gesehen abgelehnt hat, es die Welt ignorieren zu lassen.
So, hier auch ein Parathekmenwechsel, der vom Vatikan beim Thema Arbeit ein bisschen zu sehr in dieser Kirchensprache zum Thema Arbeit und Würde und ein bisschen zu wenig in dieser Weltlichen, aber man kann es zumindest ausinterpretieren. Diese Art von Kolonialismus, die wir schon mal kannten, Ausbeutung und so weiter, hat sehr viel mit westliche Welt, dritte Welt, wie auch immer, zu tun. Das ist ja jetzt schon ganz anders. Und für sehr viele in Deutschland ist es auch noch nicht so richtig nachvollziehbar. Die freuen sich, weil sie selber KI ablehnen darüber, dass Eric Schmidt ausgeboot wird, wenn er eine KI-Abschlussrede erhält. So, würde man aber diesen Leuten, die da gerade einen Abschluss machen, sagen, ja genau, Eric Schmidt ist voll scheiße, die KI kann nichts, sie brauchen wir nicht, das ist voll blöd, würde man gekillt werden. Weil die Leute diese Gefahr ja gerade sehen. Also wir kennen ja einzelne Menschen hier in Deutschland, die uns auch immer erzählen, dass die KI ja gar nicht so klug kann und hier und da und so. Aber dieser Wandel auf dem Arbeitsmarkt ist jetzt gerade. Die bohnen nicht Eric Schmidt aus, weil Eric Schmidt die KI mitbringt und so weiter und so fort, sondern weil die KI einfach da ist, unabhängig davon, ob sie jetzt nochmal verherrlicht wird oder nicht, aber derjenige, der sie verherrlicht. Der wird auf jeden Fall mal schief angeschaut und ausgeboot. Nur schon einen Tag später merkt man es ja im Bewerbungsverfahren, dass es gerade nicht so richtig läuft, wie die Freunde, die vor drei Jahren Abschluss gemacht haben, bei JetJBT 2.0 und alle so, keine Ahnung, was soll denn das sein? Ja, und den denkt man natürlich ein Jahr lang voraus. So, das ist wie so eine Inflation. Also wenn es jetzt schon mit meiner Bewerbung nicht klappt, in einem halben Jahr doch erst recht nicht. Also jetzt muss ich so langsam mein Brot kaufen, bevor es eine Milliarde kostet. So, ja, und das sind alles solche Sachen. Also diese Art von Kolonialismus, die der Papst auch wieder aufgreift, begrifflich, die findet jetzt plötzlich überall statt. Ausbeutungsmechanismen überall. Leute kommen nicht mehr zu ihrem Recht, dass ihnen versprochen wurde, also das große Versprechen der Bildung, geh in die Schule, frag deine Eltern, ob sie dir für 250.000 Euro den Abschluss zahlen und dann stehst du blank da. Das sind natürlich solche Gefahren, das hat jetzt also als die erste Frage. Plus natürlich, was er explizit gemacht hat, diese globale Verbreitung. Wie gehen wir damit um? Da haben wir ja Präzendenz aus den Impfstoffen und so. Zweite Frage, jetzt rückt er richtig ran an die Vatikanen.
Zweitens besteht die Notwendigkeit moralischer Vorstellungskraft und Ambitionen hinsichtlich des menschlichen Gedeihens. Wenn KI-Modelle weit verbreitet sein werden, wie sieht dann das Gedeihen von Menschen, Familien und der Welt aus? Schon heute machen sich Eltern Sorgen um die geistige Entwicklung ihrer Kinder, um die Zukunft ihrer Arbeiter. Das sind keine Fragen, die ein Labor beantworten kann. Das sind Fragen, die Traditionen wie die ihre seit der Tausenden tragen. Und wir brauchen sie, damit sie in diesen neuen Moment der Geschichte hinein weitertragen.
Ja, wir verbinden das mal direkt. Also, das ist quasi die Frage nach der Sozialisation, Bildung, warum überhaupt sollte man sich miteinander befassen? Und dann ja, also die Maschine kann uns diese Antwort nicht geben. Wir verbinden das mal direkt an die dritte Frage, die er hier stellt.
Der dritte Punkt ist, die Notwendigkeit, die Natur von KI-Modellen zu hinterfragen. Ich bin Wissenschaftler. Ich leite ein Forschungsthema, das die innere Struktur dieser Modelle untersucht, was tatsächlich in ihnen vor sich geht. Ich will ehrlich sein. Wir stossen immer wieder auf Dinge, die rätselhaft, ja sogar beunruhigend sind. Wir finden Strukturen, die Ergebnisse der menschlichen Neurowissenschaften widerspiegeln. Wir finden Hinweise auf Selbstreflexion. Wir finden innere Zustände, die Funktionalfreude, Zufriedenheit, Angst, Dauer und Unbehagel widerspiegeln. Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet, aber ich denke, es rechtfertigt eine fortwährende Auseinandersetzung.
Ja, das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, denn typischerweise ist es so, Menschen wurden in Deutschland geboren, vielleicht in christliche Familien, und dann ist man so eine Prozedur durchlaufen. Aber typischerweise war die dann mit dem Erwachsensein soweit fertig. So, und dann plötzlich, bei der Heirat werden sie wieder damit konfrontiert. Dass man natürlich kirchlich heiratet und dass man da das Protokoll nicht selbst in der Hand hat.
Das ist auch ein Sakrament in der katholischen Kirche.
Genau, dann ist man plötzlich schwanger und erwartet ein Kind. Und immer in diesen heiklen Momenten wird man wieder herangeführt, wie ist das jetzt mit der Taufe? Wann bringst du die zum Sonntagsunterricht usw. fort? Das heißt, genau in diesen Momenten, das ist eigentlich eine Spezifikation, die einfach im Raum liegt. Genau in den Momenten, wo man die Kirche braucht, ist sie plötzlich da, weil sie Termine in den Kalender schreibt. Jetzt hat Antropik aber nicht mit Kindern zu tun oder mit Nachwuchsfragen usw. Sondern er stellt plötzlich fest, wir haben es mit einer Entität zu tun, die wir nicht so richtig verstehen. Aber wir müssen es vorantreiben, weil wir uns in so einem Wettbewerb fühlen. Und irgendwie hört man hier auch raus, klar sitzt der da beim Vatikan, wo sonst? Die haben halt im Labor Fragen plötzlich, bei denen sie einfach so, eins plus eins ist doch zwei. Wir fragen jetzt in Rom nach.
Worauf er jetzt diese Frage auch anspielte, ist, dass er offenbar davon ausgeht, dass möglicherweise eine solche AI ein eigenes Bewusstsein entwickeln kann. Wenn er sagt, wir finden dort Momente, zum Beispiel der Selbstreflexion, dann ist das ja ein Hinweis darauf. Also selbst reflektieren kann natürlich nur, wer Bewusstsein hat, im Grunde genommen. Das ist jetzt die Frage, also ist es möglich, dass es ein anderes Wesen geben kann, das Bewusstsein hat, wo sich dann ja die Frage anschließt. Und wie ist es dann mit der Seele? Auch das ist ja eine Frage, wem kommt eigentlich eine Seele zu? Also nach traditioneller katholischer Lehre wäre zum Beispiel ein Tier, etwas, was keine Seele hat. Ja, deswegen sterben Tiere auch nicht, die verenden ja. Und das heißt aber, für ihn jetzt die Frage, eigentlich eine transhumanistische Frage, gibt es da etwas darüber hinaus, was der Papst aber in seinen Zyklika zurückweist.
Absolut, das will ich nämlich ausdrücklich hier schon mal sagen.
Das macht er ganz, ganz ausdrücklich. Ich war ja jemand, der schon in den Filmanalysen vor zehn Jahren immer wieder vor dieser transhumanistischen Ideologie gewarnt hat und da haben mich immer Leute ausgelacht, du nimmst das irgendwie alles so wichtig und so, nur was das drei Leute denken, das ist schon eine sehr militante Gruppe und auch eine große Kapitalträchtige. Und ich finde das sehr gut, dass der Papst sich hier vehement dagegen stellt.
Also der Papst wird nachher, wir werden es im Detail lesen, sagen, das ist Datenverarbeitung.
Ja.
Dass in der Datenverarbeitung die menschliches Verhalten, nämlich Kommunikation im Sinne von Worte an Worte rein nachahmt, simuliert, dass da ein dritter Satz durchaus mal auf den ersten zurück verweisen kann und daraus dann so Reflektionsschleifen, also Loops entstehen, darf nicht in die Irre führen.
Mit diesen Maschinen kann man nicht zusammenwachsen. Sie können ein irgendwas belehren, informieren, wir schauen im Fahrplan nach, wann der Bus fährt und so, wann wir, in welche Kurve wir einbiegen müssen, aber ja. Es ist trotzdem witzig, dass er hier das einfach so sagt, dass wir so funktionale Sachen sehen, die uns erinnern an und dann denke ich mir so, naja, Claude schreibt mir ganze Sätze, das erinnert mich auch an menschliche Kommunikation. Dass er halt auch substantiv die Gefühle beinhalten oder sogar Verhaltensweisen mit, ja, wenn ich Claude bedrohe, antwortet er besser. Das sind halt aber funktionale Sachen. Also da ist der Papst nachher ganz deutlich. Okay.
Ich möchte mit deiner Bitte schließen. Wir brauchen mehr Akteure aus der Welt, Religionsgemeinschaften, Zivilgesellschaft, Wissenschaftler, Regierungen, die das tun, was seine Heiligkeit hier getan hat. Dies ernst zu nehmen, genau hinzuschauen und die Ereignisse in eine bessere Richtung zu lenken. Wir brauchen sachkundige Kritiker, die den Abort sagen, wenn wir versagen. Wir brauchen moralische Stimmen, die sich von den Anreizen nicht beugen lassen. Heute ist erst der Anfang. Der Beginn einer langen Zusammenarbeit zwischen denen von uns, die dies aufbauen, und denen, die sehen können, was wir von ihnen heraus nicht sehen können.
Ja, wir hören jetzt einmal den Papst, wie er darauf reagiert. Und danach machen wir eine ganz kurze Presse schauen.
Liebe Brüder und Schwestern, ich danke Ihnen allen, die Sie hier sind und allen, die diese Versammlung organisiert haben.
Und denen, die ihre Kompetenz und Erfahrung eingebracht haben.
And in a special way, I would like to thank Mr. Ola for accepting our invitation. In turn, in the name of the church, I accept your invitation to walk together, to listen and to speak, And together, to find the way for humanity in this time of artificial intelligence.
Gemeinsam im Dialog zu bleiben und über die Entwicklung der künstlichen Intelligenz weiter zu beraten.
So, Entropic kommt und stellt Fragen. Der Papst sagt, ich beantworte diese gerne mit ihnen. Typischerweise ist das Silicon Valley hat immer recht, einfach was ja, move fast and break things. Das haben wir hier nicht gesehen. Ein dogmatisches Durchpeitschen von Kirchenweisheiten gegen alle Widerstände in der weltlichen Welt haben wir hier auch nicht gesehen. Also das ist von beiden Institutionen ein richtiger Schritt nach vorne, fast aufeinander zu. Ja, man begegnet sich und möchte die Zukunft gestalten.
Was er ja auch in der Enzyklika immer deutlich macht, wie sehr man auch sein Denken immer wieder abgleichen muss, mit Wissenschaft durch den Fortschritt, ob der jetzt aus den Naturwissenschaften oder den Geisteswissenschaften kommt. Dem kann man sich nicht verschließen.
Ja, so und deswegen, also weil beide jetzt auch aufgerufen hatten, wir brauchen hier mehr Akteure, die mit uns diesen Weg gehen. Ich finde, der journalistische Umgang dazu ist wirklich miserabel. Also es hat wirklich niemand mehr Ressourcen. In der FAZ schreibt Matthias Rüb so, ja, fand statt. So, ich bin ja Romberichterstatter, wie auch immer. Und Christian Geyer macht dann so eine Drei-Absatz-Glosse dazu. Nochmal, was der Papst so gesehen hat oder irgendwas, ja, oder dass es nichts Neues ist, wie auch immer. Süddeutsche Zeitung macht so ein kleines Täckchen, die Tats schreibt, Tagesspiegel. Also es lohnt es überhaupt nicht, jetzt, so wie wir typischerweise über journalistische Artefakte jetzt in so ein Thema reinzugehen, weil es gibt genau nichts. Es gibt allenfalls, und das aber dann auf eigene Faust, sehr viele Instagram-Clips, junge Frauen, die noch mal uns schon immer Enzyklika geil fanden und jetzt aus so einem fast fetischistischen Art so reingehen. Natürlich sehr viele Tech-Podcasts, die jetzt gar nicht drum rumkommen, und alleine, weil es der Papst ist, jetzt faszinierend davon sind. Und das fand ich alles sehr gut und auch aufschlussreich. Aber der Journalismus dazu, also wo ist der große deutsche Text, der sich mal mit dieser Enzyklika befasst, das finde ich wirklich irgendwie schräg, schräg, schräg. Also es einfach, muss man wirklich sagen, das ist nicht gut. Also wir hören noch ein Kardinal, den Präfekten des Decasteriums für integrale menschliche Entwicklung. Denn der mahnt zur Eile.
Extreme wie unkritische Begeisterung und lehmende Angst sind verständlich, da die durch neue Technologien hervorgerufenen Veränderungen in einem Tempo voranschreiten, das die kulturellen, politischen und bildungspolitischen Prozesse übertrifft, durch die Gesellschaften früher große historische Umwälzungen verarbeitet haben. Während die industrielle Revolution Arbeit, Staat, Familie und Wirtschaft schrittweise veränderte, schreitet der digitale Wandel sprunghaft voran. Manchmal innerhalb weniger Monate. Sometimes within the space of a few months. In fact, it seems like a few weeks.
So, auch das ist ein Novum. Denn perhaps Leo XIV wird sich gleich auf Leo XIII beziehen. Wir haben das hier schon thematisiert.
Aber das passiert ja häufiger in enzykliken, dass die Perze zurückgehen zu Vorgängern.
Genau, also das passiert häufiger. Und ich will nur zu Leo XIII sagen. Also Leo XIII hat den Vorgänger und der Vorgänger hat den Vorgänger. Und da war einfach jahrzehntelang gar nichts. Also Karl Marx hat schon Manifest und Kapital geschrieben. Da hat die Kirche noch jahrzehntelang nicht dran gedacht, dass man dazu mal was sagen müsste.
Und dann kam Rehrum Novarum. Das ist die Enzyklika, die sich mit der Industrialisierung auseinandersetzt, wie aber auch mit der Rolle der rebellierenden Arbeiterschaft. Das ist ein Text, der ein Grundstein ist für die katholische Soziallehre, der befrieden will, der nicht zum Klassenkampf aufruft, sondern eine sozialdemokratische, katholische Idee entwickelt. Von so etwas wie Sozialpartnerschaft würde man dann später sagen. Etwas, worauf sich die CDU zumindest in ihren Anfangsjahren immer noch recht häufig bezogen hat, ist jetzt inzwischen sehr weit weg.
Wir können die ganze Enzyklika als Nicht-CDU lesen. So, jetzt hören wir gleich den Papst dazu. Wir hatten das damals, als wir einfach nur gehört haben, weil man da heißt, der Papst Leo XIV., haben wir uns schon Gedanken dazu gemacht, die genau in diese Richtung gehen. Papst selbst bestätigt das jetzt alles.
135 Jahre vor, beobachtete mein verehrter Vorgänger Leo XIII., die Situation der Fabrikarbeiter, deren Familie entwurzelt waren, und die neue Formen der Armut, die durch den raschen industriellen Wandel entstanden waren. Er erkannte, dass die Kirche nicht fernbleiben durfte. Inmitten eines epochalen Wendepunkts, der die Menschenwürde bedrohte, sprach die Encyclikarriere um Novarum ihr evangelisches und soziales Wort über die sich abzeichneten neuen Dinge.
Heute stehen wir vor einem Wandel ähnlichen Ausmaßes, der vielleicht noch größere Folgen hat.
Künstliche Intelligenz berührt bereits viele Bereiche unseres Lebens und beeinflusst Entscheidungen, die das menschliche Zusammenleben prägen. Sie verändert auch dramatisch die Art und Weise, wie Krieg geführt wird. Mit der frühen Leo fühle ich mich dazu berufen, einen weiteren gewaltigen Wandel mit den Augen des Glaubens, mit der Klarheit der Vernunft, mit Offenheit für das Geheimnis und mit dem Schreien der Armen und der Erde, die in meinem Herzen widerhallen, zu betrachten.
Magnifica Humanitas ist aus dem Zuhören entstanden, wie es Leo XIII tat.
Also, die Kirche darf mal wieder nicht fern bleiben und sie muss es dialogisch gestalten. Not only in terms of content. So after the big machine revolution, now the intelligence revolution, Leo is so-called naming it. And paratical and programmatic. Social teacher, as you just said, that was actually from 1950 from Pius XII. Such a word. But back then and today, that's right, in, ja ja, is ja die Tradition. Also wir haben da nur mal einen Begriff noch nachgesucht.
Immer so rum, nur warum, ja.
Genau, man will die Zeichen der Zeit hören, die Sozialwissenschaftler als wesentlich einladen. Die Kirche will die Fahnen nicht hochhalten. Wir hören es ja auch nachher im Enzyklika Text, dass man sagt, die Wahrheit ist kein Territorium, sondern ein gemeinsames Gut. Weder das Silicon Valley noch der Vatikan deklariert hier irgendwas, sondern man begeht sich gemeinsam in der ganzen Welt auf die Suche. Die Menschenrechte werden ja hier, um sozusagen gemeinsam Grund und Boden zu finden, nochmal in allerhöchsten Form gelobt. Also der Papst schreibt, die allgemeine Erklärung der Menschenrechte 48 ist eine der höchsten Ausdrucksformen des menschlichen Gewissens. Ein wahrer Meilenstein auf dem Weg des moralischen Fortschritts. Auch darin liegt ein Eingeständnis, dass man sich vorher geirrt hat. Macht da jemand nicht so deutlich. Und man schuf damit eine gemeinsame Sprache. Nun müssen wir überlegen, wo kam das nochmal her, dass die Welt sich sagte, wir brauchen jetzt mal solche Menschenrechte. Also das ist wirklich Folge Holocaust. Diese Verweise hier auf allgemeine Erklärung der Menschenrechte haben also ein ganz düsteres Fundament, wenn man sich überlegt, warum der Papst gerade glaubt, sich in dieses Thema einmischen zu müssen. Das muss man ganz deutlich sagen, das ist wirklich. Und er betont dann nochmal, die aktuelle Schwäche der UNO ist wirklich ein großes Übel. Und da muss man auch dringend ran. Es geht um tiefgreifendere Formen, die er hier fordert, nicht nur um technische Anpassungen. Also hier sind bislang jetzt schon richtig Fundamente gelegt einfach. Das ist alles gar nicht schlecht. Außerdem, neben Schoah, die Sklaverei. Der Kampf gegen die neuen Formen der Sklaverei, und damit meint er ganz aktuell, das was jetzt droht, ist eine entscheidende Bewährungsprobe für das ethische Urteilsvermögen in Hinblick auf KI. Denn sonst droht, dass die wachsende Macht digitaler Systeme uns zu neuen Gräueltaten führt, die nicht weniger schändlich sind als jene der Vergangenheit. Also es ist geschehen, es kann wieder geschehen. Er schiebt dann eine große Entschuldigung nach. Er bittet um Vergebung für die Blindheit von gestern. Das ist auch ein Aufruf zur Wachsamkeit, seiner eigenen Wachsamkeit. Denn man darf jetzt nicht noch mal 1800 Jahre zu spät dran sein, Sklaverei zu verurteilen. Also da zeigt er, okay, auch wir sind fehlbar. Das ist wirklich crazy. Diese nicht groß thematisierten Raubzug durch die Urheberlandschaft gegen uns, muss man hier ganz deutlich sagen, ist ein echtes Problem. Also Urheberschaft, geistiges Eigentum, Copyright, irgendwas mit Lizenzen. Nichts dazu im Text. Wer hier wessen besitzt, wie verwerten darf. Sondern einfach nur, okay, es gibt Schöpfer, künstlerischer und literarischer Werke, die werden zumindest mal genannt. Dann Anmerkungen zu Daten, sind das Ergebnis der Beiträge. Viele und dürfen nicht an wenige verkauft werden. Also da hätte man richtig reingehen müssen, dieses Thema. Find nicht statt, der Mensch soll nicht als Produktionsfaktor oder auf einen Produktionsfaktor reduziert werden. Da würde ich sagen, also das läuft grad komplett.
Ja, also um mal diese Passage, ich glaube, die meinst du zu lesen. Unter diesen Ideologien halte ich jene für besonders heimtückisch, die suggeriert, dass jeder Mensch seinen Wert erst verdienen oder rechtfertigen muss, bis hin dazu, dass denjenigen, die effizienter oder effektiver sind, ein höherer Wert beigemessen wird. Aus dieser Perspektive werden Menschen letztlich auf ein Mittel zur Erreichung von Ergebnissen reduziert, auf eine Ressource, die genutzt und ausgebeutet werden kann und werden nicht mehr als eigenwertige Ziele an sich anerkannt, die niemals instrumentalisiert werden dürfen. Das heißt, er stellt sich hier bewusst gegen diesen Leistungsgedanken, dass nur wer Leistung zeigt, dann noch etwas bekommt, was er verdient hat. Und das hängt mit dem christlichen Menschenbild zusammen. Er sagt, der Wert des Menschen hängt jedoch nicht davon ab, was er leistet oder hervorbringt. Was bedeutet für die Kirche dann auch? Deshalb müssen Menschen, die nicht leisten können, zum Beispiel Menschen, die eine starke Behinderung haben oder so, genau gleichwertig behandelt werden. Deswegen richtet sich die Kirche auch gegen so etwas wie Sterbehilfe oder auch Abtreibung. Sie sagen, auch wenn es aktuell nicht in dem Sinne verwirklicht ist, also jemand, der sehr, sehr kranke ist, kann nicht alles an menschlichen Leistungen aufzeigen, was im Menschen ist. So ist es doch potenziell in ihm. In jedem Menschen ist es in ihm und deswegen ist jeder Mensch schützenswert. Da heißt es dann noch, es gibt Rechte, die jedem Menschen allein aufgrund seiner Menschlichkeit zustehen und keine menschliche Macht kann diese Rechte rechtmäßig verweigern oder willkürlich einschränken, was dann jegliche Form von Sklaverei oder so natürlich ausschließt.
Genau, so toll man das alles findet. Huckepack, du hast es angesprochen, wird natürlich genommen, dass die allgemeinen Menschenrechte hier einfach auf Abderzeugung zugesprochen werden. So in Sachen Abtreibung und weitere Themen ist der Vatikan natürlich hier im, wie soll man sagen, man sieht ja im Vatikan, wo die aufstrebenden Völker sind, die gerade ins Christentum streben. Und das sind nicht die Deutschen. Die im synodalen Weg und so weiter. Und hier noch mal eine Idee, und die Frauen und die ungeborenen Kinder. Also da ist man anders drauf. Aber wo wir unbedingt voll zustimmen können, Krieg und Frieden. Künstliche Intelligenz muss entwaffnet werden. Er hat es in der Vorstellung selbst gesagt. Wir hören das hier, wie er das formuliert.
Aus diesem Zuhören reifte eine beunruhigende Überzeugung heran, die in Manifekaro Manitas zum Ausdruck kommt. Künstliche Intelligenz muss entwaffnet werden. Das Wort ist stark, ich weiß. Aber bewusst gewählt, weil dieser Moment Worte braucht, die Aufmerksamkeit erregen, das Gewissen wecken und Wege für die Menschheit aufzeigen können.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen mehr als Pazifismus, denn hier geht es um die Grammatik dieser neuen Konflikte. Also hybride Kriegsformen in Führungen in allen Formen. Sowohl was Meinungsdebatten bei Twitter, X und so weiter angeht, Informationsmanipulation, Automatisierung, strategische Entscheidungen, da redest du nachher drüber. All das ist eh schon ein Problem. Jetzt kommt die KI als der ultimative beschleunigende Faktor da dazu. Das ist alles nicht gut. Im Grunde könnte man hier so, wir haben schon Atomwaffen und jetzt fliegen sie auch noch automatisch.
Ja.
So, wer ist seine Losung da?
Er sagt, einem Algorithmus konkret die Macht zu übertragen, zu bestimmen, wem etwas zusteht und wem nicht, ohne dass noch jemand die Last der Entscheidung trägt, bedeutet ihm die Aufgabe zu übertragen, die Grenzen menschlicher Möglichkeit neu zu definieren. Was in diesem Prozess verloren geht, ist nicht nur das Mitgefühl für den Ausgeschlossenen, das künstlich nachgeahmt werden kann, sondern auch die politische Verantwortung. Denn die Ausgrenzung der Schwachen wird mit Neutralität und Objektivität ummantelt, gegen die man nicht protestieren kann. Denn das ist ja auch das, gegen welchen Gegner kämpft man da. Nämlich einer, der neutral auftritt, vermeintlich neutral auftritt, und sagt, ich hab mal alle Daten gecheckt. Was jetzt auf ganz vielen Ebenen zu sehen ist. Also das kann man für den Algorithmus in den sozialen Medien sehen. Das kann aber auch das Assessment Center sein. Das Algorithm, wie schon mal auswählt, wer wird überhaupt zu einer Bewerbung eingeladen. Bis hin zum Targeting, das entschieden wird, welches Haus soll gesprengt werden von der Drohne, die wir los schicken.
Genau. Nun zur Definition von KI. Wir warten ja alle seit Ewig darauf, dass uns mal jemand erklärt, was ist das überhaupt? Was wir schon besprochen haben. Es ist reine Datenverarbeitung, ausschließlich Datenverarbeitung. Sie wird gezüchtet, das macht sie obskur zu einer Blackbox. Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass hier Menschen hergestellt werden, sondern es bleibt uns lediglich unbekannt, wie diese Datenverarbeitung, die aber eine Datenverarbeitung abläuft. Man soll sich also hier nicht in die Verwechslung begeben. Diese KI's machen keine eigenen Erfahrungen. Sie besitzen keinen Körper, haben also keine Bedürfnisse. Sie haben kein moralisches Gewissen. Sie wissen nicht, was gestern und morgen ist. Alles, was hier anders gesehen wird, ist als Missverständnis zu betrachten. Finde ich auch alles sehr gut. KI's lernen, aber das sind nur statistische Anpassungen. Es ist weder ein inneres noch ein gemeinsames Wachstum. Daraus kann die Gesellschaft nichts kreieren. Das können nur die Menschen selbst. Also hier ganz nah bei Marx auch. Nur um diesen Mehrwertgedanken aufzukranken.
Ich bin ein bisschen überrascht, dass du das alles so gut findest, da ich mich an Podcast-Diskussionen mit dir erinnere, wo ich diese Position immer sehr hart verteidigen musste.
Naja, ich will ja...
Vielleicht habe ich mich nicht so gut ausgedrückt wie der Papst. Das kann schon sein, aber...
Nee, manchmal will man einfach wissen, was 725.000 plus 13 ist. Und dann nutzt man einen Taschenrechner.
Da bin ich ja nicht dagegen.
Und klärt das nicht im Gespräch. Genau. Und sehr viele andere Fragestellungen klärt man jetzt auch lieber mit dem Computer als im Gespräch.
Gewiss. Aber ich war es ja doch, der hier relativ früh darauf hingewiesen hat, dass, wie er sagt, sein Missverständnis ist, die Intelligenz der KI gleichzusetzen mit einer menschlichen Intelligenz. Oder dass ich auch sagte, nun, da diese Intelligenz keine Erfahrung macht...
Also, Momentchen mal. Ich habe dich immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, dass hier nicht der menschliche Maßstab für Intelligenz gilt, um eine Maschine zu beschreiben, sondern, dass die Maschine irgendwas eigenes macht. Und mittlerweile habe ich ja auch den neuen Begriff Fleiß dafür in Anklang gebracht, um sehr viel Kränkungspotenzial bei Leuten rauszunehmen, die sich natürlich immer super intelligent fühlen. Aber wenn man sie fragt, naja, aber jetzt die tausend Seiten lesen, das überlassen wir doch der KI mit dem Fleiß. Oder wenn wir nur was raussuchen wollen, dann sagt jeder, ja, ich bin so intelligent, ich benutze eine fleißige Maschine. Und das versöhnt mich auch wieder mit sehr vielen, die mir anderes sagen.
Da will ich ja auch gar nicht widersprechen. Aber ich meine, als ich dann gesehen dieses menschliche hier in den Mittelpunkt rücklade, hattest du mir immer gesagt, naja, menschliche Kommunikation, da weißt du am Ende ja auch nicht, was vorauskommt und so was.
Ja, das darf man jetzt nicht verwechseln. Also alles, was der Papst sagt, stimmt. Und trotzdem bevorzuge ich manchmal die Kommunikation mit der Maschine vor einer mit dem Menschen.
Ja, ich auch.
Siehste?
Wenn ich jetzt…
Und da, das ist das einzige, worum es mir geht.
Ja klar, wenn ich jetzt in ein Parkhaus reinfahre und kann das mit einer Sprachassistenz klären, wie ich da wieder rauskomme, dann brauch ich da nicht einen Menschen für.
Ja, so, hören wir uns doch die zentrale Idee des Papstes noch an, bevor wir ein bisschen in den Text gehen.
Lasst uns nicht schlafen wie die anderen, mahnte der Apostel Paulus, sondern lasst uns wachsam sein. Eine solche Wachsamkeit ist heute notwendig. Frieden, nicht nur die Abwesenheit von Krieg, ist Gerechtigkeit in Aktion.
Doch wenn die Technologie unseren kritischen Sinn schwächt, ist der Frieden selbst in Gefahr.
Abrüsten reicht jedoch nicht aus. Wir müssen aufbauen. Das Wort aufbauen erinnert mich an meine Jahre als Missionar in Peru. Im Jahr 2017 wurde der Norden des Landes von Sinnflutartigen Regenfällen und Überschwemmungen heimgesucht. There I learned that many people saw their houses be completely replaced in this history. It means repairing times, restoring trust, and rewakening hope in the future. Over and no one rebuilds a loathing. Manifigure humanitas, I recall the biblical prophet Nehemiah. He gathers disillusioned people, to bring about rebirth. The image of wall does not legitimize closure of visions, but invites each and every one to do their part. Worked by birth, of which us living things take a break. Chained to old, of which we start living, dignity of all. Nehemias Bemühungen besprechen zu unserer Zeit. Künstliche Intelligenz kann eine Baustelle der Geschichte sein, die aus einem Horizont der Gemeinschaft heraus entsteht, in dem der technische Fortschritt lernt, dem menschlichen Leben zu dienen.
So, hier ist er ja fast schon Sprung zu weit, denn er sagt ja, wir müssen hier gemeinsam bauen, während wir uns alle noch eben abwehren. Mit Klimawandel abwehren, KI-Bedrohung abwehren und so weiter. Gemeinsames Bauen. Er kommt ja dann sehr ausführlich immer wieder darauf zurück. Turm zu Babel und diese gemeinsame Aufbauidee von Jerusalem als Stadt, in der dann die Menschheit mit Gott zusammen wohnt. Das finde ich super interessant, weil ich so viele Reisen zuletzt gemacht habe, dass ich natürlich dieses Brügel, das Turmbau zu Babel noch vor Augen habe.
Bräugel, ja.
Bräugel, wie ich da in Wien stehe und denke, ah ja, das ist ja dieses berühmte Bild. Ja, und dann sieht man plötzlich wie viele Versionen, die dann auch konzipiert haben, um das so und so und so zu zeigen. Um sozusagen eine Baustelle, also Menschen sind voll tüchtig und so, und da leben auch schon welche drin, aber es führt ins Verderben. Ja, also um dieses Wechselspiel da herzustellen. Bevor wir jetzt ein bisschen in den Text gehen, eine Gewissensfrage, die ganz wunderbar, finde ich, sehr modern auf den Punkt gebracht wird von Victor Manuel Fernández. Das ist der Präfekt der Glaubenslehre, der diese Vorstellung mit einer Fragestellung schließt.
All diese Überlegungen hinterlassen uns eine kraftvolle und entscheidende Botschaft. Oder vielmehr eine grundlegende Frage an unser Gewissen, an mein und an euer Gewissen. Will ich zu jener in sich selbst verschlossenen, dekadenten, leeren und gefühllosen Menschheit gehören, die so stolz auf ihre technologischen Ressourcen ist, dass sie sich selbst anstelle von Gott vergöttert? Oder wünsche ich mir, zu jener großartigen Menschheit zu gehören, von der Gott geträumt hat, die fähig ist, zu lieben, ihr Leben für andere zu geben, mit ihnen zu leiden, sich über sich selbst hinausführen zu lassen, um in der Freundschaft mit Gott ganz sie selbst zu werden? Die Antwort überlasse ich jedem von uns.
So, rote Pille, blaue Pille.
Ja, wir haben ja hier schon häufig Clips gebracht von Mark Zuckerberg oder Elon Musk, die in ihrer ganzen Selbstherrlichkeit dasitzen, sich auch noch verewiglichen wollen, indem sie bald noch ihr Gehirn hochladen oder sich mit Blut zufuhren, vielleicht wie Peter Thiel ewig verjüngen wollen. Das ist genau diese dekadente Lebensweise, die hier angesprochen wird, die eigentlich leer und kalt ist, wie wir bei Elon Musk dann besonders gut sehen können. Er hat einen Stall voll Kinder, aber zu keinem guten Kontakt. Also das ist ja alles wahnsinnig. Und zugleich gibt es die andere Möglichkeit, die hier eröffnet wird, eine rhetorische Frage, die er ja stellt.
Du sagst jetzt rhetorisch.
Denn man möchte ja eigentlich zu der großartigen Menschheit gehören, aber offenbar beantworten die viele anders diese Frage.
Genau, das ist ja der Punkt. Das ist ja nicht eine rhetorische Frage.
Müsste sie eigentlich sein, ja.
Müsste eine rhetorische Frage sein, wenn die Kirche noch die Macht hätte, einfach vom Marktplatz aus zu deklarieren, was Sache ist, wäre das eine rhetorische Frage. Aber du hast jetzt Elon Musk genannt, der ist nicht der einzige. Wir sehen ja ganz viele, die sich ganz bewusst dagegen entscheiden. Also Leute, die nicht doof sind, die diese Frage kennen und die auch wissen, was dranhängt und trotzdem sagen, ich fliege jetzt zum Mars. So, ich nehme euer Geld.
Man muss sich das ja mal vorstellen, jetzt so jemand wie Jeff Bezos, der mit einer Idee, ich versende Bücher und irgendwann versende ich alles, groß wird und dann so ein Reichtum ansammelt und eigentlich ja dann nur macht, was alle Reichen so machen würden, die man von RTL 2 kennt, nur eben sehr viel größer. Also ich kauf dann die allergrößte Yacht. Aber das ist ja das das holste überhaupt.
Ja, und das müssen wir hier ganz deutlich markieren. Erst durch das Lesen der Enzyklika, wo ich mich so viel mit Kram befasse, der abläuft. Die Welt ist in einem Zustand, der viel, viel schlechter ist, als wir bisher dachten.
Ja.
Also noch viel schlechter.
Hier steht die Frage im Raum, möchten wir einfach alle gemeinsam, dass es allen gut geht oder einfach Mord und Totschlag? Und dann sagen einfach alle Leute mit mehr als 100 Millionen Mord und Totschlag. Wir alle wüssten, jeder kann für sich überlegen, was würde ich mit einer Million Euro machen, wenn ich sie nicht nur für mich ausgeben dürfte, sondern ich müsste so Gehalt an jemanden zahlen vielleicht, der dann was macht, machen wir es gemeinsam so. Mit 10 Millionen Euro würden wir alle die Revolution planen hier. Wir würden ein Museum bauen, wir würden Theaterstücke schreiben, wir würden Bücher machen, was auch immer. Jeden Tag Live-Podcast. Und jetzt stellen wir sich mal vor, man hätte 10.000 Mal so viel. Und das ist die Welt, die wir kriegen von Leuten, die diese Entscheidung treffen.
Bunkeranlagen, Inseln kaufen, irgendwelche Jachten, gucken, ob man noch auf den Mars kommt.
Man kann das jetzt lesen als rhetorisches Bild. Aber ich will es mal so wie der Papst es schreibt. Die von Gott geschaffene großartige Menschheit steht heute vor einer entscheidenden Wahl. Entweder sie errichtet einen neuen Turm zur Babel oder sie erbaut die Stadt, in der Gott und die Menschheit gemeinsam wohnen. Das ist der Originaltext. Für mich steckt hier drin, es gibt zu viele Leute, die hier gerade einen Turm zur Babel bauen. Also es ist nicht eine rhetorische Frage oder so, sondern es gibt voll den Anlass, jetzt mal hier groß reinzugehen. Die bauen uns alle ins Verderben. Elon Musk schreibt in seinem Ding, Ich will, dass jede Minute ein Starship startet. Ja. Mit 100 Millionen Tonnen Zeug hinten drin und so. Das ist bescheuert. Konkret betrachtet ist sie, die Technologie, nicht neutral, weil sie die Züge derer annimmt, über die wir gerade sprachen, die sie konzipieren, finanzieren, regulieren und nutzen. Bei den Nutzen würde ich sagen, nimmt mich ein bisschen raus. Ich bin dem ausgeliefert. Ich kann gerade noch sagen, ich benutze kein Open AI mehr. Ich nutze Entropic. Aber sehr viel weiter komme ich da auch nicht. Von daher, dieser Text ist so wunderbar. Heute sind die Haupttriebkräfte der Entwicklung private, oft transnationale Akteure, die über Ressourcen und Handlungsmöglichkeiten verfügen, die denen viele Regierungen überlegen sind. Ich hätte ja gerne einen politischen Diskurs zur Sache, dass man sagt, okay, Bundespressekonferenz, vorne sitzt die Regierung, dass irgendwie die Möglichkeit besteht, diesen Konflikt aufzuheben und zu sagen, also ich, der Regierte, und sie, die Regierende, was machen wir denn jetzt gemeinsam gegen die Oligarchen? Aber stattdessen werden wir mit diesem Konflikt da in Berlin irgendwie behälligt, während die Oligarchen selbst sich irgendwie die Met-Galer kaufen und mit so einem Scheiß durchkommen. Also hier müssen einfach grundlegend neue Sachen gemacht werden. Nie hatte die Menschheit so viel Macht über sich selbst, schreibt er. Und zufällig ist die Macht gerade in den falschen Händen. Also von wegen hier Demokratie und so. Am Ende ist alles Jeff Bezos. Er möchte gerne, dass man mal wieder die Richtung der Welt bestimmt, ohne immer Notstand deklarieren zu müssen, weil es einer ist, sondern dass man mal wieder in dieses Bauen reinkommt. Man liest das so und denkt, das sind so Selbstverständlichkeiten, aber dann denkt man sich so, das ist voll gut, dass er das mal aufgeschrieben hat.
Ja, man kann es ja auch profanieren. Der Papst ist ja hier Teil eines Diskurses und das macht er ja auch immer wieder deutlich. Wir haben ja beispielsweise das Buch Abundance gelesen von Esra Klein und ähnliche Bücher, die in diese Richtung gehen, wo es ja immer um das Bauen geht. Und das ist jetzt natürlich eine religiös gefärbte, aber im Prinzip dem sehr naheliegenden Anleitung, warum baut man nicht gemeinsam eine Welt?
Ja, und er beschreibt es wunderbar, wie die einen durch ihre Gier in so eine Alternativlosigkeit reinschlittern. Wir müssen jetzt den Wettbewerb gegen OpenAI gewinnen, was auch immer. Und auf der anderen Seite führt dieses Gierverhalten bei denen, die dem ausgeliefert sind, die ganze Zeit in Notsituationen. Weshalb der politische Diskurs im Grunde ist, ja, Herr Klingbeil, also Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie können nicht immer alles mit Geld zuschütten. Aber müssen wir doch, oder? So, also wir kommen ja aus dieser Zwickmühle einfach gar nicht raus. Diese Klammer finde ich auch wunderbar. Also diese Verzeitlichung. Sehr viel kolportiert wurde ja. Es wird Gandalf zitiert, Tolkien und so weiter, haben wir alle mitbekommen. Nur er selbst, also in der Sprache des Papstes, jede Generation erbt die Aufgabe, die eigene Zeit zu gestalten. Jetzt würde ich sagen, er führt den Tolkien als den katholischen Autor ein, der natürlich selber nur Bibelstellen zitiert. Also sozusagen über Bande, aber sehr clever, weil man dann, ahja, das ZDF macht da eine Infokarrell draus. Und hat ja auch genauso funktioniert. Also wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Außerdem, also wir haben jetzt schon, er hat schon gesagt, die neuen Machtzentren sind nicht mehr die Regierungen, sondern die Konzerne. Sie haben so viel Macht, wie die Regierungen nie hatten.
Da würde ich ja widersprechen wollen. Da bin ich ja Marxist.
Also du siehst Trump gerade im unendlichen Machtfülle, oder was?
Nein, nein, so darf man es jetzt nicht einfach sehen. Man darf es jetzt nicht einfach an der Person Trump. Trump kann sein, dass der...
Macron.
Es sind ja die Staaten am Ende, die über etwas entscheiden. Es ist nicht einfach nur das Silicon Valley. Also das ist, glaube ich, ein Diskurs, den der Papst hier führt, der ist so ein bisschen veraltet. Also vor zehn Jahren hätte man das wahrscheinlich so gesagt. Aber was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist eigentlich ein Zusammenschluss zwischen den staatlichen und den privaten Akteuren. Das ist etwas, was wir jetzt gerade beobachten können. Das heißt, wer am Ende in Auftrag gibt, welche Drohnen jetzt hergestellt und gekauft werden, ist eine staatliche Frage. Helsing, der neue Drohnenhersteller, der steht und fällt damit, dass genügend Staaten kommen, das Zeug zu kaufen und dann möglicherweise auch anbenden. Das ist im Grunde wie bei Rheinmetall auch. Dass jetzt den KI-Konzernen so viel Spielraum gelassen wird in den USA, liegt daran, dass es einen staatlichen Wettbewerb gibt, dass man sagt, bevor die Chinesen kommen, lasst uns das lieber machen. Was braucht ihr? Ihr braucht Milliarden. Ihr braucht keinen Umweltschutz mehr. Wunderbar, geben wir euch. Baut überall Rechenzentren, wo immer ihr wollt. Das heißt, das sind nicht wirkliche Deregulierungen im Sinne von, wie das früher war mit einer Neoliberalisierung, wo man sagte, macht es einfach da, wo es am billigsten ist. Das ist so diese transnationale Geschichte. Sondern hier sehen wir schon, aus einem nationalen Interesse heraus werden die KI-Firmen ermächtigt, dies zu tun. Und da würde ich auch dem Papst widersprechen. Ich würde sagen, die staatliche Macht ist da ganz entscheidend. Und das macht es aber nicht ungefährlicher.
Also der Papst sagt ja nichts zum Staat. Dass in den Staaten die Konzerne dann einfach das Ruder überleben, ist ja genau im Argument.
Nein, ich würde sagen, dass sie es nicht übernehmen. Sie übernehmen es nicht. Es ist die Regierung, die entscheidet über das, was die Konzerne machen können.
Ja, also das lese ich im Text ein bisschen anders und ich fühle es auch ein bisschen anders. Die Regierungen sind alle extrem getrieben. Die finden ja keinen Ausweg mehr. Und sie sind getrieben von Konzernen, die ihnen einfach sagen, was Sache ist.
Naja, sie könnten ja zum Beispiel eine starke Regulation einführen. Aber dann haben sie ja das Problem, dass ein anderer Staat, wie zum Beispiel China, kommt und sagt, dann machen wir weiter und werden dann bald mit unserer KI-Technologie alles übertrumpfen. Deshalb wird aus einem staatlichen Interesse natürlich nicht in dieser Weise reguliert, wie man es eigentlich will. Das hat ja, um man Beispiele ohne KI zu nehmen. Warren Buffett hat bei irgendeiner seiner Jahresversammlungen mal gesagt, tja, er wüsste gar nicht, warum jetzt so mit Monopol man da so ein Problem hat. Warum soll man jetzt diese wunderbaren großen amerikanischen Unternehmen zerschlagen? Dann kommen ja andere aus dem Ausland in die Lücke. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich nicht, also es ist ja die Frage primat des politischen oder primat des wirtschaftlichen. Und ich würde sagen primat des politischen am Ende immer. Was aber nicht bedeutet, dass wir die ganze Zeit jetzt Regierungen haben, die wahnsinnig souverän sind. Aber im Ganzen versucht man, einem nationalstaatlichen Interesse zu dienen. Und dem müssen sich dann auch die Konzerne unterwerfen. Das sehen wir ja gerade bei Anthropic. Wenn die dann nur ganz minimal rote Linien aufzeichnen, denn ganz viel macht ja Anthropic auch mit und hadert ja nicht grundsätzlich mit der Trump-Regierung oder so, dann gibt es schon auch von Seiten des Staates Sanktionierungen. Und deshalb würde ich da immer wieder sprechen, und das ist ein Diskurs, der eigentlich so ein linker Diskurs immer noch sehr stark ist, dass man sagt, die transnationalen Konzerne, und ich würde sagen, ja genau, die gibt es, aber es ist schon hier gerade sehr stark die staatliche Macht und hier vor allem die US-Macht bei diesen Tech-Konzernen.
Also ich möchte euch anmerken, du bist hier sehr viel idealistischer als der Vatikan selbst.
Nein, im Gegenteil, ich bin viel nix.
Nein, nein, nein, bleib mal ausführen. Fast ist das wie Blüdern. Ach, sie glauben noch an Politik, weil sie das in den Geschichtsbüchern gelesen haben, dass der Wähler mal über eine demokratische Mehrheitsbeschaffung und so weiter was herstellen konnte. Nur genau da will ja der Papst rein in dieses Denken, um dir zu sagen, wir müssen wirklich alles umbauen. Wir können nicht einfach sagen, ah ja, jetzt haben wir, nachdem das mit Merkel gerade noch so gut ging und wir uns das bei Scholz erklären können, wir waren halt drei Koalitionspartner, einer zu viel. Und jetzt klappt es auch gerade wieder nicht. Ja, wir müssen mal wieder zurück zu, als es gut funktioniert hat. Und da würde ich sagen, nee, der Papst geht ja genau diesen Schritt weiter.
Nee, das will ich ja auch nicht damit gesagt haben.
Ja, aber er verhält sich ja genau nicht so zu Primatfragen, Wirtschaft oder Politik im Staat, dass man jetzt sagen kann, ja, wir können uns ja erinnern an gute Zeiten, warum sind die eigentlich nicht da? Also so eine romantische Reflexion, sondern er sagt ja, nee, der Drops ist jetzt gelutscht. Also die Konzerne bestimmen, was Sache ist. Und auch ein Topic wirft sich natürlich der Trump, oder jeder Administration da vor die Füße.
Aber damit bestimmen sie es doch nicht. Also dass die Silicon Valley Konzerne allesamt bei Donald Trumps Amtseinführung saßen und fröhlich applaudiert haben, dass Tim Cook dahinreißt und irgendwelche verrückten Preise oder Medaillen überreicht oder was hat er da irgendwie angebracht. Also dass die alle den Diener machen vor Donald Trump, ist doch ein ganz deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass der Staat am Ende das letzte Wort hat.
Nee, also sehe ich wirklich genau umgekehrt.
Nein.
Die sind nicht zum Weißen Haus gefahren, um da den Kotau zu machen, sondern es gibt einfach nur ein Weißes Haus, also es gibt einfach nur pro Zeitpunkt einen Präsidenten. Und diesem Konzern kann völlig egal sein, wer da regiert. Offenbar ja nicht. Die Hauptsache, es wird nichts gegen sie entschieden, weil aber nur sie die Konkurrenz anderer gleichgroßer Konzerne befürchten. Apple ist weit darüber hinaus. Du hast dieses Buch kürzlich gelesen. Wenn Apple will, ist die amerikanische Wirtschaft morgen zu Ende. Also sie können Trump so unter Druck setzen. Apple ist der größte Steuerzahler, der größte Arbeitgeber. Apple ist von allem der größte. Die können einfach... Die Straße von Donald Moos ist zu und alle wissen, was im November in Washington passiert.
Ich will nicht leugnen, dass die Macht von Apple sehr groß ist. Nur ist es nicht so, dass die Konzerne die Politik in der Hand hat. Das sehe ich wirklich nicht. Sondern ich sehe es genau umgekehrt. Es gibt gerade machtpolitische Ambitionen von den verschiedenen Blöcken. Im Übrigen auch Ambitionen von der EU. Und dem werden ja gerade Konzerninteressen unterworfen. Also zum Beispiel für die deutsche Industrie und für die europäische Industrie wäre es das Beste gewesen, man hätte weiter aus Russland Gas und Öl bezogen. Man macht das natürlich nicht aus einem politischen Grund. Und dieser politische Grund, der schlägt alles andere aus, was da sonst noch an Interessen rumläuft. Das heißt, daran können wir ja ganz klar sehen, es ist der Staat, der die Ansage macht. Und in autoritären Systemen wie China und Russland sowieso schon. Aber ich hatte ja vor vor Uhrzeiten im Salon dieses Buch Tools and Weapons vorgestellt, wo gesagt wird vom Microsoft-Anwalt Brad Smith, dass jetzt gerade Staaten und Konzerne zusammenarbeiten wollen. Und ich würde sagen, dass wir jetzt erleben, dass Anthropic erst mal mit dem Weißen Haus klären muss, was kann da mit dem Mythos-Modell gemacht werden und was sollte man nicht anderen zugänglich machen. Das ist ein ganz klarer Beweis dafür, dass sich eine neue Verflechtung dadurch ergibt. Also das heißt, das Privatwirtschaftliche spielt mehr in der staatliche Reihen und das sehen wir auch bei der bemannten Raumfahrt und all dem. Aber generell hat der Staat, muss der Staat das letzte Wort haben.
Also um es nochmal mit den Worten des Papsts ist, diese Unterscheidung aus Bauen, wir müssen wieder ins Bauen kommen. Für den Papst ist völlig klar, da muss ich nicht die Politik ansprechen. Da muss ich mit den Konzernen-Leuten reden. Deswegen sitzt da ein Tropic-Typ hier. Das, was wir gerade sehen, Trump kann Sachen kaputt machen. Also ganz wunderbar. Und davor haben die Konzerne Angst. Das ist richtig. Wenn man daraus ein Primat ableitet, also Trump kann Amerika zerstören, würde ich sagen, ja, von allen 350 Millionen Amerikanern ist er wahrscheinlich in der besten Position, um einfach Amerika kaputt zu machen. Aber wenn du jetzt einen konstruktiven Beitrag willst, also da musst du dich im Weißen Haus vorstellig werden, dass der Papst hier einfach in Konflikt mit dem Weißen Haus sagt, wir bauen jetzt gemeinsam auf, ich meine die Menschheit und alle Menschen guten Willens und an meiner Seite sitzt der Anthropik-Typ.
Dass der Papst transnational agieren muss, das wäre logisch.
Vor 60 Jahren war völlig klar, dass man hier für Khrushchov eine Einladung in die ersten drei Absätze reinschreibt und so.
Sicherlich. Sehe ich den Paradigmen weg, es wäre vollkommen lachhaft, wenn jetzt der Papst mit irgendjemand aus der Trump-Administration da sitzen würde. Das wäre einfach total albern. Das geht natürlich nicht.
Wir würden sagen, was soll das denn für ein Quatsch? Aber hier sagen wir nicht, was ist denn das für ein Quatsch.
Man könnte aber auch sagen, Anthropik ist auch ein Botschafter von den USA.
Diese Verwicklung.
Die würden ja jetzt nicht nach Belgien umziehen.
Also Anthropik gilt gerade grundsätzlich als das führende Unternehmen. Ja, es hat von allen KI's die Klügste.
Und es gibt ein hohes Interesse von Anthropik, dass das so bleibt und auch ein Interesse der US-Regierung, die sein wichtiges Unternehmen ist.
Ich wundere jetzt nicht, dass da keiner aus einer chinesischen KI-Firma oder von Mistral sitzt. Weil Anthropik investiert einfach 1000 Mal mehr als Mistral. Also da ist eine Billion im Raum und nicht eine Milliarde, wie bei Mistral. Von daher, das passt schon alles, finde ich, so ganz gut ins Bild. Und wir sollten vielleicht auch, Hollywood hat ja die Wende auch schon gemacht, uns zu verdeutlichen, es sind am Ende die Konzerne.
Ja, und diese Wende hat sich doch jetzt zumindest seit Corona, spätestens seit dem Krieg in der Ukraine als ein voreiliger Fehlschluss herausgestellt.
Ja, wir kommen auch auf Krieg gleich zu sprechen. Und das Kriegen, die zwischen Staaten geführt haben, fühlt sich gerade noch so an. Aber ich würde schon sagen, selbst in der Ukraine, die Kriegsteilnehmer dort sind Eric Schmitt und Palantir und der ukrainische Staat muss es halt irgendwie ausbaten. Das ist das Territorium.
Aber ich glaube, das wird eine neue Konfliktlinie zwischen uns. Ist es der Staat oder sind es die Konzerne?
Was wir hier als Konfliktlinie markieren würden, ist Vatikan versus CDU. Der Wert des Menschen hängt nicht davon ab, was er leistet oder produziert. Als hätte man das direkt Friedrich Merz eingeschrieben. Er darf nicht auf ein Mittel zur Erzielung von Ergebnissen reduziert werden. This is das, was die CDU macht. Zahnbehandlung für alle. Auf eine Ressource, die man nutzen und ausbeuten kann. Das ist im Grunde, wo sollen hier fürs BIP ausgebeutet werden? Ganz explizit übrigens, BIP bitte nicht mehr. Sagt der Papst. Also, bisch dich hier wirklich rein. Es gibt eine unendliche Würde. Du hast es ja eben schon. So, diese Machtfragen und Menschenrechte. Machtfragen waren schon immer interessant, weil Frank Schörmacher, das Vöter damals, über diese, wir stellen die neuen Machtfragen, denn er formuliert hier auch, und wir haben jetzt einen Disput darüber, wer die Macht hat. Das ist dem Papst so ein bisschen, er sagt einfach, die Rechte könnten künftig von denen in Frage gestellt oder verweigert werden, die die Macht dazu haben. Also, man kann es auch offen lassen. Man sieht auf jeden Fall die Gefahr. Nach scheinbarer Zustimmung, also wir haben so viele Fernsehleute, da kann man die ganze Zeit vom Gesellschaftsvertrag und so reden, als hätten wir irgendwann mal irgendwo eine Zustimmung gegeben, einer eingeschüchterten oder manipulierten Bevölkerung. Also, hier ist einfach fast könnte man sagen, ach, Stefan und Wolfgang, was streitet ihr euch darüber, wer hier das Primat hat, ja? Also, die Problemstellung ist hier auf jeden Fall markiert. Er macht die Machtfrage ganz explizit zu den Gütern, die universal für alle bestimmt sind. Müssen wir heute auch die neuen Formen des Eigentums zählen? Ja, da sind wir auf jeden Fall in der wirtschaftlichen Dimension. Patente, Algorithmen, digitale Plattformen, technologische Infrastruktur, Daten. Konzentriert in den Händen weniger, vergrößern sie die Kluft zwischen den Teilhabenden und den Ausgeschlossenen. Und da würde ich sagen, das kriegen gerade die amerikanischen College-Studenten, die ihren Eltern 200.000 Dollar rausgeleiert haben für die eigene Ausbildung. Ja, da wird es jetzt deutlich. In der digitalen Revolution ist die übergeordnete Ebene, nicht der Staat, sondern jeder große wirtschaftliche und technologische Akteur, also globale Konzerne, der faktisch Macht über die Bedingungen des gemeinsamen Lebens ausübt. Subsidiarität, er bringt es ja ganz groß, verlangt Transparenz bei Algorithmen, gerechten Zugang zu Daten, Rechtsbehelfsmöglichkeiten. Also ich will sie nochmal aufmachen, aber für mich geht der Papst hier sehr in eine Richtung, bei der ich denke, das ist krass modern und voll aktuell.
Man muss es jetzt nochmal sehen, worauf er es konkret bezieht. Es ist ja definitiv gerade so, dass es kaum Regulierungen gibt und dass dadurch diese Konzerne erst einmal in einem Nebel sich befinden, was sie gerade erforschen, machen und tun, worauf sie zurückgreifen. Dieses alte Motto, move fast and break things, gilt ja noch immer oder mehr denn je, könnte man sagen. Daraus kann man sicherlich die Schlussfolgerung ziehen. Wir haben es hier mit privaten Akteuren zu tun, die den Staat in den Schatten stellen und der Staat kommt gar nicht mit Regulierungen hinterher. Da will ich auch gar nicht widersprechen. Ich wäre ja blöde. Aber was ich sagen will, dass der Staat nicht reguliert, ist ja nicht einfach ein Versehen, dass man jetzt gemeinsam mit Amy Globuchar betrauern kann, warum macht man eigentlich nicht was gegen diese Monopolbildungen. Das ist ja eine politische Strömung, die es da gibt, die sagt, wir müssen das einhegen. Im Ganzen aber kann man im Sinne eines Staatsinteresses auch sagen und auch in dem Interesse der aktuellen US-Regierung, lass sie das ruhig mal machen. Da mögen ein paar Eierkappen zu Bruch gehen, aber sonst bekommt man auch kein Omelett. Und das bedeutet, wir wollen die Vormachtstellung bei KI haben, was auch heißt, wir nehmen das andere als Kollateralschaden in Kauf. Und das ist sicherlich aus einem grundsätzlichen Staatsinteresse herausgedacht und da würden wir dann auch feststellen, würden sich die Demokraten gar nicht so sehr von den Republikanern unterscheiden, bis auf einige wenige Aktivisten, die sagen, wir brauchen jetzt einen tollen Mittelstand mit einem super kompetitiven Verbrauchermarkt, in dem die Einzelkonzerne nicht so eine Entscheidungsgewalt haben. Und da sehen wir natürlich einzelne Strömungen, die das anders sehen. Aber im Ganzen würde ich unterstreichen wollen, dass es doch eher ein Staatsinteresse ist auch. Sonst würde man vehementer dagegen vorgehen.
Da kannst du noch ganz vehement bei bleiben. Ich merke an, was der Papst hier schreibt, nämlich die Infrastruktur der Systeme, die darüber entscheiden, wem was zusteht, wem welche Lebenschancen geben werden, sind unsichtbar. Die Ungerechtigkeit, schreibt er, ist lautlos. Den Lärm, den wir sehen, ist tatsächlich, dass Journalisten uns aufschreiben, was Politiker tun und wir dann dagegen rebellieren. Und dann hat man so einen Kreislauf an Theater, Arena, der aber diese Konzernchefs außen voll ist. Ja. So. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist...
Wir hatten hier mal, um das auch zu unterstreichen, dass das definitiv so ist, das Buch ausgeliefert besprochen über Amazon. Dort wird hier ganz wunderbar geschildert, wie zum Beispiel Amazon es geschafft hat, kleine Unternehmer, die über Marketplace dann einigermaßen Erfolg hatten mit dem Verkauf von Alltagsprodukten, wie sie die mit ihren Algorithmen und mit einer Preispolitik in die Knie gezwungen haben, sodass die ihr Geschäft aufgeben mussten und Amazon dann selbst diese Produkte herstellte. Und zugleich hat man noch alle Daten verwerten können, die dabei entstanden sind. Das heißt, das sind alles Prozesse, die im Stillen vorgehen. Oder wie Kunden dann in irgendeiner Weise Nachteile erfahren dadurch, weil jetzt plötzlich Amazon sich in eine Werbe, nicht plötzlich, aber seit einer Weile in eine Werbeplattform verwandelt hat, dass man zwar ein Suchfeld hat, aber die ersten Suchergebnisse, die kommen gar nicht der eigentlichen Suche entsprechend müssen, sondern gerade das nach oben angezeigt wird, was vorher für viel Geld an Werbung gekauft wurde. Dies sind alles diese lautlosen Ungleichheiten, die entstehen, die der Papst hier zurecht anspricht. Und da sind wir ja noch gar nicht auf einer staatlichen Ebene, das ist so.
Genau. Jetzt wird der naturwissenschaftlich-technische Fortschritt nicht von der Politik, sondern von Unternehmen ausgebeutet. Also da findet Research and Development und die neue Arbeitsweise statt. Jetzt sagt er, in diesen technokratischen Paradigma hat sich eine menschenfeindliche Anschauung als richtig und normal durchgesetzt. Und wir Menschen sind sozusagen nur noch ein zu optimierendes Objekt. Und dann bindet er das an seine eigene Kirchenlehre. Und das finde ich auch sehr clever, das so zu machen, weil man es nachvollziehen kann. Der Wert einer Zivilisation an sich lässt sich nicht an der Macht ihrer Mittel messen, sondern an der Fürsorge. Und jetzt ein kleines Herzstück hier. Das kann man natürlich jetzt so als Kirchentext vorlesen, aber in der Argumentation ergibt es Vollsinn. Der Mensch gelangt nicht trotz seiner Begrenztheit, sondern oft gerade durch seine Begrenztheit zur Entfaltung. Das ist dieser Satz, der Kreativität sind keine Grenzen gesetzt. Und jeder Drittklässer fragt sich, wieso ist das Quatsch? Also wieso brauche ich dann Kreativität, wenn hier keine Grenzen gesetzt sind? Sagt mir, wo die Grenzen sind. Und dann finden wir gemeinsam einen Weg über die Hürde. Und genau daran wieder zu erinnern und das eben so anzubinden, finde ich so gut. Die Zukunft eines Menschen ist nicht berechenbar. Sie ist seiner Freiheit anvertraut. Genial. Sofort aufs T-Shirt drucken. Nicht nur, weil es ein Spruch ist, der für sich funktioniert, sondern weil er so gut da ableitbar ist.
Kommen wir doch zu Trans- und Posthumanismus. Da heißt es, um die kulturellen Prämissen herauszustellen, die mit der laufenden digitalen Revolution dann hergehen, möchte ich die Aufmerksamkeit nun auf einige Strömungen lenken für die, der Fortschritt in einem über die menschliche Natur hinausgehen besteht und die wir unter den Begriffen Transhumanismus und Posthumanismus zusammenfassen. Sie bilden den ideologischen Hintergrund, der in einigen technologischen Machtzentren anzutreffen ist. Ja, da könnte auch, da könnte ein Name genannt werden. Das macht der Papst natürlich nicht. Und kolonisieren vereinfachend das kollektive Bewusstsein, insbesondere in den Medien und sozialen Netzwerken, indem sie mit einer futuristischen Version vom verbesserten Menschen, in Klammern, enhanced human, also wir hatten ja gerade die Enhance Games, bei denen sich herausgestellt hat, nur ein Weltrekord wurde, glaube ich, gebrochen, der Rest hat dann doch nicht so gut funktioniert. Oder vom Hybriden aus Mensch- und Maschinebegeisterung für die neuen Technologien wecken. Hier will ich auch mal sagen, haben ja die Geisteswissenschaften so mit Donna Haraway auch ihren Anteil gehabt, genau diese Hybridität herzustellen, die das Silicon Valley dann dankbar aufgegriffen hat. Also Prönolatur und Haraway haben sich ja da, ja, im Prinzip haben die ja schriftlich das vorbereitet, was das Silicon Valley damit viel Kapitale umgesetzt hat. Da heißt das Transhumanismus und Posthumanismus fassen jeweils verschiedene Strömungen und Interessenlagen und es ist schwierig, eine eindeutige Beschreibung davon zu geben. Man kann sie mit einem Archipel verschiedener konzeptueller Inseln vergleichen, die jedoch durch dasselbe Meer an Namen verbunden sind, nämlich die zentrale Stellung der Technik und den Traum, die Begrenztheit des menschlichen Lebens zu überwinden. Im Allgemeinen stellt sich der Transhumanismus eine Verbesserung des Menschen durch Technologie vor. Da steht dann nochmal ganz explizit, Biomedizin, Human Engineering, Apparate, Algorithmen mit dem Ziel, Leistung und Fähigkeiten zu steigern. Der Posthumanismus geht vor allem in seiner radikaleren Ausprägung noch weiter. Er kritisiert den Anthropozentrismus und entwirft eine Form der Hybridisierung zwischen Mensch, Maschine und Umwelt. Das geht bis zur Vorstellung, dass dabei eine Schwelle überschritten wird, an der die Menschheit sich selbst überwindet und in eine neue Evolutionsstufe eintritt. Auch wenn diese Hypothesen weitgehend spekulativ bleiben, gewinnen sie an Relevanz, weil sie die kollektive Vorstellungswelt verändern und folglich soziale, wirtschaftliche und politische Entscheidungen beeinflussen. Und das ist der entscheidende Satz. Denn natürlich ist das eine irrsinnige Ideologie und die meisten Leute werden zu Recht nicht daran glauben, dass man das Bewusstsein im Internet hochladen kann, wie in Transcendence mit Johnny Depp, das ist glaube ich ein Film. Die Leute werden zum großen Teil, wie ich muss sagen, das Scheitern dieser ganzen Missionen, das ist ja völlig klar. Und auch werden wir nicht den Mars besiedeln und all dieser Unsinn, der damit einhergeht. Aber auch wenn es spekulativ ist, und Religion ist ja auch was Spekulatives, hier spricht jemand aus Erfahrung, hier spricht der Experte, auch wenn es spekulativ ist, dann ist es dennoch relevant, weil es, wie er richtig sagt, soziale, wirtschaftliche und politische Entscheidungen beeinflusst. Auch wenn, könnte man sagen, wir Gott bislang nicht bewiesen haben, haben wir in dessen Namen sehr schwerwiegende soziale, wirtschaftliche und politische Entscheidungen getroffen. Bis hin zu Religionskriegen und was weiß ich alles. Das heißt, das muss ja gar nicht Realität sein oder werden. Es reicht, dass damit eine wirksame Hypothese in den Raum gestellt wird. Und das zu kritisieren, das ist das Entscheidende. Nicht zu gucken, wie wirksam wird der Post-Humanismus sein, was kann man da bald machen, sondern zu sehen, es verändert schon jetzt das Denken. Es verändert nämlich zum Beispiel das Denken insofern, als man sich selbst sagt, man genüge nicht als Mensch, sondern müsse eigentlich über sich hinausgehen und das Menschliche hinter sich lassen.
Und genau so kann man die Enzyklika lesen, wenn man ganz unzufrieden ist mit dem Zustand der Welt, denn hier findet auch so eine Art Bilanzziehung nach 30, 40 Jahren Digitalisierung statt. Also der digitale Wandel, das muss man jetzt mit umgedrehtem Vorzeichen lesen. Er macht eine ideale, was man sich wünscht und urteilt damit unausgesprochen über die Welt. Der digitale Wandel erfordert dreierlei, die Wahrheit wieder als Gemeingut entdecken, ist also verloren gegangen, die Würde der Arbeit schützen, ist auch verloren gegangen, und die Freiheit von jeglicher Abhängigkeit und Kommerzialisierung zu bewahren, ist auch verloren gegangen. Die Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber der Wahrheit führt zu einem langsamen, aber unaufhaltsamen Abgleitend zum Totalitarismus. Also da sind wir ja mitten drin. Er kommt dann auf Hannah Arendt zu sprechen, wie sie nochmal die Unterscheidung von Fakten und Fiktionen zwischen wahr und falsch damals aufgegriffen hat. Diejenigen, die über gewaltige technische und wirtschaftliche Ressourcen verfügen, verfügen über eine beträchtliche Fähigkeit, kulturelle Veränderungen herbeizuführen und letztlich eine bedeutende Zahl von Menschen zu beeinflussen. Und jetzt hinsichtlich der Frage, was wahr ist in Bezug auf den Menschen und die Welt, den Sinn des Lebens, die Familie und sogar Gott. Dies ist reine Macht ohne Wahrheit. Das ist einfach sehr gut. Die anderen auf subtile und offene Weise aufzwingt, was sie als wahr ansehen sollen. Diejenigen, die digitale Plattform und Medien kontrollieren, verfügen über eine beträchtliche Fähigkeit, auf die kollektive Vorstellungskraft einzuwirken und eine bestimmte Sicht der Wirklichkeit als Erstrebenswert darzustellen. Also nicht nur eine Welt vorzustellen, sondern auch das Erstrebenswerte. Das kennen wir ja auch von Marx. Also so eine Art Traktion, da gleich mitzuliefern, so ein Waren-Fetisch. Jede Technologie bildet diejenigen, die sie nutzen. Die Erziehung zum Umgang mit KI bedeutet daher auch, zu lernen, wann und wofür man sie nicht einsetzen sollte. Also wann einfach eine Arenenverwechslung stattfindet. Ich schaff meine Hausaufgaben schneller, wenn ich das jetzt so mache. Hausaufgaben müssen wir ja alle irgendwie machen. Sonst erstickt die Leichtigkeit der Antwort den Wunsch nach dem Stellen von Fragen. Das muss ich sagen, beobachte ich auch schon in meinem nahen Umfeld, dass typischerweise Sachen, die man so im Gespräch geklärt hat, von denen ich auch sage, man könnte das jetzt nachlesen, dann hat man es gelesen, wenn man es ausdiskutiert hat, hat man es studiert und es wird nicht mehr studiert. Leute sitzen hier in der Chatbots und lesen einfach nur noch für sich so vor sich hin, finde ich nicht gut. Hier kommt ein sehr, sehr, sehr wichtiger Punkt. Es geht um die Arbeit und überhaupt. Ich lese mal drei, wie ich finde, Kerntesen vor. Zum einen, er wird ungewöhnlich deutlich. Es ist notwendig, die derzeitigen Parameter zur Messung des Entwicklungsstandes zu überwinden, die seit über 80 Jahren am Konzept des Bruttoinlandsprodukts ausgerichtet sind.
Sehr gut.
Ungewöhnlich. Das Smartphone wird ja auch namentlich genannt, später im Text. Hier geht es um das Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Das hier, wie wir hier richtig hören, historisch ist. Das heißt, das gab es nicht schon immer. Das wird ja so getan, als gäbe es das schon immer. Es ist im Grunde 80 Jahre alt. Es gibt ja da Bücher, die genau die Entstehungsgeschichte beschreiben. Und dieses ist ein Kriterium, das man eingeführt hat, im Grunde, um auch wirtschaftliche Leistung von Staaten zu messen, die sich im Kriege befinden.
Und er schließt noch an, wir bräuchten Kriterien, die das Leben auf unserem Planeten weder kurz noch langfristig gefährden. Was bedeutet, das Bild gefährdet unser Leben. Ja, sehr gut, Herr Papst. Die Familie ist ein vorrangiges soziales Gut, die grundlegende und unersetzliche Zelle jeder Gesellschaft und Organisation. Da würde ich sagen, das ist nicht nur ein Wunsch, sondern das ist empirisch so. Da kann jetzt jeder noch so viel auch kommunenen Gedanken haben. So um die Familie kommt man nicht um rum. Denn wenn politische und wirtschaftliche Entscheidungen sie in eine marginale und zweitrangige Rolle drängen, wird das authentische Wachstum des gesamten sozialen Gefüges beeinträchtigt. Da muss man sagen, das ist vielleicht noch größerer Konflikt, den da mit JD Vans hat, als zum Thema KI. Und Arbeitsmarktpolitik muss der Präkarität als normalem Lebenszustand entgegenwirken. Er markiert also 2026, Präkarität ist normaler Lebensstandard. In der New York Times stehen schon Texte über die permanent Underclass aus diesem neuen Arbeitszusammenhängen. Deine Lieblingspodcasterin Taylor Lawrence hat schon einen ganzen Podcast dazu gemacht.
Habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Thema Ausbeutung, Thema Kolonialismus.
Also bezogen auf die Digitalwirtschaft.
Ja, genau. Also war richtig The Permanent Underclass. Mal so eine Überschrift in der New York Times. Sklaverei, ich verweise kurz drauf. Also er hat sich entschuldigt dafür, dass man 1.800 Jahre von Seiten der Kirche sich da verirrt hatte. So, der Frieden. Wir müssen unbedingt über die Waffen und den Frieden reden. Der Friede ist Voraussetzung für Gemeinwohl. Friede ist nicht ein Thema unter vielen, sondern eine Voraussetzung für das globale Gemeinwohl und ein Prüfstein für die moralische Reife der Völker, insbesondere derjenigen, die Regierungsverantwortung tragen. Im Sinne von, wir sehen ja, wie selbst Donald Trump, der wirklich einen Wahlkampf gemacht hat mit ich halte euch aus den Kriegen aus, jetzt einfach sagt, naja, den Internet hat einen Vortrag gehalten, dann machen wir einen Krieg, ja, so ganz solop, ja. Entscheidungen über Leben und Tod sind heute schneller und unpersönlicher. Die Technik hat sie von der Ethik losgelöst. Deswegen auch dieses klare, nicht nur bekannte Forderung. Kein Gerede vorm gerechten Krieg, ja, einfach gar kein Krieg. Wir verlieren unser historisches Gedächtnis, besorgniserregender Verlust an historischem Gedächtnis in Bezug auf Kriege und was sie bedeuten. Das Verblassen der Zeitzeugen, Schoa und der beiden Weltkriege führt dazu, dass Fake News und narrative Manipulation die gewonnenen Erkenntnisse verschleiern. Ja, also wenn Google das nächste Mal hier, wir können jetzt mit KI-Fotos und so weiter. Das ist alles Verschleierungstaktik von Wahrheit und Wirklichkeit. Die Kriegsökonomie wird von ihm direkt thematisiert. Wir haben neue bewaffnete Akteure, dschihadistische Gruppen, private Milizen, kriminelle Netzwerke. Ich würde sagen, der Krieg ist, kennen wir ja aus Afghanistan und so, wo es plötzlich hieß, da sind mehr Contractor als Soldaten. Also mittlerweile in der Ukraine und so, da sind ja gar keine ausländischen Soldaten, aber ganz viel ausländische Flugtechnik und so.
Auch ausländische Soldaten werden wir gleich noch zukommen.
Ja, die auch, aber ich würde sagen, auf jeden einzelnen kommen dann 100 Drohnen oder so, die da einfach rumfliegen. Also ganz wichtig, liebe CDUler, liebe deutsche Kirche usw. Wichtiger denn je, die Überwindung der Theorie des gerechten Krieges Das ist absolut relevant, was ihr hier schreibt.
Die evangelische Kirche hat sich ja rauszureden versucht, indem sie sagt, ja, ja, gerechter Krieg ist schwierig, wir nennen es mal gerechten Frieden.
Ja, es ist einfach völlig verirrt. Der Papst klärt euch auf, liebe deutschen Kläriker. Hinter all dem steht ein falscher, ein falscher Realismus.
Hier würde ich nur ganz kurz noch mal auf den Salon verweisen. Ich glaube, es war November 2025. Da habe ich diese Friedensdenkschrift der evangelischen Kirche mir angesehen.
Also fast, als hätte der Papst das mitgelesen. Ja, ich lese mal vor, hinter all dem steht ein falscher Realismus, der nicht nur auf der vorherrschenden Logik der Stärke beruht, sondern auch auf kulturellen und anthropologischen Überzeugungen, als ob Krieg ein unvermeidlicher Bestandteil der menschlichen Natur wäre. Ja, auf den Punkt. So sei es schon immer gewesen, heißt es, abgesehen von kurzen Unterbrechungen, also die Friedensdividente, und so werde es auch immer bleiben. Der Putin wird uns 2029 angreifen und so. Nee, er wird vielleicht mal drantagehen. Dagegen, im Gegenteil, ist der Friede weder eine naive Hoffnung, also nicht belächeln lassen von irgendwelchen, ach, das ist ein Nauflinger, nein, das ist keine naive Hoffnung, und auch nicht die bloße Abwiesenheit von Krieg. Es ist das stets mögliche Ergebnis von Gerechtigkeit und Nächstenliebe. Also wenn die Kirche irgendwie kommt und was vom gerechten Frieden, muss man sagen, muss man sie selber an ihre eigene Lehre erinnern.
Ja.
Dass das da einfach anders steht in den Büchern.
So weit sind wir jetzt schon gekommen, ja.
Das ist einfach richtig gut.
Das ist auch übrigens nicht nur von der evangelischen Kirche weiter entfernt, sondern auch von der deutschen katholischen Bischofskonferenz.
Er macht das hier zum Schluss in fünf Sprüngen, also gerade zum Thema Krieg. Entwaffnen wir die Worte und wir werden dazu beitragen, die Erde zu entwaffnen. Wir sehen ja, wie sehr mit Worten heute schon vorbereitet wird, dass man ja klatschig ist, wir haben doch lange darüber geredet. Kommen wir in Augustinus. Die Gerechtigkeit des Einzelnen und der Frieden aller sind miteinander eng verbunden. Gerechtigkeit und Friede küssen sich. Möchtest du Frieden erreichen, dann übe Gerechtigkeit. Da könnte man auch sagen, ja, das ist Sozialstaatspolitik gleich noch dabei. Also derzeit wird ja Krieg gegen den Bürgergeldempfänger und gegen Putin geführt. Das ist vielleicht nicht so vereinbar mit, dass die CDU grad regiert. Die Perspektive der Opfer ist einzunehmen. Wenn schon Realismus, dann gesunder Realismus. Man darf nicht einfach Fakten auswählen, sie verzerren und neu benennen. Also Masalla, der dann, ach so wusste ich gar nicht. Ach ja, ich hab einfach mal was zu erzählen. Und das alles natürlich erstens im Dialog, zweitens im Multilateralismus. Alle müssen wieder ins Gespräch miteinander kommen. Und jetzt noch ein Wort, das letzte an die Jungen. Die jungen Generationen sind da hingegen zu erziehen, dass sie den Entwicklungsverlauf der Technologien nicht für unabänderlich halten, sondern daran glauben, dass dieser durch persönliche und kollektive Verantwortungsübernahme in rechte Bahnen gelenkt werden kann. Das ist einer der wertvollsten Dienste für das Gemeinwohl. Das ist aber ein Auftrag an die Älteren, das den Jüngeren zu zeigen. Also einfach der perfekte Text zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, der sich einfach gegen alle wendet. Also wenn man gegen alle ist, ist man auf Seiten des Papstes.
Wir kommen jetzt zu all diesen Szenarien, die Papst Leo beschreibt bzw. vor denen er warnt. Starten wir mal mit der deutschen Politik, kurz um dann ins Internationale zu gehen. Zunächst wollen wir auf den Salon hinweisen. Das ist die Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Man bekommt etwas dafür, nämlich den Salon. Einmal im Monat sprechen wir da sehr ausführlich über wichtige Bücher. Eine oder zwei Bücher diskutieren wir zusammen, in der Regel zwei, zweieinhalb Stunden lang. Dann noch Empfehlungen von uns, also nochmal eine große Extrafolge. Diesmal geht es um das Buch Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Die stellen sich die Frage, wie ist es, dass er eigentlich mit der Freiheit der Kunst in Deutschland gerade so bestellt? Vor allem, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit der Kunstfreiheit, wenn es sich doch häufig um staatlich geförderte Kunst oder unterstützte Kunst handelt, gilt ja auch die Kunstfreiheit, wie wir sie so abstrakt verstehen. Das ist ein sicherlich wichtiger Debattenbeitrag nach berlinale Dokumentarskandalen und Wolfram Weimars ganz eigene Auslegung von Amt und Würde. Wir sprechen aber noch über ein anderes, sehr relevantes Buch von einem Autor, das ist ein Buch, das wir schon vor etwa zwei Jahren besprochen haben, zum Thema, wie würde eigentlich eine solche Machtübernahme aussehen, wenn die AfD regiert. Das haben wir mit sehr viel Gewinn gelesen. Nun hat Arne Semmsraud ein neues Buch geschrieben, womit er uns deutlich machen will, wir müssen aber nicht die Hände in den Schoß legen und auf diese Machtübernahme warten, sondern man kann sich mobilisieren. Wie heißt das Buch?
Gegenmacht, die Zivilgesellschaft schlägt zurück. Vielleicht haben wir es nächste Woche schon gedruckt, aber jetzt lese ich noch von Bildschirm. Ich bin natürlich sehr gespannt, denn Arne Semmsraud kennen wir als konstruktiven Aufbauer im päpstlichen Sinne. Also er wird einfach an der Stadtmauer hochgezogen, fragt den Staat und so. Und wir hängen ja alle so ein bisschen zwischen den Seilen. Und der Papst hat jetzt auch Anmerkungen gemacht, aber uns nicht unbedingt gesagt, wie der nächste Schritt aussieht. Und da wir das letzte Mal schon das Wort remonstrieren und so kennengelernt haben, sind wir mal gespannt, was wir diesmal so lernen.
Gegenmacht und Kunstfreiheit, das sind die Themen, das sind die beiden Bücher, über die wir dann ausführlich diskutieren. Das alles kann man hören, wenn man den Salon abonniert. Wenn man den Salon abonniert hat, dann bekommt man auch alles in einem RSS-Feed. Braucht sich gar keine Sorgen zu machen, man verpasst nichts. Das ist am besten möglich über Steady. Man geht auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Dort kommt man dann zu Steady. Wenn man auf den goldenen Salon-Button klickt, damit ist man dann schon ganz einfach dabei. Es gibt eigentlich keine Hürden. Es gibt in der Regel auch überhaupt gar keine Probleme. Und das ist sicherlich auch eine Zukunft des Podcasts generell, glaube ich, dass wir werden heute noch über verrückte Clips und sowas sprechen. Jedenfalls ist das die eine Möglichkeit für die, die schon bei Apple sind und es bequem mögen. Die können auch über Apple direkt uns den Podcast abonnieren. Außerdem gibt es noch die Möglichkeit für jene, die bei Patreon sind, dort ein Abo abzuschließen.
Genau. Wir präferieren aber Steady schon allein, weil wir euch dann sagen können, da ist alles. Also jeder einzelne Salon, das komplette Archiv.
Und ein sehr guter Überblick.
Ein sehr guter Überblick und alle Kapitelmarken. Und man kriegt immer das Cover. Und es ist ein RSS-Feed. Man kann ihn in jedem Player hören, mit dem man typischerweise Podcasts hört. Das ist sehr gut.
Vielen Dank für die Unterstützung. Beginnen wir mit der deutschen Politik. Der Grünen-Vorsitzende Felix Banaschak war bei Tilo Jung im Interview. Nur der Koch hat Clips draus gemacht. Tilo hat aber auch selbst einen Clip draus gemacht. Und wir werden den jetzt spielen. Denn das ist ja eine Frage, die er Felix Banaschak stellt, die mir auch direkt kommen würde und ich mir auch als Politiker selbst wahrscheinlich laufend stellen würde. Wir haben, wie gesagt, über dieses Buch von Arne Semsroth im Salon gelesen, wie wäre so eine Machtübernahme der AfD? Das wird nicht angenehm. Nun schauen wir mal, wie diese Gegenmacht dann aussehen würde. Ist aber problematisch, wenn die Gegenmacht auch gar nicht so richtig weiß bzw. sich sagt, so interessante Frage. Wir hören mal rein.
Ihr wollt aber auch, ihr seid auch dafür, dass es mehr Soldaten bei der Bundeswehr gibt? Ja, was sagst du?
Wir halten es für notwendig. Es ist eine extrem bedrückende Realität, aber ich halte sie für notwendig.
Jetzt gibt's viele vielleicht grüne, junge Männer, die grün werden und so weiter, Fernsehen sagen, Felix, du hast recht. Ich gehe jetzt zur Bundeswehr, verpflichte mich. Was sollen die machen, wenn es einen AfD-Verteidigungsminister gibt? Dem dienen?
Dann können sie immer noch desertieren, aber die...
Warte mal, ein Momentchen. Das Wort desertieren haben wir seit vier Jahren aus unserem Wortschatz gestrichen. Niemand darf desertieren. Wer in Russland desertiert, den lassen wir nicht rein. Und wer in der Ukraine desertiert, den schicken wir sofort zurück. Niemand desertiert hier. Was ist das für ein Staatsbürgerverständnis?
Desertieren ist ja wirklich ein Straftatsbestand. Also du kannst ja nicht desertieren. Das ist ja nicht vorgesehen. Wir hören mal weiter.
Erst einmal ist mein ganzes politisches Handeln darauf ausgerichtet, dass es keinen AFD-Verteidigungsminister gibt. Das ist mir völlig klar, aber diese Konsequenzen, wo musst du bedenken? Das ist eine mögliche Konsequenz, aber die sollen desertieren, wenn AFD-Verteidigungsminister ist.
Oder sollen sie auch nur auf dem Verlängerungsminister gehen?
Ich gebe offen zu, dass ich diese Frage noch nie gestellt bekommen habe und deswegen jetzt eine sehr spontane Antwort gebe.
Da haben wir ja mehrere Armutszeugnisse. Einmal, dass Journalisten sonst nie ihm diese Frage gestellt haben, die ja sehr nahelegend ist. Und er sich selbst diese Frage aber auch nie gestellt hat, finde ich ja auch bedenklich.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Vor allem, die Umfragen sagen doch 30% CDU, 30% AfD. Das verschiebt sich so ein bisschen intern. Dann haben die einmal 32, andere 28, wie auch immer. Aber wir sind hier kurz vor verfassungsgebender Mehrheit schwarz-blau.
Ja.
Also ein AfD-Verteidigungsminister ist doch jetzt nicht aus, ist doch kein Phantasmer oder so.
Nein, du erst.
Hör zu.
Ich würde einem AfD-Verteidigungsminister in einer AfD-Regierung sicherlich nicht in der gleichen Loyalität gegenübertreten wie der demokratischen Regierung, die wir gerade haben.
Also sollen die desertieren, die Soldaten, wenn die AfD... Es ist jetzt keine utopische Frage.
Na, es ist in dem Sinne schon eine nicht ganz naheliegende Frage, weil wir weit davon entfernt sind.
Or the other way around.
Ich würde zumindest sagen, also die Verknüpfung ist aus meiner Sicht deswegen nicht ganz so klar, weil wir im Moment erst mal darüber sprechen.
Also, so bitter und so hart das klingt, und ich weiß, damit macht man sich nicht beliebt, wenn man das ausspricht, aber ein Angriff Russlands auf die NATO und damit indirekt auch auf Deutschland ist gerade wahrscheinlicher als die Übernahme des Verteidigungsministeriums eines anderen Regierungspostens im Moment durch die AfD. Nee. Nein. Beziehungsweise, man könnte es ja machen, angeblich soll das ja mit dem Jahr 2029, dann kommt der Putin mit dem Jahr 2029 und dann haben wir auch gleichzeitig die AfD-Regierung, denn dann ist ja wieder Wahl. Unglaublich.
So hart und traurig das ist, aber sollen junge Männer auch in einem AfD-Verteidigungsminister dienen?
Das ist die Frage. Ich würde, das ist nicht im luftleeren Raum.
Wie gesagt, diese Frage stellt sich mir jetzt gerade zum ersten Mal, weil ich dieses Szenario an das AfD-Verteidigungsminister nicht für real halte, aber wenn es so wäre, dann würde ich sagen, ist es besser diesem nicht zu dienen.
Hält das nicht für real? Und es wäre besser nicht zu dienen. Ja, es ist besser nicht zu dienen. Vor allen Dingen, wenn es eine schwarz-blaue Koalition geben würde, was glaubt man denn, was die AfD gerne für Ministerposten hätte? Umweltminister wollen die vielleicht werden. Umweltfamilie, nur Gedönenswasser. Und Entwicklungshilfe, genau. Das wird das Thema sein. Unglaublich. Ja, also das ist jetzt die Voraussetzung für all das, was wir jetzt im Folgenden hören. Wir beschäftigen uns jetzt mit der modernen Kriegsführung, das heißt mit Drohnen. Dann beginnen wir mit Palantir und Helsing. Denn wir haben jetzt das Glück, dass im OMR-Podcast jemand zu Gast war, der erst bei Palantir war und jetzt bei Helsing groß ist. Wir hören aber jetzt erstmal, wie sich überhaupt dieses Podcastgespräch angebahnt hat. Philipp Westermeier plaudert mal ein bisschen aus dem Maschinenraum.
Kurzer Einblick in den Maschinenraum. Vor einigen Jahren war doch mal der damalige Chef der Bildzeitung, der Johannes Boje, hier im Podcast zu Gast. Und wir haben uns damals gut verstanden und immer Kontakt gehalten, über dies und jenes mal gesprochen. Und dann kam es so, dass der Johannes Marketing-Chef bei Helsing geworden ist, mit einem großen deutschen Defense-Tag.
Man will eigentlich direkt aufhören zuzuhören, ne? Leute, Leute, Leute.
Über 10 Milliarden Bewertung. Und dann habe ich mit Johannes geschrieben und gesagt, Mensch, wie wäre es denn mal, einer eurer Gründer kommt in den Podcast und da meinte er, ja, können wir machen.
Aber er hatte dann noch eine bessere Idee.
Und ich empfehle dir für den Podcast jemanden aus unseren Reihen, den wirst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht kennen, aber der ist wirklich ein krasser Gast. Und ich so, okay, wer wäre das denn? Ja, der Robert Fink. Und was ist mit dem? Ja, der hat in der frühen Phase unter dem Alex Karp Palantir mit aufgebaut, ist dann in der frühen Phase zu Helsing gewechselt, hat das jetzt schon sehr stark entwickelt und ist an den ganzen neuen Projekten dran. Die bauen da jetzt ja Flugzeuge, Raketen und ist dann ein Typ, der denkt einfach extrem groß und kriegt die Dinge dann auch wirklich hin.
Ja, was hat denn Palantir hingekriegt? Außer, dass sie einfach sagen, uns sind alle Regeln egal, deswegen machen wir den großen Datenfusionsreaktor. Also das könnte ich auch. Und eine Marktkapitalisierung über Börsenwerte, also wirklich jeder von uns widersprechen. Das war es, diese zwei Punkte. Das ist eine tolle Leistung. Aber sehr gut, dass da echt gebaut wird. Das ist bestimmt, also jetzt bei der Frage, ist das jetzt Turm zum Babel oder ist das... Jetzt müssen wir uns ernsthaft mal vergegenwärtigen, wie sieht denn der Robert aus, der jetzt dort sitzt, der empfohlen wurde von dem ehemaligen Bildschiff Johannes Boje?
Also du bekommst jetzt wieder einen Typ aus Neumünster daher. Aber du hast ja schon ganz anders als du. Du kannst verstehen, was ich meine, wenn ich sage, man hat das Gefühl, da kommt jemand und arbeitet an den ganz großen Themen unserer Zeit, ganz geheimnisvoll und sitzt jetzt hier im Holzfäller-Pulley. Du hattest dir so eine schlecht gebundene Fliege vorgestellt. Ja, sie war mit Zopf und so. Du könntest auch aus so einer Öko-Bewegung kommen.
Ja, genau richtig. Kommen wir jetzt gleich zum Punkt, wie es ihm geht und wie er so tickt? Das nicht. Wir reden jetzt gleich über Inhaltliches. Das Bemerkenswerte finde ich, dass man im Jahr 2026 noch immer so tut, als sei das Militär irgendwas von Leuten, die kahlrasierte Schädel haben und so aussehen, als hätten sie in den 80er-Jahren Filme Chuck Norris die Hauptrolle gehabt. Nein, natürlich hat sich das völlig geändert. Und all diese Entwicklerkonferenzen, die man da jetzt so bei YouTube sich ansehen kann, da weiß man nicht, ist das jetzt hier gerade die grüne Partei, die sich trifft, um zu tagen? Oder sind das irgendwelche Leute, die sich verabredet haben, um boldern zu gehen? Da gibt es nicht mehr den Unterschied. Und da trägt auch auf jeden Fall keiner mehr einen Anzug. Das sind halt Techies. Ja, es sind Techies und da ist es egal. Zu dem Werdegang dieses Robert Fink.
Und ja, dann habe ich in dem Bereich promoviert. In einem Feld, das heißt Datenbanktheorie, hat eigentlich mit der echten Welt relativ wenig zu tun, wie die meisten Promotionen. Und ist quasi die Computer oder die Informatik und Mathematiktheorie hinter Datenbanken, wie man sie kennt. Also wenn man sowas wie Excel aufmacht oder eine Postgres Datenbank oder sowas, die Mathematiktheorie, die dahinter steht, heißt Datenbanktheorie. Und ja, da habe ich dreieinhalb Jahre verbracht. In Oxford, war das Oxford? Das war in Oxford, genau. Und genau, habe ich dann, glaube ich, in Oxford von Palantir begeistern lassen, weil Palantir hat zu dem Zeitpunkt ziemlich viel in Oxford rekrutiert. Haben alle möglichen Leute aus meinem Lab damals, bei Dan Altiano, viele Grüße, Dan, wenn du es hörst, bei Palantir Internships gemacht oder tatsächlich angefangen. Und das war damals einfach eine ziemlich starke Marke. So die haben eine Marke aufgebaut, dass sie die allerbesten und den allerbesten Informatiker und Developer in der Welt anziehen.
Einfach eine starke Marke. Sehr gute Marke. Total Überwachung. Super Marke. Nun aber der Ruf der Heimat.
Ich glaube, ich habe mein Herz dafür entschieden, dass ich meine Talente erstens noch mal von vorne einsetzen sollte. Also einfach noch mal was von Null aufbauen. Und vielleicht auch für eine Überzeugung, die einfach ein bisschen europäischer ist. My talents are used here. Und nicht unbedingt für eine Firma in Amerika, but not necessarily for a company in America, sondern einfach für Deutschland, but just for Germany, for Europe, hier was aufbauen.
to build something here.
Also ich meine, also I mean, das ist schon so ein bisschen so a really patriotic spirit der da mitschwingt. Yes, patriotisch klingt für mich als Wort jetzt ein bisschen zu krass. Also ich glaube nicht, also I wouldn't choose the word patriot myself, aber es ist wahrscheinlich, wenn du nachguckst, jetzt auch nicht falsch.
Ja, das passt einfach sehr gut zu unserer Pabst-Lehrenstudie grad, die wir, das sind Leute auf dem richtigen Weg. Und dieses Wort Patriotismus, das klebt natürlich an so merkwürdigen Leuten, mit denen man eher nichts zu tun haben will. Aber de facto ist es natürlich ein Patriotismus. Was soll es auch anderes sein? Jetzt wollen wir mal hören, wie Philipp Westermeyer auf die Sache blickt.
Okay, also gleichzeitig sind die ja schon auch gebaut. Ich meine, ihr seid jetzt ja keine Dual-Use-Firma, sondern ihr wollt ja damit auch wirklich am Ende beim Feind Schaden anrichten. Das tun wir. Also die, ja. Ist das für dich ein Thema? Ja, also ich glaube, in voller Transparenz, mir würde es natürlich besser gehen, wenn es diese Firma nicht geben müsste sozusagen.
Aber man muss halt dominieren. Das ist das Schöne. Wer muss hier dominieren, damit ihr die Freiheit lebt? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt seit Jahren Krieg. Wir hören seit Jahren irgendwelche Leute aus Rüstungskonzernen. Hat man jemals irgendwo gehört, dass da jemand sagt, wir haben so richtig geile Raketen, das macht richtig rum? Sollen wir die los schicken? Es macht Riesenspaß. Natürlich sprechen die alle anders davon. Ja.
Also zeigen die theoretischen Aspekte, wie irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Flugdynamik funktioniert und so weiter. Das ist so ein bisschen wie wieder zu Hause ankommen. Und witzigerweise ist es, also es fühlt sich eigentlich im Moment sehr gut an, dass sich nicht nur Softwarebau, die irgendwie wahnsinnig abstrakt in irgendwelchen Cloud-Servern läuft, sondern Softwarebau, die mit der physikalischen Welt in Verbindung steht und die man anfassen kann, nur irgendwie draufdrücken kann.
Wo man draufdrücken kann. Also die steht mit der physikalischen Welt insofern in Verbindung, als sie Menschen und Gebäude zerstören kann. Das machen Drohnen. Ja, er hat damals promoviert zum Thema Datenbanken, Postgres und so. Ich möchte hier kurz anmerken, man kann aus solchen Datenbanken auch anderes machen. Also unsere Olivia läuft auch auf Postgres. Und da kann man einfach jeden Morgen hören, wie sich unsere Hörerschaft ab morgen dann zum Thema Vatikan und Turmbau zu Babel und wollen wir lieber nicht und sollen wir nochmal drüber nachdenken, gemeinsam zusammenfindet und diskutiert. Und Olivia bindet das dann alles zusammen, damit man einen Tag später weiß, welche Diskussion man gerade verpasst hat. Das könnte man auch bauen. Man könnte auch was bauen, was zum Beispiel den medizinischen Fortschritt beschleunigt. Man könnte ganz viele Dinge bauen, was für die Schule vielleicht mal... Mit Datenbanken, was dann auch in der Realität eine Auswirkung hat. Schule wäre auch ein schönes Beispiel. Man muss auf den Knopf drücken können, dann will man was sehen, damit was Häuser, die zusammenfallen. Knallt. Ja, und das reiz ich ja ein in jetzt eine Entwicklung. Die Tagesschau berichtete im Februar, die Bundeswehr bekommt sogenannte Kamikaze-Dronen. Das hat der Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestags entschieden und damit die Pläne aus dem Verteidigungsministerium gebilligt. Zunächst sollen für insgesamt rund 540 Millionen Euro Waffensysteme der deutschen Hersteller Helsing, also das Unternehmen, für das Robert Fink arbeitet, und Stark Defense bestellt werden. Die Bundeswehr… Warte mal, Stark Defense, also wie Iron Man? Ja. Ah, okay. In Stark Defense, ich glaube, da haben wir nachher noch mal einen Clip zu, ist auch Petar Thiel investiert. Die Bundeswehr lerne dabei auch von den Erfahrungen der Ukraine und profitiere von Rüstungskooperationen. Kamikaze-Dronen werden ferngesteuert, können Sprengstoff abwerfen und direkt im Ziel explodieren. Wir hören mal, wie das denn aussehen könnte in der Zukunft. Westermail fragt ob es da so etwas wie einen Krieg ohne Menschen geben könnte.
Klar, es heißt Verteidigung und es sind Verteidigungssysteme, aber am Ende des Tages muss man damit klarkommen, dass solche Systeme natürlich auch eingesetzt werden, um andere Systeme zu zerstören. Und ja, da wird auch auf Panzer geschossen, in denen noch Menschen sitzen. Das ist einfach die Realität. Ist es denn in Zukunft wohl so, dass Menschen am Krieg nur noch im Hintergrund partizipieren und im Wesentlichen drohen, gehen und kämpfen oder irgendwelche automatischen Gelenken, Fahrzeuge? Oder glaubst du, dass es weiterhin auch viele menschliche Opfer geben wird? Ist ein bisschen schwer vorher zu sagen. Also ein Aspekt da ist, viele Waffensysteme, die im Moment noch menschliche Operateure brauchen, werden in Zukunft nicht mehr unbedingt menschliche Operateure brauchen?
Also zur Definition des Genozids gehört auch der Aspekt, ich hab mir extra die Le Monde Diplomatiek dazu gekauft, in der Text gleich auf Seite 1, also Deckblatt drauf stand. Gehört auch, ah ja, genau. Also Technik des Genozids von Ilyal Weizmann. Einfach nur zu sagen, es sind keine Menschen gestorben, reicht nicht. Sondern es geht auch um die Lebensgrundlagen, die Infrastruktur und so weiter. Also diese Idee, neben dem gerechten Krieg, einen Krieg ohne Menschen zu führen, bei dem man einfach ganz Gaza raffa plattmacht. Und jetzt im Libanon auch, weil das Drehbuch so geil ist. Wir haben ja den Menschen vorher gesagt, sie sollen flüchten. Also die Menschen sind dann noch am Leben, aber deren Infrastruktur ist so weit zerstört, dass sie selbst, und das beschreibt ihr dann im Text ganz wunderbar, Israel geht ja mittlerweile so weit, dass sie sagen, die Menschen sollen nicht mal die zerstörte Stadt als ihre Stadt wiedererkennen. Also wir bomben so klar kleine Hügel und andere sichtbare Marker einer Stadt weg, wo das einfach gar nicht wiedererkannt wird. Das gehört zur Definition des Genozids. Ja, also worüber die gerade reden ist, kann man Genozid machen. Wir sind an einem Punkt angelangt, wo auch die Vorstellung ist, bald werden die Waffen das unter sich aushandeln, den Krieg. Die 8-jährigen Menschen stehen hier und hier ist die Welt im Krieg. Ja, genau. Also Moskau schickt Drohnen, Berlin schickt Drohnen und die Drohnen klären das unter sich. Das ist so ein bisschen so eine Vorstellung, Entschuldigung, das ist ein bisschen ein Beispiel unter der Gürtellinie. Man kauft ein Dildo und ein Flashlight und sagt, die sollen jetzt mal den Geschlechtsverkehr für sich regeln. Wir halten unsere Haus aus der Sache. Es ist so schräg. Es ist einfach Wahnsinn. Und wenn wir jetzt gleich tiefer reingehen in Drohnen und dann auch ein bisschen nach Israel gehen, dann können wir doch feststellen, es geht immer um die Vernichtung von Menschen im Krieg. Auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Wir haben ja hier über Demografie wirklich viel geredet. Und genau das ist der Punkt. Wie viele Soldaten schafft man es, von der Gegenseite umzubringen oder deren Lebensgrundlagen zu zerstören. Das ist der Sinn. Und gerade bei Drohnen, weil bei Drohnen ist es ja nicht so, dass die einfach so was absichern. Also die sind ja nicht einfach so stationierte Soldaten, die darauf achten, dass hier Brunnen gebaut werden wie in Afghanistan, dass da nicht die Taliban zurückkommen oder so, sondern Drohnen sind dazu da, dass zerstört wird.
Ja. Einfach weil die Software- und KI-Systeme solche Systeme besser steuern können. Das ist aber auch eine ethische Frage. Wollen wir das eigentlich? Wollen wir als Deutschland oder als Europa, dass solche Systeme autonom eingesetzt werden? Und da ist für mich im Moment die klare Antwort nein. Es muss eigentlich immer sozusagen unter menschlicher Kontrolle stattfinden. Das englische Wort dafür ist Operator in the Loop. Also der menschliche Operateur muss sozusagen verstehen können, was diese Systeme machen, was sie planen, was sie vorhaben. Und am Ende des Tages Ja oder Nein geben dazu.
Ja, wir haben immer einen Operator in the Loop, weil jemand sitzt im Weißen Haus und gibt einen Befehl. Ja. Die Frage ist dann, wie viele Menschen sind noch in the Loop? Ja, und wie viele Entscheidungen werden eigentlich getroffen? Und wie viele Menschen sind für wie viele Angriffe zuständig? Denn wir werden jetzt gleich Zahlen hören, wo man sagt, ja, da ist noch irgendjemand. Da ist ein Operator in the Loop. Die Frage ist nur, hat er einen Überblick über die Angriffe im Einzelnen? Und da ist die Antwort natürlich nein.
Aber auf dem Schlachtfeld selber kommen noch Menschen. Früher, wenn man sich die Bilder anguckt, da sind Menschen auf Pferden miteinander geritten oder später dann irgendwie in Panzern aufeinander losgegangen. Jetzt hat man das Gefühl, da sitzt irgendwer im Hintergrund und fliegt diese Drohnen.
Guckt der gar keine Nachrichten? Also wir haben doch nur Opfer, Opfer, Opfer. Und die Eingriffe finden auch vermehrt wieder in Kiew statt. Die Leute haben schon gedacht, wir haben es überstanden und so. Der Krieg ist da drüben. Jetzt ist plötzlich diese Drohnenrealität. Krieg ist überall. Ja, es werden Krankenhäuser zerbombt. Es ist bekannt, dass Tausende pro Monat auf der ukrainischen wie auf der russischen Seite stemmen. Wir haben das in Gaza gesehen. Hat man da irgendwie den Eindruck, das geht jetzt ohne zivile Opfer?
Ich glaube, es ist in der Realität ein bisschen komplizierter, weil das natürlich auch ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel zum Beispiel von Reichweiten ist. Also wenn man sich jetzt die Ukraine anguckt, da stehen sich im Prinzip, das ist quasi ein Grabenkampf, aber 50 Kilometer voneinander entfernt. Da stehen die einzelnen Truppen und wenn es jetzt zwei Gruppen mit Drohnen sind, jeweils mit ihren Drohnen und versuchen im Prinzip sich gegenseitig zu bekämpfen. Die Graben sind halt nicht mehr, man kann sie nicht mehr direkt sehen, aber man fliegt seine Drohne auf die andere Seite und guckt halt, wo die anderen Leute und die anderen Fahrzeuge sind. Und es sind immer noch Menschen. Und man wirkt nicht gegen völlig autonome Systeme, also einen Haufen Blech, sondern da sind immer noch Menschen beteiligt.
Das ist die sogenannte Killing-Zone, der sich alle befindet. Genau, wir reden nicht mehr von 14 Gramm, sondern von der Killing-Zone. Die wird jeden Tag größer. Wir hören weiter, was Robert Fink über Helsing und die Zukunft dieses Unternehmens zu sagen hat.
Ihr denkt jetzt wirklich alles, was geht? Ja, habe ich vorhin gesagt. Die Ambition der Firma, wie gesagt, ist eine der größten, eine der wichtigsten Verteidigungsfirmen in Europa zu werden. Wie wir das machen, ist nicht, indem wir irgendwie probieren, Technologie nachzubauen von vor 20 Jahren, sondern uns insbesondere darauf zu konzentrieren, die Sachen an den Markt zu bringen und zu entwickeln, die durch neue Technologien ermöglicht werden, also insbesondere die Kaite. Okay. Und das heißt irgendwie, bis hin zu einem eigenen, in Anführungszeichen, Starlink, zumindest Teil davon für Deutschland. Also das ist ja schon eine riesige Aufgabe. Es ist eine riesige Aufgabe, ja.
Ja, eine sehr große Aufgabe. Also ich höre hier wirklich genau das raus, weshalb der Elk Papst meinte, ich muss meine Enzyklika schreiben. Die Gia auf der einen, dieser komische Wettbewerb auf der anderen, den man plötzlich in Sinne Organisationslogik importiert. Also wir sind jetzt dafür verantwortlich, dass sich Deutschland gegen Putin verteidigtigt in der Zukunft. Ja, und so geschieht es ja dann auch hier der Bayerische Rundfunk.
Eine Kampfdrohne der Bayerischen Firma Helsing. Wenn sie feindliche Ziele identifiziert, kann sie diese auf menschlichen Befehlen auch angreifen. Geld für den Kauf solcher Drohnen hat der Bundestag heute freigegeben. Sie sollen zunächst bei der Litauen-Brigade eingesetzt werden.
Es ist eine neue Fähigkeit, die die Bundeswehr braucht. Auch aus den Erkenntnissen über in der Ukraine gewinnen, dass diese Art von Munition, diese Art von Waffe einfach eine besondere Bedeutung hat.
Der Haushaltsausschuss hat allerdings die Auftragssumme für die Drohnenhersteller Helsing und Stark auf jeweils 1 Milliarde Euro gedeckelt. Ursprünglich lag die Obergrenze höher.
Wir versuchen durch diese Deckelung, den Wettbewerb unter den potenziellen Kandidaten jetzt hier zu steigern und am Ende das kostengünstigste, aber auch das beste Produkt für unsere Bundeswehr zu bekommen.
Das ist ganz interessant, dass er das jetzt sagt, denn er könnte auch hinzufügen, wir wollen nicht den Fehler machen wie bei den anderen Rüstungskonzernen, die wir einfach so mit Geld zuschütten, dass die gar keinen Wettbewerb mehr haben und einfach Rheinmetall erwartet, dass wir das gesamte Sondervermögen überweisen. Vor allem, wir wollen einfach, dass der Wettbewerb ist.
Bei den Drohnen, die das Berliner Unternehmen Stark produziert, bereitet der Opposition Sorgen, dass der Trump-nahe Investor Peter Thiel an dem Unternehmen beteiligt ist.
Wir wissen nicht abschließend, welchen Einfluss Peter Thiel auf dieses Unternehmen hat und letztlich auch dann auf bestimmte Informationen, die mit der Produktion dieser Drohnen und dem späteren Einsatz bei der Bundeswehr dann zusammenhängen.
Der Verteidigungsminister verweist heute auf eine Zusicherung der Firma Stark Defense. Der umstrittene Investor Thiel halte nur eine geringe Beteiligung ohne Zugriff oder Einsicht in operative Sachverhalte.
Ja, sonst wird alles in bester Ordnung sein. Dann ist alles so schlecht. Noch eine Kooperation. Boris Pistorius stellt sie vor.
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius und sein Amtskollege Fedorow unterzeichnen eine Absichtserklärung über eine weitere Zusammenarbeit. Dabei sollen Entwickler, die vielversprechende Innovationen vorweisen, können gefördert werden. Das Ziel ist es, weitere deutsch-ukrainische Gemeinschaftsunternehmen zu schaffen. Im Fokus der strategischen Partnerschaft zwischen Deutschland und der Ukraine steht vor allem die gemeinsame Entwicklung und Produktion von Drohnen mit einer Reichweite von bis zu 1500 Kilometern, so Pistorius in Kiew. Diese Deep-Strike-Waffensysteme können Ziele im Hinterland eines Gegners treffen. Angesprochen auf die Äußerungen von Kreml-Chef Putin über ein mögliches Ende des Ukraine-Krieges äußerte sich der...
Das ist jetzt schön, wie das zusammengebunden ist. Also wir haben diese Diskussion, wie kann der Krieg beendet werden? Dann hat der Putin Gerhard Schröder vorgeschlagen, wo dann alle völlig ausgeflippt sind. Wie kann man überhaupt nur daran denken? Wo man sagt, nein, man wird schon irgendjemanden finden müssen, der mit Putin reden kann. Also Merkel wäre wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Kandidatin dafür, wenn sie das machen wollte, ist dann auch die Frage. Jedenfalls war dann ja auch aufsehen darüber, dass Richard David Precht im Podcast mit Markus Lanz gesagt hat, ich habe mittlerweile den Eindruck, dass viele ja den Krieg gar nicht beenden wollen. Ja, das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Und Markus Lanz hat dann gesagt, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, Richard. Nee, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also wir kriegen doch gerade präsentiert, wer hier nicht will, dass dieser Krieg aufhört. Es ist doch Abendnachrichten, 20 Uhr. Ja, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man darauf kommen kann, dass es nicht extrem viele Interessen gibt, daran den Krieg jetzt am Laufen zu halten. Also das ist doch klar.
Bundesverteidigungsminister skeptisch.
Vladimir Putin spricht derzeit wieder davon, dass sich der Krieg gegen die Ukraine dem Ende neige. Da drängt sich dem geneigten Betrachter die Frage auf, wenn er denn das Ende dieses Krieges aufziehen sieht, dann könnte er diesen Krieg ja auch einfach beenden. Dann hätte er den Zeitpunkt selber in der Hand. Der stellt aber gleichzeitig Bedingungen, so wie immer.
Es steht zu befürchten.
Ja, es ist jemals ein Krieg ohne Bedingungen zu stellen beendet worden. Das ist ja Diskurs März 2022 oder sowas.
Berichten so der Bundesverteidigungsminister, dass Putin ein weiteres Täuschungsmanöver unternehme. Sein ukrainischer Amtskollege Fedorov dankte Deutschland für dessen Unterstützung im Krieg und unterstrich, dass Deutschland inzwischen weltweit die führende Rolle bei der Sicherheitshilfe für die Ukraine einnehme.
Und so macht man dann weiter. Also jetzt fiel das Wort Täuschungsmanöver und so wird Putin untergeschoben. Ich halte das für ein wirklich großes Täuschungsmanöver an. Ich bin wirklich voll auf der Linie von Richard David Precht. Hier gibt es zu viele Leute, die an diesem Krieg festhalten wollen. Deswegen geht er auch noch fünf Jahre mindestens. Und zwar von allen Seiten gibt es ganz große Interessen und da sind so viele Kapitalinteressen jetzt inzwischen drin, dass man auch sieht, die Verpflichtungen sind so kolossal. Die Ukraine ist mittlerweile Waffenexporteur. Die wissen selber nicht, wohin mit dem ganzen Zeug. Also das ist nur eine Frage von, wie viele Menschen kann man noch verfeuern. Das ist die Frage, die sich jetzt stellt. Denn das haben wir jetzt eben betont. Dazu sind Drohnen nun einmal da. Kommen wir nun zu Palantir. Palantir ist ja auch ganz groß im Drohnengeschäft drin. Also die produzieren zwar nicht selbst Drohnen, aber es braucht ja eine Software, die erkennt, wo sollen denn die Drohnen angreifen. Damit kommen wir zu Project Maven. Wahrscheinlich werden die meisten noch nie davon gehört haben, von diesem Projekt. Die Genese dieses Projekts werden wir uns dann gleich auch anhören. Also die Software für diese Innenstadtüberwachung wie hier auf der Zeil heißt einfach Gotham. Ach ja, sehr gut. Maven aber als Name ist also das Maven System, das Palantir zur Verfügung stellt. Das Wort Maven, also Experte kann das ja zum Beispiel bedeuten, das ist ja nicht darauf auf Palantir Mist gewachsen, sondern das ist tatsächlich vom Pentagon. Dazu kommen wir aber gleich. Wir hören uns aber jetzt erstmal so ein Image Video an, dass es gibt zu einer Entwicklerkonferenz von Palantir, die vor wenigen Wochen stattgefunden hat. Dort ist Chad Walquist. Das ist der forward deployed architect für diese Systeme, die sie da so machen. Und der führt einen jetzt so ein bisschen über das Palantir Gelände und zeigt, was sie so alles machen. Trifft er auf einen Entwickler dieses Maven-Systems.
But also playing in the background here is a lot of the work that we've done on Project Maven. To really try to communicate how we're connecting the foundry to the fleet to the fight line.
Yeah, so maybe for people that don't know what Maven is, just a short description of what Maven is.
Yeah, our participation in Maven began by deploying computer vision models and supportive intelligence analysts who needed to make sense of the world faster. And today it is now, I would think about it as a battle space awareness tool that users can interact with to either make decisions within the environment or push the ability to make decisions through tactical datalinks that exist today. Really collapsing killchains for operation.
Das heißt, wir haben es hier mit einem System zu tun, das Ziele erkennen kann, dass auch dann ja nicht die letzte Entscheidung trifft, aber ja eine Vorauswahl trifft. Und dann braucht man nur noch bestätigen. Es wird weiter erklärt, wie das funktioniert...
.commanders to make decisions.
Yeah, so it's really about all the way from the data to the logic of everything, and then to the action, right?
Auch hier so ganz locker reden die darüber, über ein System, das so... Die haben eine ganze Schule gesprengt. Am Tag 1 des Krieges im Iran. Ja, fragt sich mit welchem System, vielleicht mit Maven.
What is some of the things that benefit the world? I mean, it's great, I always want more information, but what is the actual tactical advantage that we're seeing with it?
I think that if you think about the world today, I think one of the things that I saw in the work that I did in support of Maven is operators are searching through haystacks, looking for needles, and Maven is really reducing the hay in the haystack. And so it's making operators more effective. I know that Shom talks about it as how do you wrap an Iron Man suit around an intelligence analyst or a fire chief? And this is enabling them to identify the points of interest or the objects of interest that they care about and rapidly build plans of action, not only around tactical action, but around operational and theater level missions that they might need to execute.
Das Heu im Heuhaufen wird entfernt. Theater level. Also Kriegsschauplätze kann man sich jetzt global denken. Ganz richtig. Wenn es hier umgeht. Ja. Wir haben ja eben gehört von Robert Fink bei Helsing, ja, es soll ja schon noch entschieden werden, dass die Leute nicht alles vollständig autonom sind. Das ist ja auch der Konflikt jetzt gerade mit Anthropic. Wie autonom darf es denn sein? Ich würde sagen, wir sind doch längst im autonomen Zeitalter angekommen, also der autonomen Waffensysteme. Denn was da jetzt noch als Entscheidung einem verkauft wird, da fragt man sich, wie will man denn darüber noch entscheiden? Wir hören jetzt mal, was dieses Maven-System an in Anführungszeichen Fortschritt gebracht hat.
I think that comes real. So like that, like doing more with less is really enabling the warfighter to really keep everyone safe And really go after the mission.
Das heißt, man brauchte 2000 Geheimdiensoffiziere für das Targeting. Und jetzt funktioniert diese Zielerfassung mit 20. Ja.
Faktorwunde.
Was dann ja bedeutet, okay, da wird mit der Gießkanne gearbeitet und dann sagt man, okay, dann, wenn das, scheinbar das System hat angeschlagen, da sind überall weiße Pünktchen, dann legt los. Das ist die Entscheidung, die der Mensch da noch trifft. Aber das ist ja keine detaillierte Entscheidung, sollen wir da oder dort noch. So ergibt sich ja dann auch, dass zum Beispiel so eine Schule platt gebombt wird, weil da einfach ein weißer Punkt drauf war. Und da hat ja gar niemand mehr die Möglichkeit gehabt, nochmal darüber nachzudenken, ist das vielleicht sinnvoll oder nicht? Also in der Soziologie hat Niklas Luhmann dieses Wort der Unterwachung. Also von oben wird geführt, aber von unten wird dann unterwacht, indem die Beschlussvorlage einfach so alternativlos ist, dass für den Chef, wenn er kommt, ist es klar, was man hier unterschreibt. Nämlich genau diesen Zettel. Und das hier auch. Also man kann auch jetzt durchrechnen. Wie viele Gebäude auf einem Bild kann man sich anschauen. Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, die sitzen da wie vor so einem Capture. Markieren sie alle Motorräder auf diesen Bildern. Ja. Zack, zack, zack, zack. Zack, zack, zack. Und so geht es halt hintereinander weg. Und dann war ein Human in the Loop. Ja. Genau. Das reicht dann im Prinzip. Die Optimierung geht noch weiter.
Yeah, I've really been impressed by some of the users that we have in platform. I think the best builders in Maven are the uniform users who are downloading their intelligence and targeting brain into the workflows.
Interessant, dass er jetzt von den Menschen, also von Militärs, die dort mitarbeiten und die downloaden ihr Wissen, ihre Intelligenz, also exakt das, was Papst Leo sagt, geht nicht, das ist falsch. Das ist die Hypris. Und hier wird es einfach als toll beschrieben, die downloaden einfach, was sie wissen.
Really upskilling both the rest of the work list and then making decisions faster and even more safely.
It's funny, because that's what I see both on the USG side, but also on the commercial side. It's like, I get this question all the time, like what are the best builders? It's the domain experts that actually know what they're doing that we give them and enable them to have that autonomy We need to actually go build the workflow that they need, because they're the experts, and they've been doing it for 20 years, right? It's like now we've enabled their dream vision.
Ja, aber Herr Experte, wie wird man denn so ein Experte? Also klar, man hat jetzt die letzten 20 Jahre mit 2000 Leuten da Wissen aufgebaut, was ein Ziel von einem Nichtziel unterscheidet. Jetzt machen das 20. In 20 Jahren machen das Leute, die was gemacht haben die 20 Jahre vorher? Also man kommt ja gar nicht zu diesem Wissen um dann später dieses Jahr. Das sind voll die Domain Experts und so. Wenn man sich ansieht, wie die das präsentieren, man kann das ja ruhig mal aufrufen, so Palantir Entwicklerkonferenzen oder so etwas, dann wird einem auffallen, der Look des Silicon Valley hat sich nicht geändert. Lester Mayer muss da gar nicht erstaunt sein, sondern das ist alles wie immer. Und ein Wort ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich auch noch gut kenne. So aus den Nuller- und Zehnerjahren, nämlich folgende. Aber ich habe auch noch eine Beziehung, die da mit einhergeht. Das war immer der Begriff, der kam, wenn es um Facebook ging, das demokratisiert unsere Beziehungen, alles YouTube demokratisiert uns. Katrina Manson von Bloomberg, eine Investigativ-Journalistin, hat ein Buch geschrieben zu Project Maven, denn dieses System Maven, das hat ja einen Urheber, der nicht privatwirtschaftlich ist, sondern beim Starte USA liegt. Project Maven, was ist damit gemeint? Sie ist da bei VOX zu Gast und gibt Auskunft.
Project Maven knows nothing about it. What is it?
It was an effort that began in 2017 for the Pentagon to develop an AI tool. Develop a way of using AI on the battlefield so that AI could, AI computer vision, a specific kind of AI could look at drone feed, video footage. This was the feed that the US was taking in the cancer terrorism wars, the GWOT global war on terror. Apply AI to look at it better. That was ostensibly what it was.
Ja, sie hat jetzt diese Idee, wie ich gerade kapta beschrieben.
Mhm, richtig.
China spielt schon damals eine Rolle. Wir sind im Jahr 2017.
People were beginning to think, what about China? What if the US has to square up to China? And there was a group of people under the first Trump administration who said the US was behind, despite having the biggest defense budget in the world, bar none. The US started to feel that it was using two unsophisticated tools and needed to catch up with what the commercial sector was doing.
Der Wettbewerb jetzt zwischen den Staaten, jetzt müssen wir da dringend loslegen. Catherine Manson war auch bei Democracy Now zu Gast. Da wird sie auch eingeleitet mit dem Verweis auf das, was 2017 stattfand, nämlich da gab es ja Proteste. Vielleicht werden sich manche daran erinnern.
Google was an initial partner, but the company pulled out after over 3,000 Google workers signed a letter opposing the work, saying, quote, we believe that Google should not be in the business of war. The big data firm Palantir then took over the project and has run it ever since.
That's the platform, if you imagine.
Ja, also das ist der historische Hintergrund. Wir hatten diese Proteste von Google heute gar nicht mehr vorstellbar. Die hatten das Motto Don't Be Evil. Das heißt, wir gehen generell nicht in Militärtechnologien ein. Das war noch dieses Silicon Valley, von dem ich eben meinte, das war staatsfern. Das meinte ich damit. Die sagten, damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Wir optimieren hier Suchmaschinen. Dann Katherine Manson.
That's the platform. If you imagine Google Earth for war, a map of war with white dots infused with information like elevation, coordinate, what is precisely there, whether it's friendly or foe. That is the system that the US is using now in a widespread way as a common operating platform or even some people call it AI mission control.
Anfangs war dafür ein Colonel zuständig, den Catherine Manson offenbar monatelang beknien muss, dass er mit ihr spricht. Davon handelt dann auch ein Großteil des Buches wohl. Dieser Colonel hat, wie so viele dann, die sich mit Sicherheit beschäftigen, gesagt, Ja, wir müssen ja unsere Leute schützen. Deswegen müssen wir da mal so anfangen. Und wie das dann so geht, ist der Free Slope, hat man dann ein solches System aufgebaut, mit dem man ganz anderes machen kann. Wir hören da erstmal in die Ursprünge nochmal rein dieses Projekts.
The Colonel who led it as Chief, so the day-to-day operator, the doer, who also had a lot of the vision, was called Ju Kuko.
Und anfangs lief das denkbar schlecht.
In the really early days, so if we say before 2020, the first two or three years, it was actually just a mess. It was such a mess that the people involved in Mabin would say these algorithms don't work. So the first users they worked with were in Somalia at the very end of 2017 into 2018. They used it, the system was so annoying, they stopped using it. They then sent someone to try and encourage them. So much of what this project Maven team, which was quite a small net team of mostly marines, but not just marines, was trying to do, was just to get someone to even try it.
Ja, also hier hört man ja 2017, wenn man jetzt gefragt hätte, welcher Krieg topte da gerade? Also, keine Ahnung. Jetzt sagt sie, ja, die sind da in Afrika so. Haben sich ihre Theaters rausgesucht. Also daraus ist ableitbar, dass Ukraine für die natürlich Weihnachten ist. Das ist das Versuchslabor. Das Größte, das man sich hätte denken können. Der Innovationssprung durch AI ist dann recht groß. In wenigen Jahren passiert plötzlich ganz viel.
So, I was told in 20, last year in summer, I went to visit NGA, which is the Combat Support Agency that supports the Defense Department, but is also a member of the intelligence community, National Geospatial Intelligence Agency. Last summer they told me that with the help of AI, Maven's smart system can now get through a thousand targets a day.
A thousand?
In the first 24 hours of the US operations in Iran, they went through a thousand targets.
Also, der RAFA wurde einfach komplett plattgemacht, so. Da braucht man gar kein Targeting mehr. Das könnte man ja auch mal hier in die Wachschale werfen. Dafür ist der Iran zu groß, deswegen kann man das so nicht machen. Deswegen müssen Sie dann noch tausend Angriffe fliegen. Der Iranse Waffen ist komplett zerstörbar, wie der Gazastrein. Deswegen braucht man das hier. Ja, ja. Aber da sieht man ja bei tausend Angriffe am Tag, wer soll da im Einzelnen entschieden haben. Das heißt, wir sind eigentlich längst bei Fully Automated. Der Fortschritt durch die LMMs ist kolossal.
With the help of LLM, really using that to speed up the processes, the kind of admin processes involved in building a targeting package, getting permission for it, still from a human, still from a commander, still with legal review. But sped up. They told me, one person official told me, they could now get to 5,000 targets in a day, if they wanted to.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
5,000, das ist unmöglich. Die Idee war nun, dass man ganz viele Drohnen braucht, damit man in den Krieg einsteigen kann gegen China, wenn China Taiwan sich nehmen will.
The hope, especially for something like Hellscape, which is the Indo-Pacific Command's idea of how they could defend Taiwan from an invasion by China, if China decided to do that. And Admiral there, Admiral Paparo, talks about using autonomous weapons to buy him a month. So, just make it impossible for China to take Taiwan and then send in the larger US platforms.
Das heißt, man will sich Zeit kaufen und dann geht man doch mit Boots on the ground nach einem Monat selbst dort rein. Jetzt kann man ja immer sagen, ja, aber es gibt ja Bedrohungsnamen und all das, aber das ist ja das, worauf jetzt Paps Deo hingewiesen hat. Man muss dieses kompetitive Spiel verlassen. Man muss sich da rausbegeben. Man muss sich nicht noch mit denen, die solche Unternehmen leiten oder im weißen Haus sitzen, die Köpfe zerbrechen und sagen, ja, was machen wir da? Da müssen wir wohl. Weil dann kommen alle immer zu dem Schluss und sagen, ja, dann müssen wir das leider machen. Kindergärten oder so, ja, weiß ich, ist ein großes Problem, aber wir können uns jetzt gar nicht kümmern, denn da ist ja Taiwan und deswegen müssen wir jetzt schon mal das machen. Deswegen auch schon die Entwaffnung der Sprache. Ja, genau. Alles muss in diese Richtung gehen. Die beiden Administrationen hielt hier an diesem Projekt Maven Fest.
So under the Biden Administration, I think in 22 or 3, they launched something called Replicator, which is to bring in cheap, their word are trittable, basically, you don't need to use it again, drones. Those are meant to be autonomous. So they've been trying to develop the software, they've been competing with different companies to do that. Through the course of my reporting, I discovered that the idea was to take some of those algorithms that we even had produced, train them on data from the Indo-Pacific, really at that boat level. So boat drone cameras, aerial drone cameras, infrared, anything that might be looking at a Chinese vessel.
Dabei soll alles miteinander kombiniert werden. Es soll ein Schwarm entwickelt werden, zu Land, Wasser und auf der Erde.
Capture those pictures, Train the algorithms. Sit them on the drone.
Zu Land, Wasser und Luft. So wäre es richtig.
Now, instead of having it on a digital platform, at headquarters level, and have that AI on the drone, automatically detect the target, and then be able to have the drone go and take the target out. It was very tough going, those experiments, even before the Trump administration got in. They were making progress. They also wanted to do something very ambitious, which was to link up drones in the sky, drones on the water and drones under the water into one big autonomous swarming mesh which boggles the mind.
Und zwar überall, wo es von nöten ist, also hier wird ja kein Kampffeld definiert. Nein, es ist die völlige Entgrenzung des Krieges. Und darüber haben wir gar keine Debatte. Also ich meine, dieser Palantir-Clip, den ich da jetzt eben gespielt habe oder die mehreren, die hatten 1900 Aufrufe bei YouTube, interessiert gar nicht da. Jetzt hier hat sie natürlich eine gewisse Reichweite mit Podcast-Auftritten, aber hierzulande gibt es gar keine Debatte, muss so sein, wir schaffen das alles an. Das heißt, die Menschheit läuft ja schon auf eine totale Entgrenzung des Krieges hinaus, da ist längst dort angekommen. Das heißt, das, was der Papst da beschreibt, ist ja keine Zukunftsvision, wenn die LLMs sich weiterentwickeln, dann können wir mal Probleme bekommen, sondern das Desaster ist ja da. Und das kann man diesem Text auch entnehmen. Im Grunde ist das das Szenario, die Israelis statten die ganze Hamas und die Hezbollah da mit diesen Pager aus, nur bislang mussten sie vorher noch die Bomben da reinbauen. Jetzt ist einfach der Pager. Und dann wird einfach getargetet, die Drohne ist schon in der Luft, sie spät das dann aus und zack. Und die andere Seite macht es natürlich auch. Das heißt, die haben die totale Entgrenzung bei solch billigen Produkten. Genau, als es hieß, ja, die Ukraine hat so einen Angriff gelauncht, wo denn? Ja, kurz vor Moskau, wie denn? Ja, da ging so ein Lkw-Dach auf und dann kam da 100 Drohnen raus. Da dachte ich mir so, ja, das ist sehr inspirierend. Ein Lkw, das kann wirklich jeder. Und von daher denke ich auch, also diese Entgrenzung ist hier wirklich für jeden jetzt möglich. Ja, das war ja die sogenannten Sperrholzdrohnen. Erst hat die eine Seite sie gemacht, dann die andere Seite. Jetzt bekriegt sich eben Russland und Ukraine, nicht nur, aber teilweise eben mit diesen Sperrholzdrohnen. Trump hat das dann selbstverständlich weitergeführt. Wie könnte es anders sein?
The language now is so much more permissible. The Pentagon is simply saying it. The fight now with anthropic is over, not just autonomy, but fully autonomous weapon systems. And they're trying again. So they have this new project that I've reported recently on. It was launched in January. It's a hundred million dollar prize challenge. Same ideas have been made to a certain extent of competing the companies against each other. And SpaceX and XAI are one of the contenders. Palantir I've reported is a contender. OpenAI is named as the second on two other contenders.
Anthropic ist auch dabei. Das heißt, das ist ein neues Projekt. Auch hier, wie wir das eben schon von Boris Pistorius gehört haben, kompetitiv soll das jetzt ausgetragen werden. The company can produce the best and then get the access. What should this new model that is currently being financed be able to do? The voice control.
And they're all trying to make voice controlled autonomous drone swarming tech. So you could have an operator on a beach, let's say, saying move left and the drones The question is, how do you think the White House would move left? And you have to hope they could identify the target.
That's wild.
Also, dass dem jetzt technisch nicht zu weh gesteht, sieht glaube ich jeder. Yeah. Wie bewertet sie diesen Streit um Anthropic gegen das Weiße Haus?
And no fully autonomous weapons without human oversight. Those were their red lines. And apparently they could not come to an agreement with the Defense Department. Just what do you make of that and the consequences?
I think by the time you have a frontier AI company that is the first to put its model on classified cloud, you have a company that's leaning in in a way that is not reminiscent of Google back in 2017, 2018. Anthropic was on the very systems where there are lethal operations, and clearly comfortable with that. If you read Dario's two big essays, he has these two big essays that he wrote, making his case for why his company should be involved in national security. You're grappling with that thing that everyone in AI who's worried about existentialism or whatever it is about whether AI comes to kill us all or not takes over. He's grappled with that too. And he has found peace with the idea that you can do national security work and still be quote unquote the good guy.
Die wollen die Guten sein, ziehen vielleicht die ein oder andere rote Linie im Grunde, aber sind sie Teil dieses Systems. Darauf läuft auch der Artikel, der in eben dieser von dir schon angesprochenen Ausgabe von de Monde Diplomatie erschienen ist. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. KI im Widerstand. Anthropics Scheinstreit mit dem Pentagon. Mensen hier noch einmal.
It's not even that he's against fully autonomous weapon systems. It's that he's against fully autonomous weapon systems now. And it raises questions about what was actually under discussion. Was there a system that he was being asked to put AI onto that he didn't want to? Or was he just worried that they weren't doing the testing and evaluation right? Because Anthropic did submit, I reported, to this 100 million dollar prize challenge to create voice control, transforming tech.
Das heißt, die Zusammenarbeit mit den Staaten ist natürlich nicht jetzt gekappt. Man arbeitet nicht mehr mit dem Weißen Haus oder dem Pentagon zusammen, sondern man macht weiter. Offenbar hat man aber einige Dinge, von denen wir nichts wissen, da gesehen, wo man sagte, gut, den Schritt gehen wir jetzt vorerst nicht mit. Aber grundsätzlich ist auch dieses autonome Töten nicht etwas, was grundsätzlich abgedehnt wird, sondern zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt lehnt man es wohl ab. Wenn wir uns jetzt das vergegenwärtigen, was wir da gehört haben, wir könnten natürlich jetzt noch tausende weitere Beispiele von Drohnenentwicklung und solche Überwachungstechnologien uns ansehen, dann ist ja immer die Frage, ja, welche Kriege sind das dann? Nein, es werden Vernichtungskriege geführt. In der Weise, also es wird versucht, auf der anderen Seite möglichst viel Schaden anzurichten. Das heißt, man zerstört Infrastruktur, Gebäude und man zerstört Menschen. Man tötet Menschen. Darum geht es eigentlich bei den Kriegen, die wir jetzt gerade beobachten. Also da jetzt zu glauben, es sei einfach nur eine strategische Frage oder so, sondern man guckt, wie viel Menschen kann ich verschleißen der anderen Seite und wie viel muss ich von der eigenen Seite einsetzen? Weshalb der Glaube ist, wenn ich jetzt in Drohntechnologie investiere, dann halte ich mein Humankapital geschützt, während das andere dem Schutzlos ausgeliefert ist, dass die andere Seite dann sehr schnell damit dabei ist, das auch entsprechend zu anhaben, vergrößert nur die Killing Zone. Aber es ändert sich nichts im Ganzen. Es geht immer darum, wie viele Menschen kann man töten. Das ist der Kern eines Krieges. Und alle, die irgendwas anderes sagen, reden Mist. Wir bringen das mal an einem einfachen Beispiel. Ukraine, wer kämpft da? Unter anderem kämpfen da auch Kolumbianer. Das habe ich jetzt erfahren im Welt-Spiegel-Podcast. Demian von Osten und Marie-Christine Böse sprechen darüber.
Angriffe von Drohnen, Artillerie, Infanterie, tote Russen.
Es ist hart.
Er nennt sich Chris Facker. Das ist sein Kampfname und er kämpft für die Ukraine. Er hilft mit, das Land gegen die russischen Angriffe zu verteidigen. Dabei ist die Ukraine gar nicht seine Heimat. Denn Chris Facker kommt aus Kolumbien. Er ist tausende Kilometer geflogen auf einen anderen Kontinent, um freiwillig in den Krieg zu ziehen.
Und einen Menschen zu töten, der für seine Ideale kämpft, ist ebenfalls hart. Vier tote Russen. Es ist nicht sehr cool.
It's not very cool. Für Geld oder ist das so seitnatum einfach? For money, for money. Wir wissen, der Ukraine gehen die Leute aus. Russland gehen auch die Leute aus. Russland versucht dann in Afrika zu rekrutieren. Hier versucht man es mit Südamerika. Wie ist überhaupt die Situation in Kolumbien? Wie kommt es, dass sich da Männer auf diesen weiten Weg machen?
Wir waren in der Nähe von Cali unterwegs, im Valle de Cauca. Da einfach so als Kontext, dazu muss man wissen, das ist eine recht konfliktreiche Region aus der Geschichte Kolumbiens, geprägt von einem jahrzehntelangen bewaffneten Konflikt im Land zwischen Militärs, Gerier, Paramilitärs. Das heißt, es gibt dort sehr viele kampferprobte Männer letztendlich. Und die Angehörigen, die wir getroffen haben, haben ein Bild gezeichnet von ihren Männern, dass sie oft militär erfahren sind oder militär interessiert.
Ja, also wenn Krieg normal Zustand ist, dann ist es halt normal Zustand. Ja, und wenn die Bandenkriege da ein bisschen nachlassen, man nichts mehr zu tun hat, warum nicht in die Ukraine gehen, man hat es doch gelernt, mit der Waffe umzugehen.
Viele sind ja beruflich enttäuscht, wirtschaftlich enttäuscht, haben wenig Chancen, in Kolumbien eben aus einer prekären Situation, aus der Armut rauszukommen. Teils haben sie Familien gegründet, ein Haus gebaut, sind jetzt verschuldet. Und der Mindestlohn in Kolumbien beträgt halt nur ungefähr 400 Euro. Und viele Angehörige haben uns erzählt, in der Ukraine wurden ihnen halt sehr viel höhere Löhne versprochen, mehrere tausend Dollar, ungefähr 3000 US-Dollarlohn im Monat. Das heißt, viele hatten einfach die Hoffnung auf schnelles Geld, ihre Schulden schnell abzubezahlen.
Haben wir die 90 Milliarden in Brüssel endlich genehmigt? Ja, das ist so absurd. Wir haben Menschen, die sich auf den Weg machen aus Kolumbien, um in der Ukraine zu kämpfen, um ein paar tausend Dollar zu verdienen, weil sie zu Hause Häuser gebaut haben und die Schuldenlast ist zu hoch. Wahrscheinlich weil sie auch entsprechend hohe Zahlungen aufzahlen müssen. Und dann sagt man ja, dann geh doch hier in den Fleisch, Wolf. Wenn du überlebst, dann hast du echt Glück. Wenn du nicht überlebst, dann gibt es wenigstens noch eine gewisse Entschädigung, wenn deine Familie dich in der Ukraine findet und erklären kann, dass du wirklich tot bist. Ich finde, wir sollten hier auch gegen diese Fluchteinreize für Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge jetzt. Das ist ein Flüchtlingsmagnet, was ich da höre. Ja, aber da sehen wir einfach, hier geht es um alles Mögliche, aber hier geht es ja nicht um irgendwelche Herenideale, die uns die ganze Zeit noch erzählt werden in den Medien. Demian von Osten hat dann auch Kolumbianer in der Ukraine getroffen.
Und so jemanden, der für die Sache kämpft, den haben wir getroffen im Nordosten der Ukraine auf einem Trainingsgelände, den wir gerade geübt haben, der war aber schon an der Front. Wir haben vorhin von ihm auch schon seine Fronterfahrung gehört. Er nennt sich mit Kampfnamen, da muss man erstmal schlucken, Chris Facker. So hat er sich vorgestellt, seinen echten Namen wollen die Militärs hier in der Ukraine nie nennen. Und der ist tatsächlich jemand, der früher für das kolumbianische Militär gekämpft hat. Und er hat, wie so viele, offenbar in Kolumbien Probleme dann mit der Reintegration bekommen in die normale Gesellschaft, das ist wohl ein verbreitetes Problem dort im Land.
Das ist generell ein verbreitetes Problem mit allen Männern, die im Krieg waren. Da haben wir Bücherschränke voll mit diesem Thema. Das vererben sie typischerweise auch. Ja, das heißt, wenn dieser Krieg in der Ukraine mal ende, dann ist er nicht vorbei....
Möglichkeiten gesucht, wieder zu kämpfen und hat die eben gefunden, weil die Ukraine die sogenannte Fremden Legion hat. Etwa 8000 ausländische Freiwillige haben sich den Bodentruppen in der Ukraine angeschlossen. Also da geht es jetzt nicht um irgendwelche hochqualifizierten Jobs wie Drohnenoperator oder so, sondern das sind wirklich, das ist Fußvolk, was in die Front geht, in die erste Reihe und dort richtig kämpft und...
Ich würde sagen, das sind, ja sag du erst mal. Ich will nur ein Scherz machen. Du warst ja noch nicht im Petersdom. Ja. Das heißt, du hast noch nie so eine Aufstellung von so einem Schweizer Gardisten gesehen. Ja. Du weißt aber, wie sie aussehen. Natürlich. Und die sehen in Lebensrecht genauso aus, Faktor 5. So, der Legende nach ist das Michelangelo's Entwurf gewesen. Nicht nur bunte Farben, sondern auch so komische Faltenwürfe und so. Und der Vatikan macht für mich damit sehr deutlich, wir ziehen niemals in den Krieg. Die stehen hier einfach nur, damit die Idioten nicht einfach in die falsche Tür reingehen. Und das halte ich für sehr sinnvoll. Gerade noch akzeptable Verteidigungsstrategie. Die setzen sich nicht an den Computer und bezahlen plötzlich einen Kolumbianer um hier und so weiter. Das ist doch eigentlich Click-Worker-Arbeit. Ja, das ist Click-Worker-Arbeit. Also, die einen bleiben in Kolumbien und gucken sich den ganzen Tag irgendwelches missbräuchliches Material an und drücken irgendwelche Knöpfe, um zu sagen, oh, das ist Content, den solltet ihr mal lieber nicht zeigen. Das sind die einen. Und die anderen, die optimieren jetzt die Drohnen, indem sie da vorne rumlaufen und schauen, ob sie überleben. Der makabere Begriff ist noch Gig-Worker. Ja, also der Click-Worker zu Hause und dann hier ein Gig für dich. Ja, der Gig-Worker. Nichts anderes ist es zu beschreiben. Wie funktioniert die Anwerbung, wie bei Click-Working und Gig-Working auch?
Von denen, die wir hier getroffen haben, ist ein verbreitetes Phänomen Social Media und vor allen Dingen TikTok. Es gibt einige kolumbianische Soldaten oder ich nenne sie jetzt mal Kämpfer, die sich der ukrainischen Armee angeschlossen haben und die eigene TikTok-Kanäle haben. And in diesen TikTok-Kanälen rufen sie wirklich dazu auf, schließt euch doch uns an.
Mi nombre es Cota Severli.
Soy Comandante de la Brigada Especial Latina.
Was? Kommen ins Biwak, gegeben die Natur. Ja, kommen die Gruppe. Schließ dich an. Wir haben keine Ratschaft für dich. Was geschieht denn mit den Gefallenen Kolumbianen?
Kolumbianer Gefallen sind zwischen 300 und 500. Es gibt auf jeden Fall in Kolumbien offiziell mehr als 300 Gesuche, Gefallene zurückzuführen. Und es gibt ungefähr 440 Kolumbianer, die als vermisst gemeldet wurden. Also die könnten gefallen sein, vielleicht auf jetzt russischem Gebiet. Die Leichen können teilweise nicht geborgen werden. Und dieser Identifikationsprozess ist einfach auch sehr langwierig und langsam. Weil es eben kaum Informationsaustausch gibt.
Also, das ist ja sehr krass auch, dass man da einfach sagt, komm mal hierher, wir geben dir aber einen anderen Namen. Und damit deine Familie nicht in Gefahr ist, sagst du uns einfach gar nichts über dich. Oh, leider tot, wer ist tot? Keine Ahnung, Michael Facker ist tot. Weiter wurde dann auch gesagt, dass dann Familien über WhatsApp-Gruppen erfahren, dass offenbar der Sohn tot ist. Dann müssen sie da hinreisen, um das zu beweisen, weil sie ja sonst gar keine Entschädigung bekommen, keine Lebensversicherung ausgezahlt bekommen. Das sind alles John-Dos, gleich mal durchnummerieren. Gehen die wieder da auf die Suche. Was wir hier sehen, wir haben ja ein Buch gelesen, das hieß das Knappegut Arbeit. Man könnte auch direkt ein Buch schreiben, das heißt das Knappegut Mensch. Denn was wir in diesen Kriegen sehen, ist es geht um den Verschleiß von Menschen und wir haben diese Technologien. Die sollen nun jetzt erprobt und eingesetzt werden. Die sind dazu da zu verschleißen. Das heißt, da gibt es eine Knappheit. Deswegen muss man schon aus Kolumbien Leute herankarren. Es ist so absurd. Und nachdem man das alles gehört hat, wird auch dieser Podcast mit eigenartigen Worten beendet. Und ich finde das so verrückt. Ich höre ja sehr viele solcher Podcasts. Wir hatten das jetzt auch kürzlich schon mit den Zwangsrekrutierungen in der Ukraine. Und wann immer man solche Podcasts hört, dann hört man dort die schrecklichsten Dinge, von denen man oft noch gar nicht wusste, sie sich gar nicht ausmalen konnte. Es ist kaum auszuhalten, sich überhaupt die Podcasts anzuhören. Und dann aber kommt immer so eine Wende, bei der ich denke, wie kann das sein? Die haben doch das jetzt alles recherchiert. Die wissen das ja alles zehnmal besser als ich selbst. Ich kann schon eigentlich nach einer Podcast-Folge nicht mehr. Und man kommt aber immer noch zu einem Schluss wie jetzt Demian von Osten.
Also sie machen weiter und ich erlebe keine Resignation. Also ich habe jetzt noch nirgendwo hier das Gefühl gehabt, dass Ukrainer sagen, jetzt lasst die Russen doch kommen. Wir können nicht mehr. Das hört man bei niemandem. Eigentlich, je stärker die Angriffswellen werden, umso mehr ist eigentlich die Trotzigkeit da. Jetzt müssen wir erst recht weitermachen.
Ja, also einfach mal eine Stunde hinsetzen und Enzyklika lesen. Ja. Über die Wahl der Worte, was hier zu entwaffnen ist, wie man mit Informationen umgeht und ob diese Informationen etwas mit Beziehungsgestaltung und Wahrheit zu tun haben müssen oder ob man sich nur so ein Weltbild noch mal zusammenzümmert, nachdem man es gerade selber zertrümmert bekommen hat und sich das aber nicht eingestehen will. Sie leisten selbst die Dekonstruktion, um danach wieder zu sagen, nee, aber grundsätzlich muss alles genauso weitergehen. Es gibt auch noch Positives zu berichten.
Und vielleicht noch etwas zum Schmunzeln am Ende. Bei der Recherche haben wir auch Geschichten gehört von Kolumbianern, die sich hier in ukrainische Frauen verliebt haben und wo schon die eine oder andere Familie gegründet worden sein soll. Also auch auf dieser Ebene ist das ja nicht ganz ausgeschlossen, dass das Leben in der Ukraine weitergehen könnte.
Welcher Teil davon ist zum Schmunzeln? Ich weiß es nicht. Dass jetzt schon 100, 200, 300.000 ukrainische Männer tot sind und dass da offenbar ein Überschuss an Frauen ist und die sich freuen, wenn noch ein paar Männer von anderswo herkommen. Worüber freut man sich da? Wir bleiben mal kurz beim Thema, machen einfach einen flotten Rundown. Es geht mir hauptsächlich um den Sing-Sagen. Wir steigen ein, ich stelle kein Thema vor, sondern wir lassen uns jetzt treiben, so wie dieses Medienangebot dafür da ist. Ich sitze gerade im Auto, ich mache mal das Radio an, und man treibt so vor sich hin. Also Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag. Boris Pistorius am 11. Mai.
Der deutsche Verteidigungsminister will mit seinem Besuch in der Ukraine die strategische Partnerschaft zwischen beiden Ländern vorantreiben.
Und da geht es natürlich um Rüstungskooperation. Da geht es darum, davon zu lernen, was die Ukraine jetzt im fünften Jahr auf dem Gefechtsfeld erleben, bei der Drohnenkriegsführung, bei der elektronischen Kriegsführung, aber auch in allen anderen Bereichen. Davon können wir lernen als Bundeswehr, als Bundesrepublik Deutschland, aber auch wir als NATO-Streitkräfte. Und deswegen ist diese enge Kooperation für uns sehr wichtig. Und deswegen heben wir die jetzt quasi monatlich auf ein neues Level.
Ja, vielleicht bin ich der Einzige, aber ich höre hier einen wirklich vollständigen Paradigmenwechsel. Ja. Denn wenn man hier nochmal dran erinnert, ey, das ging damit los, dass Deutschland zu wenig unterstützt hat mit 5000 Helmen. Und jetzt heißt es, ja, die Ukraine kann euch jetzt auch zuballern mit Munition. Und hier und da haben wir halt neue Drohnen entwickelt. Und Deutschland so, ja, brauchen wir ja voll. Also dringend voll verkehrt. Ja. Das ist genau verkehrt darum. Aber hast du gesehen, es war jetzt in den letzten Tagen, nachdem ja Putin diese massiven Angriffe auf Kiew geflogen ist, nochmal kurz eine Taurus-Debatte bei Twitter. Hast du es mitbekommen? Oh nein, aber ich lese auch keinen Twitter mehr. Es kam nochmal von den üblichen Verdächtigen, dass jetzt doch Taurus geliefert werden muss. Also Taurus halte ich mittlerweile für, das ist nur noch so eine Idee gewesen, so ein Phantom einfach. Ja. Ich glaube, man wollte es nicht liefern, weil man wusste, es funktioniert dann eh nicht. Und so, lass lieber die Ukrainer drei Tage über nachdenken, was man selber machen kann. Der ukrainische Verteidigungsminister zählt gleich bei diesem Besuch.
Und so strahlt auch der 35 Jahre alte ukrainische Verteidigungsminister Selbstbewusstsein aus. Gerade bei den Deep Strikes, also Angriffen im russischen Hinterland, habe man die Initiative übernommen, sagt Mikhailo Fedorov vor der Presse in Kreiv. Deshalb sind wir der Ansicht, dass die Ukraine derzeit in jedem Bereich, in der Luft, am Boden, bei Langstreckenangriffen sowie im Hinblick auf Russlands Wirtschaft eine gewisse Initiative besitzt. Mit weiterer qualitativ hochwertiger Unterstützung unserer Partner werden wir alle Ziele, die wir uns gesetzt haben, erreichen und einen gerechten Frieden näherbringen, an dem unser Präsident und sein Team arbeiten.
So der ukrainische Verteidigungsminister, 35 Jahre alt, sagt es, wir werden alle unsere Ziele wohl erreichen und der gerechte Frieden wird dann da sein. Erinnert mich bitte noch mal dran, welche Ziele waren das und wann werden sie jetzt erreicht? Denn wenn man einfach einen Deckel drauf machen könnte jetzt, würde ich sagen, ja dann mach da jetzt mal einen Deckel drauf. Denn ansonsten nützt das ja gar nichts. Das ist ja dann wirklich nur Gerede. Die EU hat ja bis heute nicht gesagt, welche Ziele es eigentlich gibt. Genau. Und wenn man aber nur so ein Gerede hat, bei dem aber jeden Monat so und so viele Waffen, die man nach Europa verkaufen kann, die Ukraine finanziert, würde ich sagen, ja, das ist dann per petum mobile, oder wie es heißt. Per petum mobile. Aber einfach abwarten. Ja, dann gehen Jahre ins Land. Ja. Und irgendwann fährt der Palantir-Typ dann Putin so auf so eine Stütze rein, damit sehen alle, der ist noch da. Ja. So, weiter im Sing-Sang, Pistorius.
Doch ein gerechter und stabiler Frieden scheint nach Einschätzungen vieler in der Ukraine nach wie vor in weiter Ferne zu liegen. Daran endere weder die zuletzt brüchige Feuerpause rund um die Feierlichkeiten zum 9. Mai etwas, noch Putins Behauptung, der Krieg nähere sich dem Ende. Unglaubwürdig findet diese Aussage auch Verteidigungsminister Pistorius.
Von daher ist das immer so ein bisschen wie die Sphinx, wenn er so daherkommt. Er kann den Krieg beenden durch den Rückzug der Truppen, er kann zu Friedensgesprächen einladen. An allen Friedensgesprächen, bei allen Friedensgesprächen, an denen er bisher teilnehmen lassen oder selber teilgenommen hat, hat er letztlich keinen Beitrag geleistet. Eher im Gegenteil dazu, dass tatsächlich Frieden kommt.
Ja, kennen wir aus deinem Clip. Also ist jetzt das Prostorius-Singen sagen, ich frag mich ja, kommt wie die Sphinx daher, was heißt denn das? Was meint er damit? So als mystische Figur oder? Kann man generell nicht mitreden oder, das weiß man ja auch gar nicht. Bei den Amerikanern gibt es ja Kommunikationskanäle nach wie vor. Eigentlich die ganze Zeit über nach Moskau. Wir haben einen Bundeskanzler, der stolz behauptet, er hat nie mit Putin gesprochen. Wie ist das möglich? Unser Bundeskanzler steht ja jetzt und das ist eben derselbe Rundown. Wir bleiben beim Thema vom DGB und sagt dort Folgendes.
Meine Damen und Herren, mein Vorgänger im Amt hat am 9. Mai, also vor ziemlich 2022, also vor ziemlich genau vier Jahren und kurz nach dem Beginn des Ukraine-Krieges vor diesem Gremium hat er die Zusage gegeben, dass die weltpolitischen Veränderungen, die er damals zu Recht als Zeitenwende bezeichnet hat, keine Auswirkungen auf die Sozialpolitik und keine Auswirkungen auf die Situation der Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in Deutschland haben werden. Auch wenn es schwierig ist. Ich muss Ihnen heute sagen, dass diese Zusage zumindest zu optimistisch war.
Also dem Kanzler ist zugute zu halten, unbequeme Aussagen, die hat er nicht gescheuert.
Was ist das?
Wer war das jetzt schon wieder? Dagmar Rosenfeld. Toll. Im Machtwechsel-Podcast. So, also der Kanzler kommt und sagt, ich weiß, Sie vertrauen so ein bisschen auf das gesprochene Wort der Bundesregierung, aber leider ist so, dass manchmal ist der Stuhl bekannt, dann kommt ein neuer und ich muss Ihnen sagen, ist mir egal, was Sie vorher gesagt haben. Genau so nicht wie beim Papst. Genau. Also der Papst müsste dann auch erst mal so einen Zyklika schreiben. Ja, also Benedikt, Franziskus, alles Quatsch, ich mach mal anders. Also die Papste gehen typischerweise durch Petrus, Jahr 34, hat er schon recht. Und dann 1000 Jahre später, also auch recht, dann kam Augustinus zwischen den Herren auch recht. So und ich schließe jetzt daran an und übrigens, wir haben erst 1950 ein aktuelles Wort gefunden, das aber auch für die letzten Jahrhunderte steht, so ne. Er hier so, ne, sorry, aber wir müssen das Vorzeichen jetzt mal umdrehen. Allerdings, es findet ja im deutschen Sing-Sagen-Stadt, also hier Presseschauer, das Handelsblatt laut Deutschlandfunk.
Das Handelsblatt betont, der Kanzler hat seinem Publikum nicht nach dem Mund geredet, nicht auf dem Katholikentag in Würzburg, nicht den Delegierten des DGB-Bundeskongresses in Berlin und auch nicht jenen, die sich von Politik, vor allem Beruhigung und schmerzfreie Antworten erhoffen. Das ist unbequem, aber es ist notwendig.
Ich bin ja immer noch dann gespannt auf diese unbequeme Ansage gegenüber Deutschlands Millionären und Milliardären. Kommt natürlich nie. Schade. Kommt nie. Stattdessen, jetzt wo wir etabliert haben, dass der Kanzler sagte, jetzt kommt die unbequeme Wahrheit, wir müssen alle doch ein bisschen sparen, weil Krieg. Und das Handelsblatt so sagt, ja, das ist auch ganz wichtig, dass man das jetzt mal macht und so. Fragt Gordon Rypinski für Matthias Döpfner natürlich bei der AfD nach, wie es so steht um die Regierungsfähigkeit, wo wir doch wissen, dass Regierungsfähigkeit heißt, sparen.
Noch mein 200-Sekunden-Interview. Da gehe ich jetzt noch mal ein bisschen tiefer in dieses Modell rein, indem ich einmal auf der...
Geh mal tiefer rein. Entschuldigung, das erklärt er immer noch, dieses 200-Sekunden-Interview? Ja, das muss jedes Mal erklärt werden, weil... Während, ich hab sehr lustigen Clips, ich hab nachher noch Clips von Robin Alexander, aber jetzt sind wir noch bei Gordon Rapidsky...
.AFD-Seite angefragt habe, gibt es eigentlich die Option, die Union zu stützen? In welcher auch immer gearteten, tolerierten Mehrheit? Ich habe live Eric Holm angefragt, er ist wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher, also derjenige, der vielleicht auch bei den Reformfragen etwas zu sagen hat.
Wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der AfD-Fraktion, der natürlich mit einer Kompetenzunterstellung, so können wir alle nochmal überlegen aus dem letzten Podcast, was war nochmal genau die Kompetenzunterstellung bei Wirtschaftspolitik....
und natürlich auch der Spitzenkalidat in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Erst Gast bei mir im 200-Sekunden-Interview. Herr Holm, ich grüße Sie. Schönen guten Morgen, Herr Rybinski.
Also da hört man schon mal jemand mit guter Laune.
Herr Holm, spielen wir mal ein Modell durch. Die Koalition zerbricht und die Union geht in eine Minderheitsregierung. Würden Sie die AfD das mittragen? Grundsätzlich sind wir immer für vernünftige Sachpolitik. Also wir machen es dann natürlich abhängig von den Dingen, die dann beschlossen werden sollen. Wir halten das für eine ganz vernünftige Option, wenn dann eben wirklich nach Sache, nach Sachlage dann regiert würde. Insofern können wir das nur begrüßen und würden dann natürlich die Dinge, die wir auch für sinnvoll erachten, mit unterstützen. Dann gehen wir es mal durch. Erstmal gibt es einen Sparaushalt von mehreren Milliarden. Mit der AfD zu machen?
Tja, was meinst du? Ist mit der AfD ein Sparhaushalt zu machen? Könnte gut sein. Könnte sein. Mal gucken, was er sagt.
Absolut zu machen. Wir müssen sparen. Wir können nicht noch weiter Schulden auftürmen. Wir haben ja jetzt schon das Problem, dass die Schulden maximal aufwachsen, von Anfang des Jahrzehnts bei 4 Milliarden bis auf 80 Milliarden Ende des Jahrzehnts. Und das kann sich Deutschland bei Weitem nicht mehr leisten.
Nee, das können wir uns echt nicht mehr leisten. Hier muss jetzt in den sauren Apfel gebissen werden. Jetzt, also das ist so weit. Der Springer fragt ja da auf den. Eine Sendung, die ich jedes Mal mehr hasse, wenn ich sie höre, ist dieses Studio Neuen vom Deutschlandfunk. Ich verachte diese Sendung so krass einfach. Ich hab sie noch nie gehört. Ich kenn sie immer nur hier von Clips und zweimarsch. Da werden dann irgendwelche Gäste eingeladen und so. Ach ja und Timmy hier und da. Aber es ist schon nicht so gut, so einen Wal so zu quälen. Oder nee, ist echt nicht gut. So blablabla. Also einfach so ein Nachmittagssingsang. Wir hören einfach so mitten rein.
Friedrich Merz hat leider die Angewohnheit.
Wie hat es Margarita Stokowski, die Kolumnistin vom Spiegel, so schön beschrieben, rumzuonkeln. Also er onkelt einfach wahnsinnig gerne rum und belehrt Menschen. Und ich glaube, da kommt er nicht so schnell raus. Also dieses auf Augenhöhe, hey, ich hör dir zu, du bist ein junger Mensch, sag mir was, was dir fehlt. Was möchtest du?
Ich glaube, da kommt er nicht.
Er hat ja noch viel Lernbedarf als Kanzler, aber ja auch, muss man sagen, macht er erst seit einem Jahr, hat die Erfahrung auch noch nie gehabt.
Und es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so die Rhetorik.
Und so stürzen wir uns immer drauf. Und die ist wahrscheinlich auch wirklich nicht die Beste. Auch auf dem DGB hat er dann auf der einen Seite versucht, die Reformen zu verteidigen, die ja auch irgendwie inhaltlich man verteidigen kann, kann man so oder so.
Aber dann wieder von sowas gesprochen, wie die Deutschen müssen sich aufraffen.
Und das hört sich natürlich wieder so an.
Da ist auch wieder der Gedanke vom faulen Deutschen im Hinterkopf.
Aber inhaltlich sind ja auch viele nicht zufrieden. Riesenthema ist jetzt die Rentenreform. Da muss ich aber sagen, wenn er jetzt noch mal hat durchblicken lassen, da muss was passieren und gleichzeitig sagt, das ist keine Bösartigkeit, sondern Demografie und Mathematik. Da hat er doch recht.
Es gibt ja Länder, die schaffen das irgendwie besser.
Ja, also da hat er doch recht.
Wie kann man das denn sagen, dass das einfach Demografie und Mathematik ist? Das ist Demografie und Mathematik, Wolfgang. 1 plus 1 ist 2. Sonst darf ja nicht umverteilt werden, in keiner Art und Weise. Das ist verboten. Das ist ja auch Mathematik. Das ist der Satz des Pythagoras. Bitte verteilt niemand Vermögen um. Ich will mal so sagen, Deutschlands BIP sind jetzt so 4 Billionen. Ja. Weil hier 45 Millionen Leute arbeiten. Ja. Und wir übersehen jetzt mal, wie viele Ausländer das so sind. Dass jedes Jahr mehr Ausländer als Deutsche eingestellt werden im deutschen Arbeitsmarkt. Das wird schon übersehen. So, das heißt, so 4,5 Billionen werden so durchgewälzt durch Menschen arbeiten, Menschen bezahlen irgendwas, wie auch immer. Und dann am Ende wird ein Strich drunter gezogen und 10 Prozent davon, 350 Milliarden, wird als Rente ausgezahlt. Fließt aber direkt wieder ins BIP, weil die Leute gehen ja einkaufen. Dann würde ich sagen, ja, das ist Mathematik und Demografie. Aber in dieser Gleichung fehlen ja einfach 10 Billionen, die ja auch da sind. Und die kamen ja irgendwo her. Und jetzt fehlen die aber irgendwo. Da hat auch jemand Mathematik. Kann man da auch mal Mathematik machen? Oder ist das einfach da, sieht man das einfach nicht? Es ist so unglaublich. Vor allem von Deutschland-Funkjournalisten, wo man weiß, die haben noch eine schöne Pension und reden jetzt schon mal über die Rente der anderen. Die Leute fahren ja da rechts und links mit irgendwelchen Holpert-Die-Polter-Verträgen. Auch zum Glück habe ich noch mal ein Jahr Vertrag gekriegt und so raus aus diesem System. Und stellen dann fest, dass gar nichts mehr funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich machen sie sogar noch Sendungen gegen ihr Interesse. Absolut. Die machen aus Dummheit, weil sie wirklich nicht aufgeklärt sind über sich selber. Es ist nicht mal eine demographische, es ist eine biografische Nicht-Aufgeklärt-Sein. Sie wird doch keinen reichen Rentner kennen, den sie da gemeint. Also wir wissen ja, wie die Rente bezahlt wird. Davor was gesagt wurde, mit den jungen Leuten auf Augenhöhe. Der Kanzler ist nicht mit mir auf Augenhöhe, auch nicht mit einem 20-Jährigen oder einem 70-Jährigen.
Der Kanzler ist der Kanzler.
Der ist nicht auf einer Augenhöhe. Dann wird gesagt, da hat er noch Lernbedarf. Nein, er sagt es genau so, wie er es da meint. Warum wieder diese Kommunikationsberatung, wie bei Jagoda Marinic? Dann fällt tatsächlich der Satz, und der war nicht ironisch gemeint, dass er kann, dass er es seit einem Jahr macht. Der 70-Jährige, weißt du, wo man so denkt, typischerweise. Der jetzt ein halbes Jahrhundert CDU hinter sich hat und nur sich in politischen und wirtschaftlichen Gefilden herumgetrieben hat. Muss noch ein bisschen lernen. Ich würde ja sagen, das Lernen kann man, also Enzyklika lesen. Da muss man sich auch nicht für KI interessieren. Die ersten 100 kommen mit Menschenbilder aus und so. Kann man das lesen. Aber hier sollte man zwingend mal kurz in die Dunkelkammer zurückgehen. Also ihr Mikrofone mal ausschalten beim Deutschlandfunk. Mittags einfach kurz stille. Ja. So, das ist aber dieser typische Sing-Sang, der also dazu führt, dass die AfD, muss man sich jetzt vorstellen, also wir haben ja heute schon durch Enzyklika lesen und so, wir müssen jetzt die allergrößten Selbstverständlichkeiten einmal ausformulieren. Die AfD wird hier in Deutschland das Ruder übernehmen, weil sie den Leuten sagt, und wir nehmen euch das Geld weg. Und man denkt sich so, ne, könnt ihr nicht wenigstens ein Wahlgeschenk machen? So, die NSDAP, da war das damals ganz anders. Wir hören kurz, Lanz referiert, Lanz lässt sich ja sehr gute Sachen immer hinlegen, die er dann referiert. Lanz referiert mal kurz, wie das damals bei der Machtübernahme der NSDAP war. Und ich denke mir, also wenn wir schon das alles nochmal machen, ja, dann wenigstens so.
Und die NSDAP damals, das arbeitet Ali eben raus, hat sozusagen mit diesen ganz simplen sozialen Fragen im Grunde die Leute gekriegt. Die haben versprochen, die Halbierung der Gebühren für Arztbesuche.
So, wie kriegen wir die AfD? Wir schaffen Ärzte ab. Das ist der Weg gerade zur AfD, ne? Und kostenlose Hautarztbesuche. Damals hat man den Leuten gesagt, ihr dürft jetzt zum Arzt gehen. Und das Volk hat sich verführen lassen. Wir fragen uns wieso. In 100 Jahren fragen sich die Leute, also die AfD kam und hat beim Springer gesagt, wir müssen sparen und allen das Geld wegnehmen. Und dann haben die sich da und das Wort lautet verführen. Das verstehe ich nicht. Ja, das ist ja der Grund, warum, auch wenn Adam Toos ja auf der Gegenseite steht dabei, also die haben ja einen langen Disput um diese auch wirtschaftliche Analyse, die Ali dann später gemacht hat, aber das mal beiseite gelassen. Das ist ja der Grund, warum Adam Toos bei einem Vortrag mal sagte, ja, mit der AfD kann man ja noch nicht mal Faschismus machen. Weil Faschismus natürlich schon in gewisser Weise diese anfängliche Sozialstaatlichkeit meint und diesen baubenden Staat, der natürlich darauf ausgerichtet war, die entsprechende Kriegswirtschaft herzustellen. Das hieß damals, das hatte Serbzialismus im Namen. Wir fragen uns heute, wie haben die sich verführen lassen? Ich denke mir, naja, man hat den Arzttermine versprochen.
Also das verstehe ich.
Die AfD macht Übernahmegrad, verstehe ich nicht. Also wir hören das mal durch.
Das sind die Rezepte, der Stopf für auch rechtskräftige Pfändungsbescheide, Stopf von Zwangsversteigerungen vom Bauernhöfen, Senkung des Bierpreises um 10 Prozent. Und wenn man sich mal anschaut und da ist durchaus und ich meine jetzt nur im Mechanismus ja, auch an der Parallele da, wenn du dir anschaust, auch diese dieser Politiker-Typus, die jetzt auch in den USA zum Beispiel aufsteigt oder bereits aufgestiegen ist und ähnliches kannste in ganz Europa sehen. Das ist auf der einen Seite diese etablierte Politik, die immer im Verdacht steht und häufig stellen sie es ja auch unter Beweis, dass sie nicht wirklich verstehen, wie das Leben von ganz normalen Menschen aussieht. Und auf der anderen Seite Parteien, rechtspopulistische Parteien häufig, auch links mittlerweile, die genau das adressieren. Und Ali sagt, die meisten Leute damals, aus der NSDAP, die stammten aus Verhältnissen, in denen sie genau das kannten, die kannten Mietschulden, die kannten Pfändungsdrohungen, das mulmige Gefühl, wie es ist, wenn der Gerichtsvollzieher klingelt und so weiter. Joseph Goebbels, der berüchtigte Propagandaminister später, den zitiert er häufig. Der hat Tagebuch geführt. Und noch 1929 schreibt dieser Goebbels, der Gerichtsvollzieher war da und hat Kuckucks geklebt. Und am nächsten Tag schreibt er dann in seinem Tagebuch, viel Sorge um den Gerichtsvollzieher und die Schuld von 500 Mark. Und knapp vier Wochen später schreibt er, Gerichtsvollzieher hat gerade Radio und Föhn abgeholt, ganz wieder das Recht. Das heißt, diese Leute hatten diese Erfahrung und haben diese ganz simplen wirtschaftlichen Nöte der Leute adressiert.
Eine Abstiegsgesellschaft.
Exakt.
Das ist die Parallele.
Genau.
Und die Moral ist, wenn nicht die Freunde der liberalen Demokratie die Systemfrage stellen, dann stellen die Feinde der liberalen Demokratie die Systemfrage. Ja, das ist sehr schön, recht.
Aber damals war das Nationalsozialismus. Und das war erfolgreich. Und ich denke mir, ja, das kann ich nachvollziehen. Aber dass dieser Nationalsaddismus gerade, wir quälen euch zu Tote, wir nehmen euch alles Geld weg und so, ja, das verstehe ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Tja, aber wenn man nicht mehr um seine Interessen weiß. Zwei Clips von Lars Klingbeil aus diesem Gespräch bei Machtwechsel. Hast du es gehört? Nein. Ich bin durch Rom gelaufen, war fasziniert von der Stadt und hatte gleichzeitig diese Worte aus der Heimat im Ohr und habe mir gedacht, Alter, du kommst nie mehr wieder. Jetzt gerade kriege ich es nicht zusammen. Hier sind gerade zwei Leute in Rom. Also mein Körper und mein Geist ist irgendwo anders. Folgende zwei kleine Snippets von Lars Klingbeil, unserem möchtigen Kanzler und Vizekanzler.
Ich habe eine feste Überzeugung und die ist, dass die Menschen in diesem Land wollen, dass was passiert.
Ach so. Ja, Lars, so regeln wir die Zukunft. Einfach, dass was passiert. Ja, das war jetzt acht Sekunden. Wir hören uns das nochmal 43 Sekunden an. Da muss doch irgendwas dahinter stecken.
Ich war neulich beim Zoll in Leipzig, am Flughafen, hab da einen Termin gemacht, war ein sehr, sehr schöner Besuch, den ich da als Finanzminister hatte. Und dann hab ich mit den Kollegen vom Zoll gestanden und hab gesagt, so, Presse war weg, was wollt ihr noch wissen? Gibt's irgendwas, was ihr mir sagen wollt? Und dann meldete sich so eine junge Kollegin und hat gesagt, kriegt das hin im Land, macht was zusammen, trefft Entscheidungen, handelt zusammen, macht dieses Land stark und sorgt dafür, dass die Demokratie hier stabil bleibt und so weiter. Und das ist die Messlatte, die die meisten Bürgerinnen und Bürger an uns legen. Und deswegen ist meine Überzeugung, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir machen jetzt ein dreiviertel Jahr lang nichts, weil Wahlen sind, dann fällt uns das auch auf die Füße. Das haben wir übrigens. Es gibt auch genug Beispiele in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik, wo man gesagt hat, wir haben Angst vor Politik.
Ich will ja nicht an Aussagen von Politikern zweifeln, aber ich darf doch nochmal nachfragen. Man spricht mit einer Zollbeamtin, die dann nochmal dem Vizekanzler zu ruft, stärkt die Demokratie. Ich wohne ja in Koblenz unter normalen Menschen. Ich höre nie von irgendjemandem, stärkt die Demokratie. Ich kenne Leute, die sagen, hier müsste unbedingt mal die Straße gemacht werden. Leider hat die Kita geschlossen, weil dies und das ist. Das Schwimmbad wird doch nicht mehr aufgemacht. Da muss dringend was getan werden. Es muss was passieren, aber im punto, ganz konkret meine Lebenswelt. Ich habe noch nie jemanden so abstrakt über Demokratie oder so sprechen hören, außer auf den entsprechenden Podien, die man sich jetzt reinziehen kann. Also ich glaube natürlich dem Finanzminister, wenn er sowas sagt und Vize kann. Das muss eine ganz außergewöhnliche Zollbeamtin gewesen sein. Und Robin Alexander und Dagmar Rosenfeld sind sich auch ganz sicher, dass er gerade auf der Höhe seiner politischen Karriere ist, wo ich mir denke, das ist für jeden Bundesminister so. Und ja, ganz beeindruckend. Ist einfach schlimm. Wir sprechen noch einmal über den Krieg. Nun den Krieg von Israel gegen den Libanon. Wir hören einen Beitrag von Monitor.
Panzer auf den Straßen, Bagger, die das Dorf dem Erdboden gleich machen. Eine israelische Flagge auf den Ruinen. Diese Bilder zeigen, wie auch weitere Dörfer im Süd-Libanon von Israels Armee systematisch gesprengt werden.
Diese Bilder erinnern uns doch an Gaza, oder?
Israelische Regierungspolitiker haben für den Libanon eine klare Vorlage.
Alle Häuser in Dörfern nahe der Grenze im Libanon werden zerstört. Das ist das Modell Rafah und Beit Hanun aus Gaza.
Darieh wird aussehen wie Hanunis.
Darieh ist im Libanon Hanunis in Gaza. Eine Stadt, die 2023 so aussah, von der jetzt kaum etwas übrig geblieben ist. So wie von nahezu ganz Gaza. Über 76 Prozent der Gebäude wurden zerstört oder beschädigt.
Also zu diesem großen Themenkomplex. Man weiß ja wirklich nicht mehr, was man kommentieren soll dazu. Ich habe jetzt glücklicherweise diese Erfahrung im Vatikan gewesen zu sein. Ich kenne alle Symbolik. Der Vatikan zeichnet sich aus durch zwei Schlüssel über all den Rom verteilt. Einer weiß, einer gold. Deswegen ja die zwei Farben, weiß und gelb. Und das sind eben die Schlüssel. Und das eine ist weltlich, das andere ist halt himmlisch, sagen wir mal so, salopp. Und der eine Schlüssel davon ist für mich ja. Also bei solchen Fragen wie jetzt, wo man auch wirklich nicht mehr weiß, was soll man dazu noch sagen? Also welche Genozidiskussion soll mir denn noch Definition noch herbeiziehen oder was auch immer? Ich denke mir jetzt einfach, ich habe den Schlüssel jetzt. Ich kann einfach geistig in den Vatikan einziehen und bei solchen Sachen einfach sagen, was dieser Umgang mit Menschen angeht, bin ich komplett auf Seiten des Vatikans. Der Papst spricht für mich in dieser Angelegenheit. And if you are interested in my opinion, just go to vatikan.va.com and read the texts. It's all about people, dealing with each other, what this has to do with Lebanon, who is having a hard time to discuss my opinion, I can't discuss that. I know I am being ruled by the CDU but I am just team Matikan. But we have these developments right now, Lebanon is bigger, Und so, aber ich bin hier Team Matikan einfach. Aber wir haben jetzt gerade diese Entwicklungen, dass ich meine, der Libanon ist größer, deswegen kann man das nicht gleich wie in Gaza machen, aber im Süd-Libanon, dass wir dort Vertreibungen haben, zweieinhalb bis drei Millionen Menschen auf der Flucht, dass dort ganze Häuserblöcke gesprengt werden. Zeitgleich haben wir hier eine Diskussion darüber, ob man bitte mal die Kritik an der israelischen Regierung weiter einschränken kann. Also gerade hier in Hessen, ja. Es ist lächerlich. Vielleicht müssen wir den Podcast bald in Rheinland-Pfalz aufnehmen, weiß ich nicht. Der wäre es weiter kriegen. Erger bekommen von Boris Rhein, der bevor hat, dass Israel Kritik noch viel weiter gefasst wird, so dass alles Mögliche darunter fallen kann, was er dann verbieten will. In Frankfurt. Der Antisemitismusbeauftragte von Hessen ist Uwe Becker. Das ist der Typ, der hier nur 48,0 Prozent bekommen hat. Der ist also besonders wütend auf Frankfurt. Also wir sollten uns nicht wundern, wenn hier demnächst Vertreibung aus dem Bahnhofsfeld stattfindet. Also es ist wirklich eine erstaunliche Entwicklung, dass man jetzt... Und dann sind wir aber in der Diaspora, ja? Ich will die Worte klären. Wo es immer klarer ist, dass Kritik artikuliert werden muss, gibt es jetzt lauter politische Bestrebungen, diese Kritik einzuhägen, Universitäten. Also wir bekommen ja laufende E-Mails, ob das in Köln an der Uni jetzt war oder an anderen Universitäten von Vorträgen, die sich kritisch mit der israelischen Kriegsweise auseinandersetzen, dass diese verboten werden, dass da ausweichenden Plätze gesucht werden müssen und und und. Ich will auch gar nicht im Einzelnen bewerten, wer wo was wo gesagt hat, wo das freie Wort gilt, gilt das freie Wort und alles andere. Wenn man dem widersprechen will, kann man ja in solchen Veranstaltungen tun. Aber dass wir jetzt gerade solche Zensurmaßnahmen immer stärker erleben, die dann auch noch von vielen unterstützt werden, so aus der Presse heraus. Man sagt ja, wie wichtig und die werden da hofiert, also das ist wirklich irre. Ja, beim Monitor hingegen wird doch noch das auch gesagt, was Sache ist.
Janina Dill ist Völkerrechtsexpertin. Wiederholt sich im Libanon das, was in Gaza bis heute geschieht?
Die Einebnung von Grenzdörfern, die Vertreibung der Zivilbevölkerung, beides mit Ankündigung, beides auch so benahmt, das sind schwere Verstöße gegen das humanitäre Völkerrecht. Im Grunde genommen sehr, sehr plausibel. Auch Kriegsverbrechen, die hier passieren, kein Selbstverteidigungsrecht kann das rechtfertigen. Jetzt wird das sogenannte Gaza-Modell ganz explizit im Libanon wiederholt.
Das bedeutet auch eine dauerhafte Besatzung?
Das hier ist der Gaza-Streifen. Die israelische Armee kontrolliert weiterhin etwa 53 Prozent des Gebiet und längst äußern israelische Regierungspolitikerpläne für eine dauerhafte Besatzung in Gaza.
Wenn wir Sicherheit wollen, müssen wir Gaza besiedeln.
Auch nach dem möglichen Fall der Hamas wird die israelische Armee in den von ihr kontrollierten Gebieten innerhalb des Gaza-Streifens bleiben.
Besatzung. Droht das auch im Libanon? Hier kontrolliert Israels Armee bislang rund 6 Prozent und auch hier reden Israels Regierungspolitiker über eine neue Grenze, weniger als 80 Kilometer vor Beirut.
Über die Niederlage der Terrororganisation Hezbollah hinaus muss der Litani-Fluss unsere neue Grenze zum Libanon wehren.
Nicht aufhören.
Nicht im Libanon, nicht in Gaza, nicht im Westjordanland.
Weitermachen.
Na, man weitet die eigenen Grenzen aus. Ich höre schon wieder Merz, der auf irgendeiner Verbandstagung steht, wahllos, die Gelegenheit ergreift, um zu sagen, es ist vier Jahre, ja 2022, also vier Jahre her, bis der Kanzler sagte, es werden keine Grenzen mehr verschoben. Und ich muss ihn leider sagen, ja doch. Da unten geht's.
Hier geht's.
Ich habe jetzt einen Ort gefunden, wo wir das machen können. Ja. Wir haben ja auch noch einen Außenminister. Nur wenn er gesund ist. Ach so. Der Außenminister verhält sich ja mittlerweile wie so ein Drittklässler. Papa, ich habe heute Bauchschmerzen. Ja, warum? Wegen der Mathearbeit?
Nein, ich habe Bauchschmerzen. Fehlt er oft, ja?
Ja, er hat jetzt Termine nicht wahrgenommen, habe ich gehört. Ja, aber er ist auch vielleicht, weil er so besorgt ist. Denkt beim Arzt rum. Er ist besorgt. Wer hat es, könnte da mal was sagen. Nimmt uns die Arzttermin mit. Also Wadephul ist sehr besorgt.
Bundesaußenminister Wadephul zeigte sich zuletzt zwar besorgt, aber mit welchen Konsequenzen? Faktisch setzt die Bundesregierung viel mehr auf Annäherung. Januar 2026. Benjamin Netanyahu trifft Bundesinnenminister Alexander Dobrindt in Israel. Am Ende steht ein gemeinsamer Deal. Es soll um Cybersicherheit gehen.
Das könnte man ja genauso mit der AfD auch machen. Absolut. Also Dobrindt ist ja sowieso in meinen Augen nur der mit dem falschen Parteibuch oder so.
Absolut, ja.
Also Dobrindt ist durch.
Ja. Wadephul hat sich nachdem er in Syrien war und meinte, sieht ja aus wie 45, vom Chef, also vom Vorsitzenden der Jungen Union Hessen so beeindrucken lassen, weil er kurz ein Snippet hatte in den Tagesthemen, dass er danach nie wieder ausgeschert ist. Da ist nichts mehr zu erwarten. Nee, das ist völlig durch. Aber was ist jetzt mit dieser Kooperation? Denn wir haben ja jetzt hier schon von Palantir und all dem gehört. Wir sehen, wie gern man miteinander kooperiert. Wir wissen vom Palantir-Kunder Alex Kaab, dass für ihn auch Groß Israel eine tolle Sache ist, die zu unterstützen ist, auch wenn er das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders ausdrücken würde. Worum geht es jetzt bei dieser neuen Kooperation?
Doch laut dieser Sprecherin von Netanyahu geht es um mehr.
Deutschlands Elite-Polizei wird Seite an Seite trainieren mit Israels Anti-Terror-Einheit Yamam.
Gemeinsame Trainings der deutschen Elite-Einheit GSG 9 mit der Yamam-Einheit. Das ist eine Spezialeinheit der israelischen Grenzpolizei. Sie steht häufig in der Kritik, etwa wegen des Vorgehens im Westjordanland, ziviler Opfer bei Einsätzen, Vorwürfe von Tötungen ohne Prozess.
Damit der Grenzschutz noch besser funktioniert bald. Es gibt noch eine Kooperation.
Februar 2026. Generalleutnant Freuding vom Deutschen Heer trifft in Israel den Kommandeur der israelischen Landstreitkräfte. Am Ende steht ein historischer Moment. Das erste formelle Kooperationsabkommen zwischen dem Deutschen Heer und Israels Bodengruppen.
Wir wollen zusammen Ausbildung und Übungen machen.
And we want to exchange ideas.
Über Einsatzgrundsätze können hier viel voneinander profitieren.
Von unseren Erfahrungen.
Also, das Wandel durch Annäherung. Aber andersrum. Und trotzdem interessant, historisch. Ja. Wer sich jetzt wieder zusammenfindet und so. Ja. Dabei müssen wir nochmal darauf hinweisen. Wir hatten jetzt eben die Frage von Tilo Jung an Felix Banaschak. Wie ist denn das, wenn die AfD regiert? Wie verhält man sich da als Soldat? Man muss sich als Soldat die Frage stellen, in welcher Truppe bin ich da eigentlich, die mit der anderen Truppe kooperiert, von der man sagt, sie habe ein Genozid möglicherweise begangen. Wir warten noch auf Urteile. Aber ist das vielleicht jetzt ein Kooperationspartner, bei dem man sagt, ja, da sollte man unbedingt von lernen? Das ist die Situation, der wir uns da befinden. Was auch noch mal hinzukommt, ist natürlich, dass durch die Neuen Drohnenkriege sich ohnehin die Fronten ja verändert haben. Wir haben diese Killing-Zone schon angesprochen in der Ukraine. Die Killing-Zone sehen wir aber dann zum Beispiel auch im Süd-Libanon, was dann auch dazu führt, dass natürlich die Gegenseite, also die Esboller, sich auch sehr leicht mit günstigen Drohnen bewaffnen kann, die ja weiterfliegen als zehn Kilometer. Bei Al-Jazeera wurde genau darüber diskutiert, was es denn eigentlich mit dieser Killing Zone auf sich hat. Und dieser Idee von Isa eben, er macht einfach so eine zehn Kilometer Puffer-Zone und dann ist Ruhe.
Bring in Elijah on Hezbollah's tactics, because they are using new tactics this time. And interestingly, we've heard about these fiber optic cable drones. That's something they've learned from the war in Ukraine.
The glass fiber? No, apparently they have this range, which they then can extend. It sounds like an upgrade, which we've heard. So face log in, pixel log in, in Bumblebee, then you don't need these lines anymore, but the drone and just look. Und die Killing Zone verbreitert sich dadurch immer mehr. Wir beide wissen ja noch, wie der 11. September über die Welt hereinbrach. Und es war erschreckend einfach für diese Terroristen, Flugzeuge zu kabern, sie als Waffe zu nutzen und dann Hochhäuser zu zerstören. Jetzt ist es noch sehr viel einfacher. Und gleichzeitig sind wir aber alle sehr viel aufgeregter. Also hier unter Terrorgesichtspunkten würde ich sagen, eins plus eins ist leider gerade 500. Hier besteht ja wirklich allergrößte Gefahr. Die Leute haben ja in Garmisch-Partenkirchen plötzlich Angst, wenn sie hören, in Kiel sei jemand mit einem Auto vielleicht in eine Fußgängerzone reingefahren. Also es ist wirklich nicht sehr kompliziert denkbar, dass wir Szenarien haben, bei denen sich von jetzt auf gleich jeder in Deutschland bedroht fühlt. Und ich frage mich, was ist denn dann der Schutzschirm? Was macht ein Doper dann? Permanente Ausnahmezustand. Wir hören hier nochmal über die Killing Zone.
The strategy appears now, in the short term at least, to try to create a wasteland, a killing zone. Again, the Israelis have long dispensed with any care for international humanitarian law, etc. They have their own definition. They don't care. They have carte blanche from the Americans. The idea is to create this killing zone. The fundamental problem has been, and this is what analysts have been warning the Israelis about time and time again, when they keep on invading and occupying or invading and destroying, they create more formidable enemies, time and time again. Now it turns out that a 10-kilometer buffer zone, as Elijah just pointed out, is not really going to be very effective, not even to protect Israeli troops at their border, but much less the kind of hinterlands and border communities or deep into Israel because of technological advances. So you can launch one of these FPV drones from 30 miles, 40 miles, etc.
Ja, also da scheint es eine große äquivalente oder eine Co-Evolution zu geben. So sehr wie man im Gefecht stand, Pistorius hat sich auch einen angeschaut, wo die Ukrainer so ihre Drohnen steuern. Umso mehr man da die Reflektion rausnimmt, umso weniger findet sie auch politisch statt. Denn hier müsste man ja einfach noch mal eine Szenarioplanung machen. Israel im Jahr 2029. Also wollen wir jetzt einfach vorausprojizieren, dass wir jetzt die letzte Woche gemacht haben, machen wir einfach drei Jahre. Oder, ja, gibt es da Veränderungen. Und da würde ich sagen, das sieht wirklich für die keinen Beteiligten gut aus. Und am Ende, man kann ja nicht ewig immer auf die Enzyklika zu sprechen kommen, aber es ist noch mal der Text. SpaceX. Wir machen einen Rundown, es ist wirklich amüsant. Wir sind ja nicht die Doppelgänger. Die Doppelgänger haben sehr gute Ausarbeitung dazu gemacht. Wir hören gleich auch einen Clip. Die Doppelgänger haben sogar noch mal einen Clip in Haken dran rübergeschickt, damit da auch noch mal das thematisiert ist. Wir machen natürlich unsere eigene Aufarbeitung. Denn es ist auch wahnsinnig amüsant. Wir hören Ed Elsen im ProfG Market Podcast, der jetzt selber kurz dazu sagt, ja, also das IPO-Filing, also der Datensatz, der sozusagen Werbematerial ist für die Investoren, kam vor fünf, zehn Minuten. Wir machen jetzt eine spontane Analyse. Und ich denke mir, das hätte man auch in zehn Minuten hingekriegt. Und es wird nicht besser, wenn man länger wartet. Also alle sind erschüttert darüber, was da eigentlich vorgestellt wurde.
Lots of numbers to discuss here. Today we're speaking with Patrick Boyle, Professor at King's College London, former hedge fund manager and host of one of the most popular finance YouTube channels. Patrick, thank you so much for joining us again on the show to discuss again SpaceX, the filing for which literally came out about 15 minutes ago, 20 minutes ago. So we've had that amount of time to get up to speed on it.
So, es geht jetzt um den größten Börsengang der Welt zu einer Firma, die ein Thema bespielt, von dem sich alle am meisten versprechen. Weltraum, irgendwas mit KI und so weiter. Und es ist einfach nur amüsant zu hören.
You know, other things that were interesting, the company has lost $37 billion since inception. There's lots of stuff, there's some new business stuff in there. There's, you know, there's talk about point to point travel, you know, where people will be able to travel from place to place on rockets rather than airplanes. There's talk of, I believe I saw, in orbit manufacturing or at least manufacturing on the moon. But I've noted down in orbit, I'm not sure if that's correct. Asteroidmining is another business that they expect to make money from as well.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit von dem ganzen Scheiß ist wahnsinnig hoch. Und es ist auch ein riesiges Business, dass Leute jetzt als Touristen mit einer 20-Minuten-Reise nach New York, mit einer Rakete, die dann da landet, und alle vertrauen darauf, dass das so und so weiter.
You know, is it profitable? Or is it on the path to profitability? It doesn't seem to be. There's other stuff in there as well. I don't know if you noticed that Elon Musk will get, I think, 85% of the voting shares. There's, you know, he doesn't like, as we know, shareholder lawsuits. And so that has to go to arbitration. So essentially, if you're buying, this is very much an IPO for the Elon Musk fan. Like, you're not necessarily that worried about profitability, you know, it's sort of, you know, it used to be sort of rockets. Now it's rockets, Twitter, AI in space, you know, space manufacturing, transportation by rockets and asteroid mining. And not all of these businesses are functioning at the moment. Even if you look at the, you know, the starship thing, the starship, they're talking about, what is it? Sorry, I've got the numbers down here. Basically, they're talking about hourly launches of starships in order to get, I think, something like a million tons of stuff into space per year. At the moment, you know, I think the next starship test is tomorrow. It's never gone into orbit. It's never carried any cargo. I think it's going to carry some dummy SpaceX satellites tomorrow. But this is, you know, this is very much a vibes-based IPO. Like it's for people who are excited about Elon Musk.
Ja. Es ist ein Kult, mit anderen Worten. Es ist wirklich ein Kult. So. Und jetzt so ein paar Zeilen. Also irgendwo müssen doch mal Gewinne abfallen, oder?
The mission of this company is to quote, ensure species level redundancy and that the light of consciousness will not be tied to a single planet. It's also to quote, understand the true nature of the universe.
Also es geht, er liest hier vor, um Spezien-Redundanz. Dass das menschliche Bewusstsein nicht an ein Planeten gefesselt ist. Ja. In a multi-planetary future, bla bla bla. Multi-planetary existence sollst du führen. Sure that humans do not always stay in your Frankfurt. Genau, der IPO-Bericht ist so aufgebaut, dass man in die ersten 20 Seiten einfach nur Raketen hat, die so auf Bildern rumfliegen. Erst danach geht es in die Zahlen.
Don't have the same fate as dinosaurs. By the way, that phrase, the light of consciousness is mentioned 10 times in the filing. And AI...
Sehr schön, dass Elon Musk die Fackel des Bewusstseins jetzt in den Weltraum trägt....
is mentioned over 1200 times in the filing. Just looking at profitability again, they break out each of the businesses into space as a business. Connectivity, which is like satellites and AI. Space lost 662 million dollars in Q1. Connectivity turned a 1.1 billion dollar profit. And it seems that actually the satellite business is pretty good. AI lost two and a half billion dollars. And that really struck me that maybe this AI thing is perhaps the problem.
And I think that's per quarter, isn't it, that loss?
That's the quarterly number.
Ja, also von Croc ist in dem Sinne nichts zu erwarten. Da macht man keine relevanten Homesätze mit. Jeden Monat eine Milliarde Verlust. Ja. Jetzt haben sie ja natürlich diesen großen Deal mit Entropic, die ja das Rechenzentrum einfach nutzen und dieser Verlust wird ausgeglichen, zumindest das. Aber wir müssen uns jetzt kurz im Hinterkopf merken, diese KI-Sparte, die da drinsteckt in diesem ganzen Prospekt, macht jeden Monat eine Milliarde Verlust. So, weil nachher werden kontradiktierende Zahlen genannt zur Bedeutung dieser KI-Sparte in dem SpaceX. Wir denken ja, das hat mit dem Weltraum zu tun. Nein, das ist ja zusammengeschnürt. Also mich hat es ein bisschen erinnert, an diese Schrottpapiere, die man so gebündelt hatte, mit ein paar guten Papieren, um so ein AAA-Rating zu bekommen, weißt du? Ja, das ist im Grunde diese Finanzmarktarchitektur, bei der es dann später heißt, ich habe das nicht vorher gesehen. Hoch ist wieder eine Finanzkredit-2008. Und ich muss ein bisschen dran denken an diese Struktur, dass man einfach so alles mit reinpackt, das so geschickt miteinander verbündet, dass man den Börsenwert so hochtreiben kann. Aber eigentlich, wenn man sich dann die Einzelzahlen ansieht, ist es nicht so toll. Aber über all dem wacht ja dann, das muss man auch nochmal hier extra betonen, hier wurde es ja gesagt, mit 85 Prozent, Stimmrecht der Elon Musk. Stimmrecht der Eigentümer Elon Musk. Das heißt, das Board, das es noch gibt, besteht wirklich nur noch aus Clowns. Also die vorläufige Schlussfolgerung hier ist, das Ding mal schnell in die Börse bringen, bevor jemand zu genau hinschaut.
I mean, looking at these numbers, personally, this seems insane. What do you think this means for the IPO? Do you think that this stock will actually perform well?
You know, firstly, I think they're kind of rushing it out largely because it's burning so much money, right? Like 37 billion in losses since inception. And you know, the VCs and whatever only want to keep putting more money in for so long. And there's a very hot market right now. S&P is near highs. And people are excited by Elon Musk stuff. They're also excited about AI.
So, also irgendwo schwirren 50 bis 75 Milliarden rum, die man jetzt schon einsammeln will, um dann vier Prozent des Unternehmens zu verkaufen, um die Marktkapitalesumme insgesamt auf zwei Billionen zu treiben. Ob man danach noch mal eine weitere 45% Charge für eine Billion verkauft. Also das Problem kennt man ja. Das macht dann halt die Börse irgendwie. Und dann heißt es später A-Erfolgsaktie. Bisher auch noch reingefallen. These.
VC Funding is kind of drying up for this sort of stuff. This is worth a lot and they want their money back. On top of that, you've got big IPOs coming from OpenAI and coming from Anthropic.
So, also, das ist einfach ein Exit für die Investoren, die bis jetzt ihr Venture Capital da reingehauen haben. Die wollen jetzt ausgezahlt werden. Also muss man jetzt die Normallos einladen. Ey, werd doch Aktionär bei SpaceX. In der Hoffnung, dass ein paar Tausend Leute ein paar Millionen zusammenschleppen, wenn jeder seine 15.000 da investiert. Naja, aber die institutionellen Anleger müssen ja, das ist das Verrückte ja, das verstärkt die Verknappung, ja dann mitgehen. Das heißt, wenn diese Aktie so wertvoll wird, wenn sie so beliebt ist, müssen die institutionellen Anleger mit rein, wenn sie in den Indizes ist. Das heißt, das genügt ja so als Anschub, um dann das Ganze zu verstetigen dadurch. Ja, also das ist eine sehr große Verarsche, die natürlich überall auffällt, außer im Deutschlandfunk, wo sonst, da ist der Singsang einfach dieser.
Der geplante Börsengang von SpaceX springt jedes bisher dagewesene Maß. Frei nach dem Motto, the sky is the limit, steht dem Unternehmen in der Fantasie einiger Investoren buchstäblich das Weltall offen.
Das alles so interessant, weil es einfach viele Geschäftsmodelle bietet, sagt Eckhard Schulte von der Vermögensverwaltung MeinSky. Denken wir an den Massenmarkt, Satelliteninternet, aber auch der Abbau von Rohstoffen und im All scheint eben immer die Sonne. Das heißt, wir können Energie erzeugen. Es gibt ja auch Überlegungen, Rechenzentren deswegen ins All zu verlegen. Und auch für Militär und Verteidigung ist die Nutzung des Weltalls essentiell.
Also das ist für mich voll Volksaktien-Vibes, das so zu reportieren. Wir kriegen es noch nicht hin, hier Fotovoltaikanlagen auf die Dächer zu bekommen, aber wir werden das mal alles im All realisieren. Und wir brauchen hier die Einsicht in eine bittere Wahrheit. Ich war gestern, wurde heute morgen veröffentlicht, im Hackentram Podcast bei Gavin. Der hat eine Studie vorgestellt aus Australien. Junge Menschen berichten, sie kriegen weniger Konfrontation mit Nachrichten, weil sie jetzt kein Social Media mehr haben. Und Gavin fand das besorgniserregend und ich fand es gut. Denn es ist gut, wenn Leute sowas nicht mehr hören. Oder über eine Kachel von News stolpern oder Focus oder was auch immer. Dann lieber nichts. Dann lieber zurück in die 80er, 90er, als einfach niemand sich immer ständig mit Politik befasste, sondern man das so einmal die Woche im Fernsehen kurz mitbekam. Aber mehr Demokratie wagen und so, on vogue war. Weil du jetzt das mehrmals aufgerufen hast, das werden nicht alle wissen, mit der Volksaktie. Das war der Trend dann vor der Dotcom-Place, bevor sie platzte, von der Telekom, die ging an die Börse. Und dann gab es, weil es noch nicht über Push-Nachrichten gehen konnte, täglich rauf und runter im Fernsehen und im Radio Spots, damals mit dem beliebten Tatortkommissar Manfred Krug, der für Solidität wie kein anderer stand und für sicheres Anlegen, wurde man also dann gebeten, doch hier bei der Telekom einzusteigen. Das entpuppte sich dann bald als ein großes Fiasco, weshalb man immer wieder von der Volksaktie heute redet, um zu sagen, wenn dieser Vibe da ist, lieber die Finger davon. Es war wirklich ein Vibe damals. Das ist keine Sache von heute. Man kann das noch so ein bisschen, wenn man alte Harald-Schmidt-Shows guckt, aus der Sat.1-Zeit, da kann man das sehen, der hat doch damals diesen Vibe auch mitgespielt. Da wurde das gut aufgegriffen. Der Big Tech Podcast.
I don't know if I'm angry. It's more like I was shocked. So, okay, so, Open AI at a negative 122 percent operating income margin. I'm weirdly okay with that. As SpaceX at a total of $18.7 billion in revenue, of which 11 billion is Starlink, and that's the whole thing, and it's a $2 trillion company, I just, I don't know what, how we got here. I thought this was such a bigger thing, a bigger like vehicle of capital and cash and everything. This genuinely shocked me.
Ja, denn wir haben typischerweise Internet für ein paar Irre, die sagen, aber was ist, wenn morgen eine Atombombe auf Frankfurt fällt, dann habe ich ja kein Internet mehr. Ja, dann buchst du dir Starlink für 15 Euro extra. Damit kann man aber nicht so ein Business machen. Also damit kann man einfach kein 2-Billion-Business machen. Ja, vor allem wenn es sehr an der Fläche, dann ist das, Starlink hat ja jetzt gerade diesen Ukraine-Vorteil. Ja, da kann man sich damit profilieren. Und jetzt hat man ja auch gerade den russischen Starlink dann doch jetzt abgeschaltet. Die Zeit lang hatte ja Russland das dann über Zwischenhändler doch alles noch machen können. Wo dann Elon Musk eine Zeit lang sagte, ne, das stimmt gar nicht, war aber dann doch wieder so. Da fragt man sich auch, also man hat die ganze Zeit den russischen Infrastruktur zur Verfügung gestellt, damit die bessere Drohnenkriege führen können. Ah ja, also offenbar schon. Jedenfalls mal davon abgesehen von diesen Konfliktherden, wo das natürlich brauchbar ist. Wenn wir das jetzt so auf eine Fläche denken, wenn wir sagen, okay, möglicherweise ist das eine Zukunft, dass wir daher das Internet bekommen. Wir machen das nicht mehr über die Kabel im Boden und so was. Das läuft nicht so gut. Dann wissen wir ja, dass das ein, also Telekommunikationsunternehmen, das ist ja ein hochkompetitiver Markt. Das heißt, da sind ja nicht Gewinnmargen zu erreichen, die eine solche Börsenbewertung rechtfertigen. Also Starlink ist was für Flugzeuge, ja, Ozeanübersegler und halt Leute, die gerne Redundanz haben, weil sie irgendwie was hochsicher sind. Ja, und noch Teile der Welt, die nicht so sehr erschlossen sind, aber da werden ja nicht solche margenfällig. Das sind typischerweise nicht die reichsten Orte der Welt. So, jetzt haben wir ja vorhin gehört, im Grunde ist diese KI-Branche oder Sparte gar nicht richtig vorhanden. Es gibt dafür nur ein riesiges Rechenzentrum und zum Glück kann man es vermieten, aber Elon Musk hat jetzt deswegen keine Anteile an Entropic oder weiß auch nur, was da passiert. Er hat einfach einen Datenkabel. So, jetzt hören wir aber hier dieses im Grunde nicht vorhandene Marktanteil 0, % und jeden Monat 1 Milliarde Verlust. Wird aber hier nochmal anders konnotiert in diesem Prospekt.
So, this is what annoyed me. SpaceX told us that it had the biggest total addressable market of all time. 28.5 trillion dollars. That was the market. Okay, so I'm thinking, you know, you're gonna go to space and do all these things, build the Mars colony. What is the biggest sort of revenue driver there? 93% of that opportunity is AI, with enterprise applications accounting for the vast majority. So, SpaceX thinks of this 26.5, 28, 28.5 trillion dollar TAM. 22.7 trillion is AI enterprise applications. What?
So, ich schlüssel das kurz auf. Das kann man wirklich nicht glauben. Entropic trifft diese Entscheidung zu sagen, wir gehen in Code. Und die ganzen Unternehmen so, ist genau mein Use Case. OpenAI sagt, wir machen den Leuten so eine App aufs Handy und dann können die sich so Rezepte zusammensammeln, was auch immer, was sie im Alltag so brauchen. 2 Jahre später stellen alle fest, also Entropiq hat das Rennen gewonnen. Mehr Umsatz, treuere Kunden und ein echten Use Case. OpenAI so, wir hauen jetzt alles weg, wir gehen komplett in Kodex, wir kopieren jetzt Entropiq. So, OpenAI schafft das gerade so, da dran zu bleiben, was Entropiq macht. Jetzt kommt Elon Musk und sagt, also meine 15 Milliarden Verlustsparte, die ich aber als bei Profiterwartung, die ich meinen künftigen Investoren verspreche, 93 Prozent ausmache, ist Unternehmens-KI. Also wenn ein Markt zu ist, wo auch völlig klar ist, Leute sagen jetzt nicht, es gibt zwar Claude Code und OpenAI Kodex, aber ich nehme jetzt Croc, das gibt es einfach nicht. Das habe ich ja noch nie gehört. Aber eher einfach, damit mache ich 20 Trillionen Umsatz. Denn es wird das beste System irgendwann sein. Das ist höchste Größe Scheiß der Welt. Das ist unglaublich. Hier ein bisschen Doppelgänger.
Das eigentliche Milliardengrab ist aber natürlich die KI-Sparte.
Ja, das ist ein Milliardengrab.
Die allein 6,3 Milliarden im letzten Jahr verbrannt hat und dieses Quartal oder das letzte Quartal nochmal 2,5 Milliarden verbrannt hat. Also wird dieses Jahr 10 bis 12 Milliarden verbrennen, schätzt man die KI-Sparte und wir wissen, die trägt nicht signifikant zum Umsatz bei, wie ich mehrmals gesagt habe und es wird hier wieder bestätigt.
Bedeutet das, der Laden wäre genauso viel wert, wenn die KI-Sparte nicht da wäre oder vielleicht sogar mehr?
Da würde ich am Ende nochmal drauf kommen vielleicht, weil das ein bisschen das Resümee sein könnte.
Ja, also diese Port, die hebe ich mir mal auf für mein Finale, dass es vielleicht alles besser wäre, wenn diese scheiß KI-Sparte da nicht drin wäre, von der Elon Musk 93 Prozent der Profiterwartung drauscht.
Also es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Wir hören uns jetzt nochmal auf Deutsch, die Doppelgänger gehen nochmal, die Wachstumsprognose von dem, was da in dem Prospekt angepriesen wird durch.
Es gibt ein schönes Zitat dazu, also weil man keine Zahlen liefern kann, hat Elon Musk stattdessen Zitat im IPO-Prospekt entlassen. Und zwar schreibt er da, It's important to consider for the, also es geht um den expliziten AI-Bereich dabei, It's important to consider for the competitiveness of any technology company. What matters is not the position at any point in time, but what is your velocity and acceleration. And if you're moving faster than anyone else, in any given technology arena, you will be the leader. And XAI is moving faster than any other company, no one is even close. Das ist, was er sagt.
So, ich übersetze. Elon Musk schreibt also ausdrücklich da ein, es ist nicht so wichtig, wo du gerade bist, sondern wie schnell du wächst, weil dann holst du die anderen ja automatisch ein, ist dann nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Was die Zahlen zeigen, egal, es geht ja gar nicht. Also ob die Position, wir können sagen, es ist nicht mal 5% des Umsatzes von OpenAI und Entropic, also lass uns auf die Position scheißen, lass uns stattdessen auf die Geschwindigkeit gucken, wie er vorschlägt. Aber die Geschwindigkeit ist 12,5% Wachstum, während sich andere verzehnfachen, also 1000% Wachstum haben. Also wen will er mit diesem Bullshit blenden? XCI ist unheimlich klein und wächst in dem Markt, der so...
Ja, wächst nicht. Also es ist wirklich, bleibt ja eine Frage. Warum? Wer kauft das? Und wer ist der neue Manfred Krug, der uns das verkaufen möchte? Und damit sind wir beim All-In-Podcast, also unsere dreieinhalb Milliardäre, die die ganze Zeit um David Sext und so, uns den ganzen Scheiß verherrlichen, der hier wirklich einfach tot am Boden liegt. Und da hören wir diesen... Was ich noch gerade einführen will, nicht, dass wir jetzt in ein paar Wochen, also wir geben ja eh hier keine Anlagetipps. Zweitens kann sich die Aktie natürlich jetzt lange Zeit gut nach oben erst mal entwickeln, weil wir ja offenbar hier mit einem System der kompletten Entkopplung zu tun haben. Also während wir jetzt beim Krieg Entgrenzung haben, haben wir hier Entkopplung. Das hat mit realwirtschaftlichen Zusammenhängen nichts zu tun. Die gibt es ja mitunter schon bei der Börse, aber offenbar hat man hier ein Finanzpaket geschnürt, das für Elon Musk sehr gut ausgehen könnte, vorerst zumindest, was aber nichts mit der Realität zu tun haben muss, die wir draußen realwirtschaftlich antreffen. Genau. Der Gegenbeweis zu dem, was ich hier Schlussfolgere, ist nicht, dass, ah ja, jetzt sind die an die Börse gegangen und zwei Billionen wert, Marktkapitalisierung. Das werden die locker erreichen, weil sie einen so kleinen Teil davon verkaufen und eine so große, ich habe noch 10 Milliarden übrig, wo schieße ich denn die hin? Ich habe jetzt schon drei Jachten gekauft. Das wird dieser Abnehmer finden für diese drei Prozent des Unternehmens, die dann die Börse gebracht werden. Das sind aber nicht mal 100 Milliarden zu bewegen. Plus man verliert ja nicht dieses Geld wirklich, weil man tauscht ja nur ein Geldschein gegen eine Aktie. Also das bleibt ja Geld, das wird ja auch immer übersehen. Man denkt ja immer, es ist ja halt eine Investition, das Geld ist ja da nicht weg. Dass man es halt ein bisschen mit Verlust, vielleicht wenn es dann doch schief geht oder so verkauft. Aber deswegen für sehr viele Leute plus diese Automatismen, also wenn die in die Indizes reinrutschen, müssen eh die institutionellen Anleger da ihre Anteile kaufen und so weiter. Also das wird schon gut über die Bühne gehen. Die Frage ist nur, was hat man da gekauft und was bedeutet es, dass das, was wir jetzt gehört haben, der größte Börsengang in der Geschichte der Menschheit ist? So, dass so darüber gesprochen wird. Und jetzt hören wir die verherrliche. Also, Shamad Palihabatia, einer der wirklich großen Investoren, die da die Dinge halt so machen, und jetzt mittlerweile ihre eigenen Podcasts haben und so. Der erzählt uns das.
The Internet has to sit physically somewhere. And the assault on data center builds out in the United States right now, I think, may indicate the importance of having an alternative Internet. From the ground layer up, if you have a communication network that isn't restricted and controlled by a government on Earth, it's almost like a backup for civilization, but it's a backup for progress.
Ja, also es ist ein Backup für Fortschritt, wenn wir Datensender jetzt dort bauen können, wo das Weltraumrecht gilt. Also, und das Recht des Stärkeren. Du hast ja mal einen Text dazu gelesen. Und ja, wenn Elon Musk derjenige ist, der diese Infrastruktur anbietet, hat er halt einen Vorsprung vor allen anderen. Und da darf man jetzt nicht die allgemeinen Finanzkennzifferlogik anwenden.
And I don't own any SpaceX shares, and I'm not trying to sell the book of SpaceX. But I think that there's like an important aspect of, can you create a system that's not under the control of governments as a way to ensure humanity's progress, to ensure civilizational continuity if things go south, if things aren't good, if things are restricted, and if fundamental forms of tyranny start to restrict speech, restrict commerce, restrict information flow and whatnot. And I think having a space-based communication network, space-based data centers, and space-based communication back down to Earth, wireless, I think is generally a good thing. It's good to have a backup. Yeah. So put all the economics aside and the multiples and evaluations and whatnot, and whether it's SpaceX or not. I think the idea that you could have data centers, store information, transmit information, route information, and access information through space-based systems that can't be controlled, manipulated or destroyed by governments is important. And I just like that.
Das ist der libertäre Traum. So, ja, das sind jetzt, es gibt in Amerika 2000 Milliardäre, aber 300 Millionen Menschen. Das heißt für 99,9999% der Leute ist einfach, mein WLAN geht nicht, ein bisschen blöd, muss ich jetzt mein Handy netz benutzen. Punkt. Für die ist einfach, mein Internet geht nicht. Ja, können wir Fabriken im Weltraum die Router herstellen und dann direkt das Internet aus dem Weltraum zu uns senden? Können wir eine einfache Rückfrage stellen, wie kommt das Internet da hoch? Also gibt es vielleicht irgendwo eine Bodenstation, die man nur auch rett und dann bauen müsste? Ach so, ja. Die Hoffnung ist wahrscheinlich, dass es gar nicht mehr dann über… Nur noch im Internet, ja. Ja, dass es keine Berührung mehr zur Erde gibt, damit man an keinen Nationalstand mehr gebunden ist. Das wäre dann wirklich, dass die Wirtschaft tatsächlich die Wirtschaftswelt losgekoppelt vom Primat des Politischen, dass man sagt, wir können auch alle Finanztransfers darüber laufen, da müssen wir null Steuern zahlen. Dann gibt es gar keine Restriktiven mehr. Alles sehr gut. So, jetzt hören wir noch eine halbe Minute Verherrlichung von Elon Musk. Es ist ja so, hier reden nicht einfach irgendwelche Leute. Die haben das ja schon mal, das haben wir hier auch besprochen. Ja, unser YouTube-Video hat ein bisschen weniger Zugriffe. Und dann rufen die direkt bei Google an, in der Chefetage, um das zu klären. Und Google schickt direkt einen Techniker, um zu klären, warum. Und dann wird es genau geklärt. Also es sind Leute, wo einfach klar ist, hallo, ich bin's. Kann ich meinen Chef reden? Und dann geht Sunder Pichai selber ran, weil einfach klar ist, wenn der jetzt nicht ans Telefon geht, rufen die jetzt nichts beim Weißen Haus an. Und sagen, Google hat uns hier zensiert. So, diese Leute reden natürlich so über Elon Musk.
And now you have this incredible corpus of physical capability, movement of all kinds, X, Y and Z, right? You have learning capability, you have infrastructure, you have all the connectivity. That thing will look very cheap, I think, in a few years. And he has this one thing that nobody else, if you look at the big CEOs, who steps on stage where you're always curious, okay, what has he got up his sleeve? You know, the Steve Jobs, oh, and one more thing. This is the only guy at the scale of civilizational out of left field s***. He's the guy. Whether you like him or you hate him, he's the guy. And there's a premium that is well deserved that comes with that.
Ja. Also im Zuge meiner rohen Besuche habe ich natürlich ein bisschen Wikipedia gelesen. Unter anderem zum Thema Sixtinische Kapelle, Deckengemähte. Du kennst es. Und da steht in der Wikipedia der Satz, ja, und er wurde beauftragt vom Papst, das als 30-Jähriger zu malen. Dieses Werk veränderte den Kurs der westlichen Kultur und zählt zu den großen artistic accomplishments of human civilization.
Und ich krieg sofort eine Gänsehaut, weil ich einfach verstehe, was da steht. Wenn er hier sagt, Elon Musk ist der einzige, der im Zivilisationslevel gerade für uns das Schicksal in die Hand nimmt und auf der Bühne noch mal ein Ass aus dem Ärmel schütten können, während alles da niederliegt. Denke ich mir, nee, passt irgendwie nicht so mein Bild. Also ich sehe hier einfach einen Typ, der nach Washington ging, dort USAID gekillt hat. Darauf sind eine halbe Million Menschen gestorben. Niemand hat jemand zur Rechenschaft gezogen. Ein halbes Jahr später kamen Erzählungen, wie diese jungen Typen den Staat kennengelernt haben und meinten, ja, der hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum wir da irgendwie, wir haben halt gesagt, macht's mal aus. Da haben sie USAID ausgeschaltet, Punkt. So, ja. Es ist einfach ein Massenmörder, der immer noch frei rumrennt und irgendwelche Märchen erzählt.
Diese Leute, die wir da hören, das kann sie ja auch sehen in ihrem Podcast bei YouTube, wirken ja auch so enorm traurig, oder? Also ich finde, das ist so ein trauriger Männer Podcast.
Ja, die haben diese AfD-Depression. Ja. Das sind Leute, die eigentlich mitten im Leben stehen.
Und Milliardäre sind.
Genau, aber dann heißt es plötzlich, ja, du hast jetzt einen super geilen Garten, ach was, Gartenfeld. Du wohnst hier in Thüringen, hast dein eigenes Feld und könntest unter deinem Apfelbaum sitzen und einfach einen pflücken und essen. Und dann heißt es, es kommt irgendwie keiner mehr, der für mich die Apfelernte macht, wie solchen, die morgen verkaufen. Aber du hast doch die Ausländer rausgeschickt, die Ausländer sind ja auch blöd, kann es nicht ein Deutscher machen. Ich hasse jetzt nicht nur die Ausländer, jetzt hasse ich auch noch die Deutschen. Ich bin zu tiefst deprimiert, kann die AfD immer was tun. Das ist so die Gedankenfolge. Und diesen Leuten ist nichts zu helfen.
Aber bei All In hat man es ja mit extrem reichen Männern zu tun, die nicht in der Lage sind, ihr Leben zu genießen und diesen extrem traurigen Podcast machen. Das ist ja auch nie lustig oder so. Die sind ja ganz verbittert, sitzen die ja da, hoffen jetzt darauf, dass Elon Musk ihnen irgendeine Freiheit bringt, dass wenn ihnen mal das Internet abstürzt, sie das vom Mars her bekommen. Also das ist ja so trostlos.
Absolut. Es ist, was soll man sagen, enzyklikal ist es.
Ja, also wenn man doch so viel Mittel zur Verfügung hat, man würde doch, also wenn man schon keine Verantwortung für die Gesellschaft übernehmen will, da würde man sich doch wenigstens Spaß rausnehmen. So dass das Bill-Kaulitz-Level nur noch mal richtig skaliert.
Ich glaube, die konsumieren sehr viel in Spaß rein.
Ja.
Und es ist trotzdem nicht.
Es ist dieser leere Dekadent der hedonismus, von dem wir anfangs hörten, als du die Clips aus dem Vatikan spielst.
Es ist der Vatikan, der dich darauf hinweist, dass die Lücken in dem Wunsch, den du von dir selber hast, eigentlich deine Stärke sind. Weil sie der Anlass sind, für andere dir vielleicht zu helfen und ihr dann gemeinsam Sachen macht. Genau hier, wo einfach immer nur, ich hab Durst, ich schreib mal eine Rechnung, wo ist mein Apfelsaft? Wie wäre das in dieser CDF-Doku da über, sehen Sie hier irgendwo einen Orangensaft? Ah nee, stimmt, dann hab ich den doch noch nicht serviert. Problem gelöst. So kann man kein Leben führen. Geld verdirbt wirklich die Lebensfreude.
Wir schauen uns jetzt noch eine neue Ökonomie an, nämlich die Clip-Economie. Devin Nash ist ein YouTuber, der aus dem Marketing kommt und über solche Phänomene, immer mal wieder spricht. Der hat sich was angesehen und zwar, wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass jetzt sehr viele Podcaster und Streamer solche Reichweiten bekommen haben und deren Clips sind überall. Ein Beispiel ist dann Clavicula. Viele werden schon von ihm gehört haben. Das ist der junge Mann, der sich bereits irgendwelche Präparate spritzen lässt, die seine Männlichkeit verstärken sollen, was ihn zwar impotent, aber offenbar sehr männlich gemacht hat. Er bearbeitet seine Knochen im Gesicht mit einem kleinen Hammer, damit er eine bessere Jawline bekommt. Also ein ganz übler Typ ist das, der aber überall viral gegangen ist, tausende Interviews gegeben hat bis hin zu New York Times. Und der ist nur einer von vielen, und wir können ja diese Phänomene auch im Deutschen sehen, dass Leute, die wir nicht kannten, plötzlich mit tausend Clips überall vertreten sind. Wir werden damit bombardiert. Der Podcaster Ben ist ja nur ein Beispiel. Wir haben auch schon jetzt gehört, jemand wie dieser Christian Wolf macht 100 TikTok-Videos am Tag jetzt. Das heißt, er hat ständig jemand dabei, der ihn filmt, irgendwas aus ihm macht. Und vor allem ist es aber bei den Podcastern, die täglich aufnehmen und bei den Twitch-Streamern, die acht Stunden lang am Tag streamen so, dass ja überall diese Clips auftauchen. Und da hat sich etwas verändert. Devin Nash schaut sich das Phänomen an und fragt sich, wer finanziert das eigentlich?
That's short form videos across TikTok, Instagram, and YouTube and X. 69,000 videos that are all about him. How is this possible? Well, he has 1,610 paid clippers that are working full time to put this stuff out on the internet. And likewise, you can see all of these other influencers who, to varying degrees, have the same thing going on. Here's Aidan Ross with 812 clippers. Those that came out this month accumulated about 714 million views.
Wir haben was damit mit Streamern zu tun, die zwischen 10.000 und 70.000 Clips im Monat von sich produzieren lassen. Das heißt, das muss man auch dazu sagen, die erscheinen natürlich nicht einfach auf deren Main-Accounts, sondern man hat jetzt einen Account, macht einen Fan-Account oder was auch immer und dort streut man diese Clips, lädt sie überall hoch, ob als YouTube Short oder Instagram, TikTok und so weiter.
Wir können jetzt jeden Monat nachschauen. Ich gebe dem Ganzen drei Monate, dann ist das completo automatisiert. Bei dem, was Google IO da jetzt vorgestellt wurde, ist das einfach, dieses Business ist jetzt schon tot, wo es uns zu Recht von dir hingelegt wird.
Du hast völlig recht. Wir wissen ja, wie gut jetzt schon Clipping funktionieren könnte mit AI. Jedoch braucht es ja noch Folgendes. Du musst ja einen Account machen, dich möglicherweise jetzt neuerdings auch verifizieren oder musst mehrere Accounts machen, damit diese Clips ja ins Internet gestreut werden. Und das ist natürlich, was die AI jetzt noch nicht macht. Das heißt, die Dinge anfertigen, ich glaube, da wird auch schon sehr viel KI im Einsatz sein. Aber hier brauchst du schon noch die Menschen, die da sind, die sagen, ich mache jetzt 50 Accounts und bestücke die mit Clavicula-Content oder mit irgendwelchen anderen Streamern. Diese Akquise von den Klippern funktioniert häufig über Discord.
The first thing we have to understand is that you start with a central Discord server. Now, there are other ways to do these campaigns. And there are platforms like Vero or Dozlo. One of those has some association with MrBeast. They operate the same way, but as platforms. But for this video, I think the most interesting stuff that we're going to go over is actually just going to be the platforms. So, you can see here, this is the largest clipping server. And you can see that once you get into the clipping server, which I think has over like 20 or 30,000 people in it, you can say, hey, you're just a few steps away from getting paid for post content. Here's how you get started.
Darüber funktioniert diese Clickworker Ökonomie.
Each campaign is going to be one influencer, or a podcaster, or a brand. Typically, for the purposes of this video, we're going to be talking about live streamers. But this is being done for... I sat in these Discord servers, the invite-only ones and as well as like the public ones, for the past like three weeks before making this video. And it shocked pretty much every major podcaster or like brand that you've heard of has had a campaign in these Discord servers in the time that I was sitting in them.
Der Hype ist also gemacht. Wir sind nicht mehr in dem Zeithalter, wo man sagt, da ist was viral gegangen. Komisch, das gucken jetzt alle gerade. Sondern der Hype ist gemacht mit sehr viel Kapitalaufwand. Die Ungleichheit in der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie verändert sich, verstärkt sich also in ganz erheblichen Maße. Es ist so interessant, dass jetzt wir immer so Debatten haben, ja, inwieweit ist Aufmerksamkeit ein Privileg und diese ganzen Diskussionen, die da kommen. Na, man muss jetzt eigentlich mal diese Kapitalseite bedenken. Wie schafft man das eigentlich, so reichweitenstark zu werden? Das kann man natürlich zum einen machen mit Gästen. Ja, also wenn wir jetzt Höcke hier in unserem Podcast einladen, ist auch viel los. Wenn wir sagen, wir laden Höcke und Merkel zusammen ein und die sagen zu, dann ist noch mehr. Ja, das sind aber nur wenige Fälle, mit denen man das quasi schaffen kann auf natürliche Weise.
Diese kleine Pointe müssen wir kurz machen. Wir können natürlich jetzt flapsig sagen, wenn wir Höcke und Merkel einladen. Das Ding ist, die kommen ja nicht. Das ist die eigentliche Sache, die bei Ben entscheidend ist, dass der Höcke da überhaupt hingegangen ist. Also selten war das Medium so sehr die eigentliche Message. Leute haben dann gedacht, jetzt haben sich irgendwie drei Millionen Leute das drei Stunden lang angeschaut. Das ist ja nicht der Punkt, sondern der Höcke ist zu diesem Ben hingegangen. Das ist die Nachricht.
Der fährt nach Köln und geht da ins Studio.
Warum?
Naja, weil er verstanden hat.
Das ist eine rhetorische Frage. Man muss es nicht beantworten. Der Höcke ist halt zu dem Ben gefahren.
Punkt.
Was die dann da berühren.
Was aber auch bedeutet, wenn wir ja von Oliver Pocher gehört haben, wir wissen ja nicht, ob das stimmt und gesagt wird, dass Christian Wolf wohl mit Ben unterstützt hat beim Aufbau dieses Podcasts, ist für mich ja jetzt bei allem die Frage, dass ich so gerade Reichweiten stark angezeigt bekomme. Was heißt das eigentlich, wenn da hohe Klickzahlen sind? Wir haben ja schon gesagt, man kann mit sehr wenig Geld sich YouTube-Klicks kaufen. Also im Sinne von, das wird dann überall als Werbung ausgespielt, Leute klicken drauf und jeder Klick zählt. Und dann kann man sagen, ich habe 100.000 Aufrufe bei meinem Video, auch wenn dann Leute nur drei Sekunden dabei waren. Was ja jetzt stattfindet, ist, dass man durch das Kapital diese Aufmerksamkeit herstellen kann. Das bedeutet also, man kann jetzt sehr gut mit ein bisschen Geld in die Hand nehmen, solche Hypes produzieren, kann aber damit auch einfach eine enorme Verdrängung anstellen. Denn das ist ja auch das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist, dass eine Content-Flut stattfindet, wie wir sie vorher noch nie hatten. Also wir haben einmal das AI-generierte Zeug, aber gerade im Zuge von AI habe ich fast den Eindruck, stehen jetzt viele in so einem Konkurrenzverhalten, zu sagen, ich muss jetzt auch so fleißig werden wie die AI. Das schaffe ich zwar nicht ganz, aber ein bisschen fleißiger könnte ich schon sein. Das führt dann dazu, dass jemand wie Christian Wolf sagt, ich muss jetzt 100 TikTok-Videos machen. Oder dass man sagt bei solchen Streamern, die haben 10.000 Clips im Monat produzieren lassen. Das heißt, um wirklich alles mit dem Content zu fluten, braucht man also Kapital, was sehr bedeutet. Also für die, die in der Nische sind, letztendlich auch wir, wird es immer schwieriger überhaupt, noch wo angezeigt zu werden, dass jemand auf uns zufällig trifft.
Also, ja, das sieht immer so aus. Aber ich meine, das ZDF hat doch vor 15 Jahren schon Marietta Slomka in die Republika gesetzt. Nee, solange ist nicht, ja, vielleicht 10 Jahre. Und die dann dort sagte, ja, ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt überwunden. Wir haben ja echt immer gedacht, wenn ein Tweet viele Sterne hat, ist das wichtig. Und jetzt denke ich mir so, und es ist eine Frage von eben, wo kommt die Viewer her, die drei Millionenfach bei Ben anschauen und nach sieben Sekunden oder wie auch immer wird der Counter eins hochgezählt? Die Antwort ist ganz einfach. Es geht ausschließlich über die Platzierung dieses Videos auf der YouTube-Startseite für die Nutzer. Aber keiner geht zu YouTube und tippt oben die Suche ein. Also es machen ein paar Journalisten, deswegen glauben die alle machen das so. Aber Ben, wie heißt der gleich? Ich bin Bernd Höcke und dann wird das angezeigt. Nein. Und diese Statistiken wird der Ben auch nie veröffentlichen, dass er einfach steht. Ja, die Leute kamen zu 98 Prozent über die allgemeine Empfehlung.
Wenn so viel Kapital aber in die Hand genommen wird, bedeutet das ja eine enorme Raumverdrängung, die stattfindet. Und das sieht man doch schon. Also wenn ich Instagram öffne und ich meine jetzt nicht meinen persönlichen, also den Account, den ich öffentlich betreue, ich habe ja noch einen Account, mit dem ich auch recherchiere. Und da sehe ich ja fast nur noch, dass mir Clips aus Podcasts und all das angezeigt wird. Das heißt und Dinge, die ich nicht höre. Und auch bei dem anderen Account ist es auch zunehmend so. Das heißt, man wird ja flächendeckend zugemüllt mit irgendwelchen Podcasts, die man sonst eigentlich nicht hören würde, mit Content, den man sonst nicht sich ansehen würde, weil jetzt sehr viel Kapital in Bewegung gesetzt wurde, damit es überall verstreut wird. Und das macht es natürlich für jetzt Leute, die zum Beispiel unabhängigen Journalismus machen oder die Nischen-Podcasts machen oder so, enorm schwer, noch irgendwo eine Aufmerksamkeit zu finden, weil jedes größere Medienhaus jetzt auch plötzlich anfängt und sagt, wir machen jetzt 150 Clips von irgendwas und streuen die überall. Und das nimmt ja Aufmerksamkeit weg für andere Sachen. Deswegen kann man immer weniger entdecken, das meine ich.
Ja, stimmt absolut. Aber Laufpublikum ist nicht das einzige Publikum.
Nein, nur für Leute, die jetzt anfangen. Wir haben ja auch glücklicherweise ein Publikum, das einfach da ist, das nicht jetzt eingefangen werden muss. Aber um entdeckt zu werden, wird es immer schwieriger. Es sei denn, man macht dieses Spiel mit. Wir hören mal hier weiter. Sonst würden die das ja nicht so obsessiv betreiben.
Es gibt auch Mund zu Mund im Sinne von, ich habe in meinem Lieblingspodcast etwas gehört, das kannte ich noch gar nicht, denn es tauchte nirgendwo in meinen Feeds auf.
Ja.
So, dieses Phänomen gibt es auch.
Ich will dir auch gar nicht davor hören, dass es das nicht auch gibt. Ich sehe nur, dass der Markt jetzt gerade sich woandershin entwickelt.
Aber schon immer bestand, also es ist einfach eine andauernde ewige Wahrheit, 90 Prozent des Publikums sind Laufpublikum. Ob es am Kiosk vorbeiläuft in den 80ern und da liegt eine Zeitung oder sonstiges wie auch immer. Aber das eigentliche Medienverhalten von Leuten ist nicht nur Laufpublikumsverhalten, sondern auch Idioten bleiben ihren Sachen treu.
Aber du bist ja jemand, der sich viel kritischer in letzter Zeit geäußert hat zu den Kurzvideos in den sozialen Medien als ich das tue. Deswegen will ich ja eigentlich dir zur Seite springen und sagen, ja es ist interessant, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt hat, dass also diese Clipisierung, das ist, was jetzt vordergründig der Fall ist und darauf stößt man auch überhaupt auf Dinge, wie zum Beispiel auf jemanden wie Clavicula. Werden wir ohne diese Millionen Clips gar nicht gestoßen. Wir hören mal ein anderes Beispiel.
So, this is a campaign for Caleb Hammer. And you may be seeing a lot of his clips. And this is a separate Discord server that's been created. You can see the payout for Caleb is 75 cents per 1000 views. That there's a minimum view required for payout. And that there's a payment method. And it shows you the platforms that it wants you to post on. So you can post on TikTok, you can post on Instagram, you can post on Twitter, you can post on X, in this case. So there's an example of a pretty prominent podcaster. Now either it's his agency paying for this or it's him, I don't know.
Das weiß man dann auch nicht. Wer zahlt da eigentlich für was? Oder wir können das ja auch zum Beispiel sehen bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen Podcasts, dass die auch extrem viele Clips anfertigen, von ihren Inhalten und immer wieder neu aufbreiten und aufspielen. Und das bedeutet ja was. Also das verdrängt sehr viel von dem anderen. Das muss man ganz klar sehen. Wie wird das eigentlich bezahlt?
Most of this stuff is very well put together. I mean by pretty elite operators. And it seems to be pretty above board. I mean the Clippers get paid. And they get paid a base CPM, which you saw from Caleb's campaign that I listed here. And then they also get to keep the RPM, which means the money the platform itself pays you. So, you get both the CPM, which is like the 75 cents per 1,000, that gets paid out through the campaign. And then you also get to earn whatever the YouTube short or the real actually makes off of the ad revenue just off of the platform. So, this ends up being a pretty good deal for like second and third world people, which are kind of the majority of people that are participating in this system.
Es gibt eine doppelte Bezahlung. Einmal indem man den Auftrag annimmt, 70 Cent vielleicht pro 1,000 Klicks, die man erzielen kann. Zusätzlich, wenn man beispielsweise YouTube Shorts macht auf dem Kanal, dann kann man das auch monetarisieren mit Werbung. Dann gibt es ja nochmal ein paar Zents. Was hat das jetzt aber schätzungsweise, man weiß natürlich nicht genau, Clavicula gekostet, so viele Klicks anfertigen zu lassen?
The math on it is it would cost $666,371 a month, even at $1 CPM, just to run Clav's campaign alone, not even considering all these other people. So, literally hundreds of thousands, if not millions of dollars, are being spent every month to do this.
Also, wir haben das ja in Deutschland auch, ich nenne jetzt kurz News, aber es gibt auch andere, kleinere, größere, wie auch immer, wo die Rechnung einfach so aussieht, ein mit zehn oder irgendwelche Leute, die was wollen, bezahlen, sagen wir mal, 20 Millionen Euro im Jahr. Sagen dann, ein bisschen Revenue müsst ihr machen, dann sagen die, wir machen ein Abo-Modell und es spielt dann 200.000 ein. Also, ein Prozent. Und dann gilt das als Erfolg bei diesen Leuten. Was bedeutet, jenseits der ökonomischen Handlungsfähigkeit, gibt es Menschen, die das auf Biegen und Brechen, die kosten es, was sie wollen, einfach machen, damit es so etwas wie News gibt. Darüber finde ich, deswegen diese Zahlennennung sehr gut, muss man unbedingt aufklären. Also, wenn ihr News oder was auch immer, Video gesehen habt, da ist richtig Geld reingeflossen.
Damit das bei euch ankommt.
Also, richtig Geld reingeflossen. Da hat jemand einen Euro bewegt, damit du im Treppenhaus kurz fünf Sekunden Julian Reichel ziehst. Und dann entdeckt das relativ zügig. So, man würde da nicht, ah ja, jetzt soll ich noch dazu mich verhalten.
Das ist jetzt dein aufgeklärter Umgang damit, aber den finden wir ja leider nicht, diesen aufgeklärten Umgang, sondern der verstärkt sich ja noch da. Wir hatten ja sogar jetzt, wo war das? In der Tagesschau, dass da News eingeblendet wurde als Quelle.
Ja, das war natürlich sehr dramatisch.
Um zu zeigen, viele sind sauer über die Regierung von Friedrich Merz.
Das war wirklich News, Bild und Fokus. Ja, prima. Um zu zeigen, es gibt da auch Leute, die es anders sehen. Da denke ich mir, das ist jetzt wirklich nicht die Pflicht, heute schon als oder das Tagesthemen, mich darüber aufzuklären. Dass es da Leute gibt, die eine andere Meinung haben.
Jetzt sehen wir 600.000 Euro im Monat werden da ausgegeben, um Clips zu machen. Was auch bedeutet, das ist ja Elon Maske im Kleinen. Elon Maske hat einfach das Geld gehabt zu sagen, ich kaufe jetzt Twitter.
Den ganzen Clip-Apparat, ja.
Dann habe ich alles. Das können die jetzt nicht, die mit irgendwelchen komischen Energy-Food reich geworden sind oder mit irgendwelchen Kryptobörsen. Die können aber sagen, ja, ich kaufe mir mal so fünf Podcaster. Beziehungsweise, da sind fünf Podcaster, die gefallen mir eigentlich ganz gut. Jetzt gebe ich denen jeden Monat 50.000 für Ads und Clipping. Und dann kann es losgehen. Und dann haben die diese Reichweiten. Womit ich ja sagen will, wir wissen ja, wie diese Plattformen funktionieren, was wird einem empfohlen. Es geht ja nicht um die YouTube-Startseite, sondern bei Spotify, bei Apple oder sonst wo. Und da sehe ich ja auch, da werden mir ständig Dinge empfohlen, die ich mir nicht empfehlen würde und die du mir auch nicht empfehlen würdest. Und das ist ja doch ganz erstaunlich, weil ich ja nicht wenig Zeit darauf verbringe, wo man dann eigentlich sagen würde, warum wird einem das angezeigt? Naja, weil dann plötzlich so ein Rand darauf ist, dass man sagt, es muss wohl alle interessieren. Was sagt Clavicula dazu? Da erfahren wir dann, wer gibt das Geld eigentlich aus?
One of the fastest come-ups in streaming, absolutely. Why do you think you're the fastest growing creator in the world right now? I think I have a lot of strategies that are good for viral clipping engagement. I think Kik has helped push me a lot with their clipping budget. So, you know, over six figures a month.
Das heißt, KIK, also diese Alternativplattform zu Twitch, zahlt selbst, und da gibt es auch sehr viele Beispiele, die Devin Nash auch zeigt, die zahlt selbst das Geld dafür, dass geklippt wird auf anderen Plattformen, die Videos erscheinen, dann nur das Logo von KIK drin ist, damit die Leute wissen, das ist die Plattform, wo ich eigentlich mehr davon haben kann. Was jetzt Devin Nash klarmacht, ist, das Volumen ist plötzlich das Entscheidende. Wir haben, sagen wir, auch noch vor 3, 4 Jahren vor allem darüber gesprochen, wer kann viral gehen mit irgendetwas. Und bei TikTok hat man dann gesehen, das geht noch mal sogar aus dem Stand. Jetzt aber ist die neue algorithmische Entwicklung, dass man sagt, wir versuchen dem Algorithmus einfach mit Volumen dazu zu bringen, dass irgendwann Klavicula wichtig ist oder andere wichtig werden.
They are uploading so many clips. And the volume is so much. That it's just telling the algorithm, hey, you should talk about this person nonstop. This is the most important thing in the world. So, what is so crazy about this. And this is like the, this is the nuttiest thing about this video. Like it's just not an exaggeration that content creation isn't about being interesting or engaging anymore.
Das ist ja auch etwas, was man vielfach jetzt sehen kann. Ich bekomme Clips angezeigt, Aber bei denen gar nichts mehr interessantes passiert. Also das eine ist ja zu clippen jetzt wie nur der Koch, der schaut sich eine ganze Talkshow an und dann bringt er uns die 90 Sekunden mit, die wir uns mal alle ansehen sollten. Aber was ich zunehmend bei den Clips sehe, ist, dass nur noch geklippt wird, damit man irgendeinen Clip wieder hat. So eine ganz kurze Reaktion, reicht schon irgendeinen Satz, einen Halbsatz. Es muss schon gar nicht mehr eine Pointe sein. Ich meine, es gibt auch diese Clips, den Karl Lagerfeld, Markus Lanzow Sprüche entgegen schleudert. Sowas ist es ja gar nicht mehr. Sondern es ist nur noch die Masse, die es dann macht. Ed Elson, den wir eben schon gehört haben zum Thema SpaceX, hat sich diesem Thema auch angenommen. Er hat einen Artikel geschrieben, der heißt The Clip Economy. Er stellt ihn im Podcast von The Atlantic vor und sagt, Yes, it is increasingly becoming a volume game.
You could have an incredibly insightful, thoughtful article. I mean, this is what you guys do over The Atlantic every day. Incredibly smart people with incredibly great ideas. If you're not clipping that up and giving it to people in bite-sized little shoots of information, the way that they are consuming information today, which is through their phones and online, scrolling on social media, scrolling on TikTok, scrolling on Instagram, etc.
Ja, wir kennen diese Art der Clipproduktion, die wir überall jetzt sehen. Das muss verbreitet werden. Dabei hat Ed Elston selbst festgestellt, er wird auf der Straße angesprochen, wird erkannt. Und die sagen, find das Zeug toll, was du machst. Und dann sagt er, ah ja, hörst du den Podcast? Und dann sagt er, nee, aber ich sehe so viele Clips von dir.
So we looked at the average concurrent views across these live streamers shows. For Hasan Piker, it was around 30,000. For Nick Fuentes, it was around 20,000. For Clivikula, it was even less than that. It was about 16,000. That is not a big number for a lot of these shows. And yet that is the average for their concurrent views. And then you look at the clip viewership. And we just looked at a small sample size because there have been a lot of clips. But for Hasan Piker, the average was above 700,000 views. For Nick Fuentes, the average was above half a million views. For Clivikula, it was a quarter of a million. I looked back at one of Nick Fuentes' most recent clips. It reached 11 million people.
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Rechnung so richtig aufgeht. Also was er ja machte, ist, er schaut sich einen Livestream an, sieht dann, ha, da sehen gerade 16.000 Menschen zu. Und dann schaut er sich an, wie die Clips im Durchschnitt wirken, kommt dann auf hunderttausende. Diese Diskrepanz, die da entsteht, ist ja zunächst einmal natürlich. Wir wissen, dass in einem Livestream Leute zuschauen, aber nicht in solchen extremen Höhen. Also es sitzen nicht drei Millionen Menschen vor einem Livestream, es sei denn, das ist gar der Olympische Spieder oder so etwas.
Also wir wissen ja, dass ein TikTok-Clip im Durchschnitt 0,3 Sekunden geschaut wird. So, einfach direkt aussortieren. Der gilt natürlich dann trotzdem als geschaut. Jetzt können wir das mal auf die analoge Welt übertragen und fragen, ist das wirklich so neu? Ich habe letztens mit jemandem geredet, der hat so ein kleines Startup für so Bonbons. Und er hat einen Wettbewerb gewonnen, den Rewe ausgeschrieben hat. Seine Bonbons werden jetzt in 600 Reves an der Kasse platziert. Das ist also millimetergenau ausgemessen, wo das dann hinkommt und so. Und dann hast du einfach die Chance, dich da zu bewähren. Was ja bedeutet, diese Räume sind einfach kapitalistisch erschlossen. Leute gehen die ganze Zeit an Supermarktregalen vorbei und sehen das immer gleiche Kelloggs irgendwas und so. Dann sitzen irgendwelche Leute da bei Kelloggs und versuchen durch eine ganz kleine Veränderung in der Farbnoance doch nochmal andere Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen, wie auch immer so. Aber im Grunde ist das halt immer dasselbe. Man könnte jetzt auch in der analogen Welt einfach durchzählen. Also wirklich jeden Blickkontakt, wie man es bei TikTok wieder machen kann, durchzählen auf. Okay, wir haben jetzt zumindest schon mal die Aufmerksamkeit pro, da läuft jemand das Regal entlang und guckt, was es gibt, von 0,03 auf 0,09 erhöht. Bald sind wir bei 0,1 Sekunden Aufmerksamkeitsdauer. Und wir wissen, bei 0,17 greifen sie auch mal zu. So funktioniert das hier. Das machen wir im typischen analogen Welt nicht. Sie wünschen sich das alle, dass man das so machen könnte. Nun, das findet bei TikTok statt. Von daher finde ich das auch nicht verkehrt, dass jemand wie Ed Elson, der einen täglichen Podcast macht, zu den Marketvitals, natürlich immer auf der Suche ist, nach so Scoop-Themen und so weiter und so fort. Also, dass er jetzt hier beim Clippen so da reinspringt. Aber wir haben es halt hier mit einer extremen Verkennzifferung und Datenanalyse zu tun, die einfach möglich ist. Während mir ich denke, naja, wenn ich selber Instagram gucke, ich sitze wirklich nur da mit einem Gehirn auf 3% Leistungsfähigkeit und gehe durch Instagram. Also, so relevant das alles ist. Aber es ist auch wahnsinnig albern, dass irgendwer, irgend wem, eine halbe Million pro Monat dafür zahlt, weil ich so Instagram benutze.
Das funktioniert ja nur ganz kurz.
Ich schalte ja mein Gehirn dann wieder ein nach sieben Minuten und sage, und jetzt höre ich den Podcast, den ich die ganze Zeit schon hören wollte. Und dann höre ich den ja auch. Und da läuft ja was ganz anderes dann.
Nur, stelle ich zum Beispiel fest, gibt es Leute, die ich regelmäßig in Clips sehe und auch deren Beiträge wahrnehme und noch nie deren eigentliches Format gehört habe. Das ist etwas, was Ed Elson ja da auch erzählt. Also hast du jemals von einem Hasan Piker Stream gesessen? Hast du dir vier Stunden lang Hasan Piker Stream angesehen? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Siehst du aber laufend Clips von ihm? Wahrscheinlich schon. Also Hasan Piker, für die, die ihn nicht kennen, so ein linker Twitch-Streamer.
Ich sehe lauter Zeug auf Instagram, bei dem ich nicht weiß, von wann ist das, von wo ist das. Es steht keine Zeit, keine Ortsmarke, kein Nichts.
Ja, nur die, was ja so interessant ist, ich hörte auch, dass ja diese Clips irgendwann bei Spotify kommen sollen. Was heißt, diese Verklippung wird ja weitergehen.
Ja, die Enchilification. Also wenn ich meinen Spotify ausmache, würde ich plötzlich Fitness-Training kriege ich angeboten.
Prima.
Seit gestern.
Super.
Läuft einfach so ein Fitness-Video.
Vielleicht wissen die was, was du nicht weißt. Jedenfalls geht es ja immer mehr in die Richtung. Ich habe den Eindruck, um sich überhaupt dem zu erwehren, geht es eigentlich nur, dass man bewusst sagt, man entscheidet sich für lange Formate und hört die in aller Ruhe.
Absolut.
So, also es geht nur so, dass das andere fühlt sich in die Irre.
Also es gilt Adam Toos, ne? Wie Herr Toos kann ich mir eine Vorrangstellung erarbeiten. Einfach lesen.
Kommen wir gleich dazu.
Einfach mal ein bisschen länger lesen.
Ja, Punkt.
Wir hören nochmal, wer ist eigentlich der Erfinder dieses Clippings? Also im Sinne von, jetzt macht aus Mainstreams einfach 1000 Clips. Wir ahnen es, Andrew Tate.
So, I don't purport to know how he figured it out. But he figured it out and he was the first one to figure it out. And he did that in 2021. And that is he created this community that he called Hustlers University. And he said that this was going to be, if you want to escape the matrix, which is sort of tagline, then join Hustlers University and I'll teach you how to do it. And what happened when you join Hustlers University, is he gave you instructions and he said, watch my live stream and use these clipping tools. And I want you to clip up as many segments of my live stream as you can possibly imagine. I want you to get up on social media, create a social media account that is related to Andrew Tate and Husses University. I want you to post as many clips as humanly possible from those accounts.
Ja.
Wollen wir auch die Neue Zwanziger Akademie eröffnen?
Nein, das gibt es ja seit fünf Jahren. Es ist auch immer erstaunlich, wie kurz das eigentlich immer alles ist. Ich würde ja sagen, diese Verschort-Videorisierung hat uns schon komplett doof gemacht. Jetzt kommt noch KI oben drauf. Keiner weiß mehr überhaupt, was man da tut so.
Ja und deshalb sehe ich ja durch diese Schwämme, dass alle gerade so im Getriebe sind und sagen, sollte ich nicht vielleicht doch sieben Podcasts am Tag aufnehmen und 80.000 Clips daraus machen. Also gerade jetzt so diese Vertiefung, die wird ja immer weniger. Das längere wird eigentlich entweder ausgeweitet, so dann streept man den ganzen Tag rund um die Uhr. Aber eigentlich so die Vertiefung ist etwas, was jetzt gerade sehr erheblich angegriffen wird.
Das ist alles Wall-E.
Schon, ja.
Wir kommen in diese Wall-E-Welt.
Letztes Beispiel hier von Ed Elson.
And this guy, there's a live stream of this guy called Neon. And I was looking at his live stream recently and he revealed on his live stream, how much he pays his clippers each month. He's talking with someone. And this young woman asks him, wait, so how much do you pay them? And he's kind of playing a guessing game. And he finally reveals the answer. He pays his clippers one million dollars a month to post clips of his content all throughout the internet.
Ja, also skeptisch sein, wenn man irgendwo viele Clips findet von jemandem, wenn es über den eigenen Kanal hinausgeht, dann würde ich sagen, passiert da ganz viel mit sehr viel Kapital, das mobilisiert wird. Wir müssen zum Ende kommen.
Ja, ich hab noch einen Clip im Angebot. Du hast auch noch einen.
Ich hab auch noch einen, aber ich glaube, deiner ist der vorletzte. Okay.
Also, ein wahlloses Thema Organspende. Es wird gerade wieder diskutiert und mir ist eine Sache, die ich so beim Zuhören, wo ich dachte, ah ja, also wenn das jetzt gilt, bin ich total dafür, ja. Also mir geht es jetzt nicht um die Organspende, es wird nur ein Prinzip vorgestellt.
Heute kam die Gegenrede einer weiteren fraktionsübergreifenden Gruppe. Sie will, dass es in Deutschland bei der sogenannten Entscheidungslösung bleibt. Das heißt, wer Organspender sein will, muss zu Lebzeiten ausdrücklich zustimmen, legt keine Erklärung vor, haben die Angehörigen das letzte Wort. Chris Predow berichtet.
Eines möchte die grünen Gesundheitspolitikerin Kirsten Kappert-Gonther gleich zu Beginn klarstellen. Sie und ihre Mitstreiter wissen um das Problem. Um die rund 8.000 Menschen, die in Deutschland auf einen Spenderorgan warten und um die rund 1.000, die jedes Jahr sterben, weil es kein Organ für sie gibt.
Unsere Gruppe ist dezidiert für Organspende. Wir sind der Auffassung, jedes Spenderorgan rettet potenziell Leben.
Die Frage sei aber, darf Schweigen als Zustimmung gelten, in der so wichtigen Frage, ob man nach seinem Tod Organe spenden möchte.
Und da sagen wir nein.
So.
Was machst du jetzt daraus?
Schweigen als Zustimmung ist…
Nein, sagt sie.
Ja. Schweigen als Zustimmung ist der Modus operandi unserer ganzen modernen Welt.
Ja.
So machen wir Rentenpolitik, so machen wir Gesundheitspolitik, so machen wir Verkehrspolitik, so machen wir Mietpolitik. Ich habe nie zugestimmt, dass meine Miete doppelt so hoch ist, wie sie sein muss. Ich habe auch nicht zugestimmt, dass meine Miete nur halb so hoch ist, wie sie sein müsste. Dass die Autos ständig im Bahnhofsviertel rumfahren, weil irgendwer einen Parkplatz sucht, ich habe da auch nicht zugestimmt. Ich habe nicht zugestimmt, als es hieß, die Bahn fährt jetzt nur noch für diese und jene Preise und das ist der Fahrplan. So, also ich bin sehr dafür. Klar, die Organspender sind super scheiße. Wir haben gehört, 8.000 Leute, also jeder Zehntausendste in Deutschland braucht ein Organ. Aber warum sollte man das jetzt nicht mal verallgemeinern? Also wenn Schweigen als Zustimmung nicht reicht, bin ich dafür, dass wir das Grundgesetz neu schreiben. Artikel 2, Schweigen als Zustimmung reicht nicht.
Bin sehr gespannt, wie der Vorschlag aufgefasst wird. Zum Schluss möchte ich noch das Lesen heraufbeschwören, denn wir haben jetzt eben von diesen fürchterlichen Clips gehört, dass dort man zum Beispiel vom Lesen abgehalten wird. Das Lesen ist aber noch viel mehr. Peter Sloterdijk war zu Gast bei Arte, wurde dort von einem französischen Moderator befragt und das leitet uns eigentlich ganz gut zum Salon über, nämlich zu der Tätigkeit, die wir dann, nachdem wir den Podcast jetzt aufgenommen haben, wieder ausüben. Wir lesen nämlich Bücher. Was bedeutet das für uns als Menschheit? Wir haben also Gelegenheiten, uns mit Drohnen zu beschießen. Wir könnten aber auch lesen.
Sie sagen, das wirksamste Mittel der Domestikation sei die Lektüre, die Literatur. Aber warum?
Weil ich sage, in der Gutenberg-Ära gibt es nichts, was so zivilisierend und domestizierend wirkt, wie die Tatsache, dass Menschen vor einem bedruckten Blatt Papier ruhig halten und sozusagen den Anblick der Welt durch den Anblick der gedruckten Buchseite ersetzen. Und ich finde, das ist die eigentliche Kultivierung des Menschen. Wenn der Mensch zum Leser wird, dann ist im Grunde das Schlimmste schon überstanden.
Absolut, das ist die, das ist das Argument der Gutenberg-Paranthese. Wir stürzen gerade zurück ins Mitteleiterliche, indem wir unsere Sachen zu rufen, eine Meinung haben. Aber die gilt nur für jetzt gerade morgens schon wieder anders.
Scheinst so zu sein, ruhig dazusitzen, zu lesen. Das werden wir tun und dann darüber sprechen. Da geht es natürlich dann weiter. Im Salon sprechen wir zum einen über öffentliche Kunstfreiheit von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Die beiden Autoren beschäftigen sich damit. Wie sieht es aus mit der Kunstfreiheit in Deutschland und vor allem, wie ist damit umzugehen, wenn es sich um staatlich geförderte Kunst handelt? Stichwort Dokumenta, Berlinale und andere Vorfälle. Außerdem diskutieren wir im Salon über ein weiteres Buch von Arne Semshort, ein Autor, den wir schon zu schätzen gelernt haben, mit seinem Buch Machtübernahme. Da ja, skizzierte er, wie es aussehen würde, wenn die AfD regiert. Die regiert aber noch nicht. Deswegen gilt es, Gegenmacht aufzubauen. Und so heißt sein Buch.
Ja, ich möchte einen Text hier mal ausführlich kurz benennen, dass ich ihn lese, weil ich leider jetzt nicht zugekommen bin, obwohl Sebastian, der ihn geschrieben hat, wir sprachen schon darüber, seine Bachelor Arbeit in München. Ich wollte das eigentlich zusammenbinden mit einer Argumentation zum Thema, warum sage ich so oft über Wande und Einflugschneise? Weil dieser, und das ist jetzt, passt perfekt zu Sloterdijk, weil der direkte Blick auf die Welt gar nichts hilft. Wir brauchen eine Zyklika, die uns geschrieben wird und die wir dann ausgedruckt oder auf digitalem Papier, aber eben im Austausch der Welt lesen. Sebastian hat also eine Bachelorarbeit geschrieben zum Thema Herrn Hegemon. Narrative Hegemonie. Und er macht darin wirklich ganz tolle Analysen, und zwar ganz ohne Luhmann. Ich würde sagen, mit Luhmann kriegt man das nochmal abgelevelt. Er kommt mit Habermas und Foucault, wo ich denke, das kann man auch machen. Er schreibt aber selber mitten im Text so, hier und da sind Begrenzungen, weil es ja nur eine Bachelorarbeit. Also in der Hinsicht würde ich auch sagen, Bestärkung hier von der Seite. Das kann man auch mal mit Luhmann nochmal richtig aufgreifen. Und es werden uns drei Sachen aufgeschlüsselt, die auch sehr gut zu deinem Verklippungsargument passen. Denn es war nicht nur Andrew Taylor, das war auch Charlie Kirk. Und in dieser Arbeit hier von Sebastian wird ins Detail gegangen, wie das bei Charlie Kirk gelang. Er nimmt sich, glaube ich, 19 Clips, die alle für sich mehr als jeweils 20 Millionen Views hatten. Also wir reden von einer richtig riesigen Reichweite, die Diskursbestimmend war. Bis hin zu, jetzt wird Donald Trump gewählt und so weiter, der ganze, wir kennen ja den Circus, ja. Wir kriegen also Aufklärung über die narrative Hegemonie, wie sie schon im Titel steht, über simulierte Diskurse. Jemand im Hintergrund bringt Geld rein und schafft damit den Arenenübertritt. Also man kauft sich für Geldaufmerksamkeit und so. Und dann auch Selbstinstitutionalisierung. Wie hat Charlie Kirk das geschafft, selber wieder als eine Institution zu gelten, die danach noch verherrlicht wird als, wir haben ja den Text von der New York Times kurz angesprochen, selbst Israel Klein sagt, er hat Politik richtig gemacht. So. Und es wird hier einfach ganz wunderbar aufgeschlüsselt. Und ich sag's auch deswegen hier öffentlich im Salon, weil ich das für vorbildhaft halte, wie Sebastian auch im Gespräch mit mir, aber auch mit seinen Professoren, rätselte, ja, wie geh ich jetzt mit dieser Bachelorarbeit um, bring ich die zu irgendeinem Verlag, blablabla und so. Und ich so, mach doch deine Webseite wie auch immer. Und dann hat er genau den richtigen Weg gefunden. Also sie ist auf dem Open Access-Kanal der LMU München veröffentlicht und auf seiner privaten Webseite verlinkt. discourssebi.de So, keine Clips, kein Föllefanz, sondern eine einfach nachvollziehbare URL, wo alle seine Kontaktdaten draufstehen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann kann man da einfach diese Arbeit lesen, wenn man es noch schafft, sie vor sich zu halten und im Austausch gegen die Welt einfach mal einen sehr modernen Text von einem sehr jungen Autor, den wir viel Erfolg wünschen bei der weiteren Forschung und so weiter. Das heißt, den Text, den wir im neuen Salon vorgehen, gehen wir natürlich durch.
Also, Christoph Möllers, Nils Weinberg, Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit und Gegenmacht von Arne Semsroth. Das sind die beiden Bücher, die wir ausführlich miteinander diskutieren. Und dann gibt es, wie immer von uns, Literaturhinweise. Ihr könnt uns abonnieren, unterstützt damit diesen Podcast. Geht damit ein bisschen aus der Welt der Clips raus. Jetzt geht es hier in die Vertiefungen. Also, das ist möglich über Patreon, wenn man schon dort ist, oder Apple, wenn man es gerne bequem hat. Aber wir präferieren und empfehlen Steady www.neuezwanziger.de. Das ist die Homepage, die Stefan zusammen mit einem Dutzend KIs erstellt hat. Und dort findet man den goldenen Salon-Button. Klickt man auf diesen, kann man diesen Podcast, den Zusatzinhalt ganz einfach abonnieren. Vielen Dank für die Unterstützung und einen guten Monat.
Bis nächste Woche.